[Music]
o
oo o
[Music]
e
e e
[Music]
C
n
[Music]
oh
hello hello welcome everyone to stage
four today we're going to be talking
about account
abstraction our first speaker is named
something
something thank
[Music]
you oh but will I have the the title or
no no I have it on my phone okay
Dan so our first Speaker of the day is
Danielle yanev Danielle is the CEO and
co-founder of rhino fi and the talk is
called the age of account abstraction
opportunities and challenges Danielle
will delve into the transformative
impact of making web3 seamless and
accessible and help us understand how to
navigate and thrive in this evolving
landscape welcome to the stage Danielle
yanev
[Music]
w o
questions and next up on the stage
is next speaker is blah blah
blah okay
perfect so I I end the Q&A and at the
same time I announce the next speaker
yes perfect
y
e
e e
[Music]
n
look Rock
[Music]
o oh
for
[Music]
T 1 2
T Test one 2 3 test test one 2
3 test one 2 3 test
test test test one 2 3 test one test 1 1
2 3 4 5 6 7
8 test test testing one 2 T Test one 2
3 test 1 2 3
4 test 1 2 3 4 testing 1 2 3 4 testing 1
2 3 4 test test 1 2 3 test one 2 3
[Music]
back
you
[Music]
he
a
[Music]
o
oh
[Music]
we will be starting in 10 minutes 10
minutes to go time
[Music]
a
m
[Music]
B
oo o
[Music]
o
oh
[Music]
o
got
[Music]
m
n
[Music]
w
o
[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to day three
of Devcon you're here bright and early I
can see how are you feeling everything
good yeah all right so we're g to have a
set of lightning talks about chain
abstraction and account
abstraction and our first speaker is
Danielle yanev Danielle is the CEO and
co-founder of rhino DOI and the talk is
called the age of account abstraction
opportunities and challenges so Danielle
will delve into the transformative
impact of making web 3 seamless and
accessible and help us understand how to
navigate and thrive in this evolving
landscape please welcome to the stage
Danielle
[Music]
yanev uh hi everyone um my name is danev
co-founder and CEO of rifi um and yeah
today I'm going to talk to you about
account abstraction and some of the
challenges and opportunities that that
brings uh we only have 5 minutes so uh
let's get uh let's get right into it um
we would have uh heard a lot about kind
abstraction at this conference uh so I'm
not going to repeat a lot of that but
just to recap kind of what we're trying
to achieve um as a basis for this talk
uh where we aming to get to with chain
abstraction is that users are oblivious
to what chain they're transacting on um
that's completely removed from the from
the from the ux they don't care is call
S the credit card
experience um and the second Str we're
making is that users get the best
execution of what they want to do if I
want to buy e with usdt I can assume
that I'm going to get uh the best the
best price for that but what do we have
today uh today we have daps which were
deployed on multiple chains often in a
messy way for example a is on 13
different blockchains that you need to
kind of choose from the UI connect
different wallets and so on um l2s and
chains have direct consumer power so
there are these kind of strong Brands
like let's say bass scroll arbitrum and
they attract consumers directly in in
different ways um and the ecosystems can
be quite separate either ideologically
or in ux so for example a Solana user
might find using an ethereum L2 very
strange um and and vice
versa um but uh as we have heard a lot
about this week there are a lot of
Technologies coming which are which are
going to uh to change this and bring us
closer to to that dream state now I
think that's going to have some some
consequences um and the way we can think
about it is uh pre kind of inter pre-
internet and pre Amazon uh you could
have had a like let's say an electronic
store in a town um and all the towns
would be would be separate and your
store has a captive audience the people
in this town rise so you could afford to
run a crappy store like your store could
be a bit expensive it could not be very
good and people would still come to it
because really have choice now when
Amazon comes along and people now have
access to the same amazing Marketplace
um running a crappy store becomes quite
difficult right like you can't you can't
attract um users anymore you're
competing with kind of the best uh the
best from all around not just in your
town and I think something similar is
going to happen uh with the different L2
uh ecosystems um that once users have
access to the best uh protols and so on
on kind equal footing the ones which are
not the best are are really going to
suffer uh that's going to cause a few
effects uh the first one is the kind of
winner take all liquidity what I mean by
that is that um we have a virtuous cycle
uh that reinforces and makes the best
products the best and the worst products
even worse uh let's say again in our
example we want to buy eth with usdt our
order gets rooted to the most liquid
pool um and that happens with uh kind of
all the orders um now that generates
more fees for the LPS in that pool more
LPS go into that pool it becomes even
more liquid and so so uh the wheel goes
and that
attracts um everything um and so you
know the the top like let's say a few
pools for this for this pair maybe get
used the bottom ones will get no uh
we'll get no uh flow whatsoever so that
brings to the next point that like
duplication is L having the same pool
and the same protocol or a fork of it
deployed on 20 chains um or multiple
times on the same chain uh makes no
sense and it will make even less sense
um in this um in this world now that
sounds a bit uh threatening a lot of a
lot of our ecosystems are duplications
in Forks uh right now um however there
is also an upside to that uh which is
this uniqueness is rewarded uh if you
build a Dap or uh a protocol that adds
value to the ecosystem it will now be
exposed to the whole ecosystem not just
this chain but all the ones which are
which are connected to it so if you
bring if you build something of value it
will be uh exposed to a much bigger
audience uh regardless of what else
happens on this particular chain you no
longer need to have kind of Primitives
on each chain um which brings to my next
point that
um up in this in this situation if we
think about uh that a unique use case is
what brings value to the chain the kind
of value of this chain and the value of
this protocol converge so we could
see um the kind of app chain thesis um
coming back that you only need one good
use case on a chain to uh to make it
successful uh so we could see uh each
use case having um having its own chain
for example
you know if we here created a layer two
and the only thing on it was we
integrated uh taibat payments um now
that could be integrated into the rest
of uh the l2s and so they could access
that and we could have nothing else on
this chain so the the use case in the
chain um converge so uh we're just uh
wrapping up now so I guess the whole
point uh of what I'm trying to say is uh
many of you may be uh Founders Builders
uh maybe
investors um Don't Waste Your Precious
time and energy building Forks of of
things um if you have that voice going
in your head like oh let's do another
Unis swap fork with a token on this new
chain and we'll make loads of money shut
that down shut it down and do something
that matters because you'll be rewarded
more than ever because this uh this
mechanic makes sure that like unique
things that add value get exposed to the
whole ecosystem um immediately so you'll
be rewarded more than ever for it um
yeah thank you and I think now we're
going to take some uh questions yes
thanks a lot Danielle all right so we're
gonna do the questions with the catchbox
if you're familiar with it I'm just
going to throw it to you you're going to
speak into the box and that's how we're
going to do it so raise your hand if you
have any questions and we'll get the box
to
you come on I yes amazing so get ready
and
catch okay um so you talk about unique
um daps on chains have you got any
examples where this is already kind of
bearing
fruit um yeah so I think we can see
examples of some chains that have
managed to like build a m because of um
difficult to copy um Mechanics for
example Tron uh which you know you know
we're Devcon uh it's not an evm chain
but Tron has a very big network of
payment service providers um which has
made it very useful in a lot of emerging
economies and now although Tron is
expensive and kind of out of fashion and
all is modern and like other chains are
poised to kind of steal their uses that
uh in that that network of PSPs is
difficult to replicate so they have a
mode and and that has use and I think
we're going to see something similar
happened with uh coinbase base and ink
from Kraken being very efficient on
ramping um rails because they have um
the kind of relationships with the with
the banks and payments providers that
other chains might not have and that's
something that will be difficult to to
replicate um and and compete
with all right I saw another question
over here can you get the the box to
this person
perfect uh yeah my questions is that I
think liquidity definitely is the key
here what are some of the best is our
strategies has worked to basically
tracking liquidity to the
CHF yeah so in terms of um yeah how do
we attract liquidity how do we fight
this this mechanic um so the first one
which you know this doesn't sound
serious but it kind of is is like
bribing the solvers and the intent uh
intent networks um I think we will see
chains of protocols essentially sort of
paying for order flow which is something
that um exists in in in traditional
markets um and um I guess the the other
the other one which hopefully is more
positive is building kind of more and
more efficient uh protocols so that they
can have better outcome for users maybe
with um maybe with less liquidity or
generating more rewards for for the for
the
LPS perfect and that's all the time we
have for questions uh give it up again
for Daniel yanev thank you
lovely and we just keep going so our
next speaker is Gregory Rocco with the
talk titled product like product Le
blockchain development Gregory is the
head of portfolio at ethereal Ventures
as well as a co-founder and product
adviser to Spruce ID and in the talk
Gregory will go over the history of
product Le growth how it evolved to
product Le protocol development in web 3
and finally what product Le blockchain
development means in the context of app
specific Roll-Ups give it up for Gregory
Roco hello everyone my name is Gregory
Roco as mentioned and um I tried to
figure out what I could do in a short
amount of time for a lightning talk I
felt like you'd have a lot of Highly
specific technical talks so I figured
I'd give product a go when it comes to
giving one of these so the title itself
is product Li blockchain development so
it's kind of covering the whole lineage
of going from product Le growth for
startups to uh product Le protocol
development which was originally coined
by Dan Romero a couple years ago and
thinking about forecaster and then
finally product like blockchain
development which is this new era of
everyone U seemingly wanting their own
block space for some strange reason but
we'll we'll figure it out eventually um
but the subtitle here is why you're
wrong and the market is Right deals
specifically with making sure that
whenever you think about uh product
development protocol development or even
blockchain development that you are
serving some customer need and not your
own interests to a certain degree you
have to be interested in what you're
doing but at the same time you have to
serve a market um and a disclaimer to
this talk is that I was a founder and I
was wrong plenty of times I specifically
started my career in uh this space in
decentralized identity which namely is a
hard space to crack when it comes to
product development and probably there
are just very few uh companies and
protocols that have done it maybe ens is
the closest to product Mark Market fit
when it comes to Identity um but user
controlled credentials generally were
quite tough um going back into the core
basics of product development one of the
kind of core pillars there is product L
growth namely that's whenever you build
a product you specifically have to make
sure that customer needs and customer
experience are at the Forefront
dictating everything that you do and
become the full kind of motion for what
you do so feedback comes in you then
take that feedback as a product
developer and that's what influences
engineering design messaging and
everything in between it shouldn't come
from oh just one more feature and all
these users are going to use it never
works out that way it's specifically in
the case of someone requesting a feature
from what you build you bring something
to Market you get your initial set of
users and you're constantly using that
messaging to inform what you're going to
do and all the decisions you're going to
make when thinking about product
development this was the framework for a
long time when it came to startups it's
what I was indoctrinated with when I
went through Y combinator and then later
in the space since we're all kind of
building these emerging protocols and
blockchains uh the framework had to be
changed a little bit because it was a
bit of like a blue ocean space when it
came to protocol development uh kind of
fast forward a little bit later and you
have the situations where developers do
developer things where the developer
might have an interesting idea and might
have some problems bringing it to Market
specifically because they're just kind
of handing a protocol over to someone
and saying here build on this build all
these great ideas on my protocol it'll
be great but the problem is it's not
taking those first principles into
account and a couple years ago Dan
Romero from forecaster put out a post
post post called Product protocol
development and it's specifically dealt
with the idea that as a protocol
developer you're building the first apps
and clients that leverage your own
protocol and are then taking the
feedback from those to inform protocol
development namely in his case there are
three core tenants of product Leed
protocol development the first is that
users use apps and clients they don't
use protocols so in let's use foraster
for the sake of the example users are
using warcast they're kind of making
posts they're interacting with
application on on the back end it's
forecaster the protocol that's kind of
informing all these interactions the
second thing is that a developer worth
their salt will make sure that they're
concerned with meaningful daily active
users instead of the coolest technology
that they want to use a developer that's
building for an audience specifically
and not experimenting and the third and
final part of it is that Protocols are
valued based on the clients and app
success that build on set protocol so
it's always making sure that apps and
clients are at the center here and then
if you're building a protocol you are
defining the blueprint for how that
protocol should be used by being
informed of what's happening on these
apps and clients that people are
actually using and then finally to round
it out complication requires a bit of
order recently in the space we're
finding protocols wanting to have their
own block space building app specific
rollups and I think just the bottom line
of all this is just making sure that if
you kind of go down this route that you
have to be the block space you want to
see in the world you have to make sure
that when you're building this you are
building the killer app leveraging this
block space that you're not going the
usual route of building this thing and
saying hey everyone we're going to get a
growth marketer to bring a million
developers through the door and then
they're going to build a whole bunch of
stuff on our new protocol and it's been
going to be great it's like no you're
going to be building the app that
specifically leverages this for what you
designed it to do and if it doesn't work
out well then you might need to hit the
drawing board again but it's all
specifically going back to this core
idea of product Le growth where you are
presenting something to the market
you're presenting the end users with
something to use they are then informing
what happens with that and everything in
between so kind of returning to First
principles I encourage experimentation
but at the end of the experimentation if
you do wish to bring something to Market
please keep designing and developing
with users in mind and making sure those
users are able to give you feedback to
inform the next stages of what you're
building so
thanks thanks a lot Gregory
and now we have a little bit of time for
questions wow someone's ready I can I
can see that all right let me get this
box to you ready and
go know thank you don't I'm I'm curious
to have your opinion about the fact like
don't you think like the space is even
designed to not incentivize like
competition between different rollups
because they're all looking to attract
liquidity attract user and just grow
like individually and so this doesn't go
in pair with like taking care of re user
because they compete for user they
compete for liquidity and there is like
a lack of interality really so what are
your thoughts on this so in the case of
like very app specific case you're then
competing with others like we don't need
all those rollups no we don't it's it's
it's unnecessary like I think I'm an
agree with you we we don't to a certain
extent but making sure that if you were
building something to then build in in
those use cases at the same time um or I
might not be understanding the question
correctly well I think like the the the
space is designed in a way like everyone
wanted to talk own rollup get users get
liquidity but at the end like we're not
building something that actually can be
useful for people like and it's also
sometimes just Ser serving like the
ecosystem but to an extent so if there
is a dominant use case that's an app
specific rollup then good for them I
hope it it masses the most amount of
liquidity in in that only way and
dominates that space of it's providing a
good enough of experience like I'm I I
want to allow the ability for anyone to
create that app specific roll up but at
the same time I want a very like I want
someone to win and that's okay because
it means user getting the value and if
if that app specific rollup turns around
and does something against user want
there's another app specific roll up
kind of waiting for that or waiting for
that user
base okay thank you J is there another
question because otherwise I was another
one here yes there are other
so um so you essentially mentioned that
you developers should focus on building
a product that the market wants um what
makes it and we see that most companies
actually have are having a hard time
doing this what do you think makes it so
difficult to apply that very easy
fundamental first principle thinking I
think being in the space for a number of
years
um everyone there's there's a lot of
cases where people aren't working uh
deeply enough or pinpoint enough on a
very specific issue um namely that good
good example like let's let's use
hypothetical like social protocols or
like someone building a chain for like
all the social protocols they're
thinking mostly about this is again a
hypothetical but like we're going to
amass all the social protocols they're
going to be using our chain they're
different clients and all that without
building the very specific client
themselves and saying we're going to be
offering this experience first as a
first class citizen they're thinking too
much about offer it to everyone before
let's get the experience right and
figure out how to then open it up and I
think that's been a part of the thinking
or an issue with the thinking for a long
time it's ambitious and it's very like a
good thing overall but at the same time
it becomes difficult to provide that
very narrow experience or solve that
very specific problem before thinking
too widely and I think you have to
balance both of that when When
developing and
designing perfect and that's all the
time we have for questions now maybe you
can catch Gregory later but for now
let's have another round of applause for
Gregory
lovely and we have our next speaker
ready um our next speaker is D Chang
Derek is the founder and CEO of zerodv
and the talk is called chain abstracted
smart accounts how to build amazing web
3 ux in 2024 so Derek will explain how
developers can build amazing web 3
experiences by combining AA with CA in
the form of chain abstracted smart
accounts smart accounts that can spend
their balances on any chain without
bridging let's hear more about this from
Derek Chang Give It Up
[Music]
hey
guys all right
so hi everyone um so my name is Derek
I'm the founder of zero death so today
today I want to talk to you about this
New Concept called chain abstractive
smart account um so very simply a chain
abstractive smart account is a new type
of account that changes how we think
about web 3 so with a normal smart
accounts you know as you can see here we
have what we call a trans Centric point
of view right so with the normal
accounts you think about your assets in
terms of different CH so you might have
for example 500 usdc on base 300 usdc on
polygon and 200 USC and 200 USC on
ethereum but with a train abstractive
smart account you can afford to have a
what we call a asset Centric point of
view right so now you can just think oh
I have one I have 1,000 usdc in my
wallet and it doesn't actually matter
which underlying blockchains your tokens
are are actually on right as far as you
are concerned you own 1,000 usdc and you
can spend them instantly on any
blockchain so that's why chain objective
smart account is better than than than a
normal
account so let me tell you about how
chain abstractive smart accounts
actually work so very simply a chain
abstractive smart account is simply the
combination of two technologies smart
accounts and
intent so let's first think about how
intense work right uh let's use a you
know the most popular intense Bridge
which is AC cross as an example so
here's how a cross
Works in order to bridge in this case
you know say 50 usdc from base to
polygon the first thing you do when you
use AC cross is that you send 50 usdc
from your accounts into a vote right and
then the second step the solver there's
going to be a intend solver on the other
s side that transfers 50 usdc to your
account on the other s side and finally
they reclaim the 50 usdc on base through
some kind through some kind of cross
Trend proof showing that they did send
you 50
usdc and know that like the reason why
we need the vote here is because without
first moving the vot in uh you know
without first first moving the tokens
into the vaults the user can very easily
scam the server by taking their money
away after the server paid for them on
the other ch right so that's why it's
important for the for the account to
First Lock the tokens into a vote uh
before the server can send them the
tokens on the other side right so this
is how intense work so now let's think
about how we can add smart accounts into
the mix to enable CH AB smart
accounts so again you know it's the same
flow so you first lock the funds into a
vault but here when your smart accounts
like when your account is a smart
account which means that it's a smart
contract the solver can do something a
little different which is that instead
of just sending you 50 usdc the server
can actually make a call to your account
which is now a smart contract with the
50 usdc and then your your smart account
can interact with whatever application
right so this 2 a and 2B here like these
two steps I actually one single
transactions and this is only possible
because your account is now a smart
contract so the solver calls you and
then you call the dep so now we have you
know move from a system in which we can
only do transfer you know which is the
normal intend Bridges to a system where
we can do executions meaning that your
smart accounts can now interact with
arbitrary applications and the huge
benefit here is that this is gas list
right like this is gas list on the on
the destination chain because the
transaction was submitted by the s
so your account actually doesn't need
any e right so from your account's
perspective it was able to interact with
the application without holding any e
and you are just spending usdc so this
gives you gas list transaction on the on
the destination
chain but this system is still not
perfect because uh if you look at the
source chain you see that you are still
like to you know to actually execute a
transaction on the target chain you
still have to first send a transaction
on the source chain right you know so
you still have to hold the gas
here so that's why you know we can
actually also have the solver work for
you on the source train as well right so
again it's basically the same as the
last flow except that in the first
step instead of having your smart
account uh transferring usdc to the
Vault
directly here the first step is to have
the solver call your smart accounts to
trigger the transfer to the Vault right
so again because the transaction was
originated by the solver your smart
account actually doesn't need to hold
any e right uh you know and again this
is only possible because your smart your
smart account is a smart contract that
can accept cost so your smart account
will transfer the funds to the vaults
you know which then triggers the
transaction on the other s side to
interact with the
application so let's recap what we have
achieved here you now have like one
single unified balance across all the
chains that can be spent on on on any
chain right like like any tokens on on
any chain can be spent on any chain and
we have achieved gas list
transactions uh in the sense that for
example here you literally need to own
nothing except usdc in your accounts to
perform this transaction right because
like all the gas on both the source
chain and Target chain are handled by
the
solver and the user never interacted
with a bridge uh manually right from the
users perspective they are just sending
a transaction uh you know and then like
the bridging is is handled by the solver
under the
hood so that was just like the tip of
the the tip of the iceberg as as far as
like how CH chain abstracted smart
accounts work especially like with the
next ethereum upgrade pectra you know
like when uh you know with EIP 7702 all
the existing wallets such as metamask
will be able to be upgraded to Smart
accounts so that's when you know this
huge issue of L2 fragmentation today you
know this huge ux issue of like having
to bridge your tokens all like all over
the place
um will be solved through chain
abstractive smart accounts so today you
know like you know we already offer you
know you know a early solution in beta
you know so if you want to check out how
to improve QX you know through CH
abjective smart accounts feel free to
check out zero death thank
you thanks Derek all right we have time
for questions now yes you've been so
great about coming up with questions so
far all right whoever catches it is
going to ask ask the question and here
you go you ready uh maybe some basic
question the solvers uh kind of approve
it to move funds from your accounts
right sorry could you could you repeat
the question so the solver is
preapproved to move funds from your
account okay so so so so let let me be
let me be very clear are there several
solers approved to do this only one
solver okay so iess I guess I can't see
my slides anymore you know but but
basically one thing I'm I'm I have
skipped over for Simplicity is that the
very first thing that the user do is to
sign an intent right so user has to sign
a message first right so that intent is
fundamentally what's authorizing the
solver to move the tokens on your behalf
right so you sign intent and then when
the solver calls your smart account
accounts they include the sign intent
and that's why your smart account will
allow them to move the tokens for you
does that does it make
sense maybe you can discuss this more
after the talk yeah um I have a question
so would us be able to what say I have a
$50 CH a $50 CH B I want to buy
something with $100 on CH C can that
work oh for sure yeah if you think about
the flow right um yeah you know like so
so in that case the solver would just
like give you 50 usdc on the destination
chain and then you will be spending 100
usdc in total on the destion
yeah all right that's all the time we
have for questions this time but again
thanks uh Derek for the wonderful talk
let's give it up for Derek
[Applause]
lovely um
so if uh someone is uh here for the
first time uh you can um ask questions
after the talk we're not doing the
mircat thing just oldfashioned raise
your hand and ask your question if you
want to go to the bathroom it's on the
right at the end of the hallway and
Meanwhile we're going to welcome our
next speaker our next speaker is MAV
and the talk is titled achieving chain
abstraction through transaction
orchestration so mislav is a software
engineer and founder working in the
blockchain space since 2016 which in
blockchain years is basically forever
and in the talk M will explore the
concepts of transaction orchestration
and Signal single signature multi-chain
permissioning all right let's give it up
for MAV
[Music]
good morning everyone uh glad to be here
uh as you see I renamed my trans uh my
presentation but it's the same thing I
promise uh so we basically just
rebranded some things uh I applied here
as um co-founder at cluster but now I
work as VP product at by economy so uh
without further Ado we only have five
minutes so let's get started um so one
of the things that we basically deal
with today is let's call it monolithic
execution um so let's call it like this
you have your normal blockchain
transaction you encode a transaction you
sign it and you send it to an RPC node
and the RPC node sends it to a block
Builder who then you know it goes to a
minor or a validator or a sequencer they
include it into the blockchain and
that's it that's monolithic and some of
the some of the features of the
monolithic environments are they're
unicast like one RPC node communicates
to one blockchain they're isomorphic in
a sense that an evm node doesn't
understand an svm transaction nor like a
near transaction or a wasm transaction
or whatever uh signature scheme coupled
uh you know your ethereum node really
does only use one signature scheme for
everything uh they're non-c composable
so imagine if you are pre-signing two
transactions so one and two you can't
pre-sign that the second transaction
takes as its input the output from the
first transaction action uh and they're
non collaborative if you have multiple
transactions that you want to execute
first of all you can't even bundle them
in a single object but even if you could
there is no way for a collaborative
execution where let's say a solver
solves for a fraction of your uh
transaction then a bundler solves for
the next fraction of your transaction
Etc um so yeah these are the problems
with monolithic execution and that's
where we go into this uh modular
execution what we Ed to call transaction
orchestration uh modular execution
environment uh in essence is um is using
super transactions and a super
transaction is a single data object
which can contain the payment
information for how you want to pay for
this super transaction uh user Ops
intents offchain actions ZK proofs it's
modular it's extensible and it's also
recursive so what does this enable so
this enables essentially um a node to
commit to multiple actions to the user
and the user permissions these multiple
actions with a single signature uh it
requires uh smart contract accounts it
relies on ERC 7579 validator module it
encodes all of this into a Merkel tree
then you sign the Merkel tree root hash
and after you've signed the Merkel tree
root hash this essentially gives
permission to all to all of the leaves
to get uh executed um what's the cool
thing about modular execution
environments well like one of the
coolest things is that they are uh
modular obviously but they are also
recursive uh what does this mean so
let's say I'm a node um which has
committed to execute something for you
um and I don't know how to execute the
entire thing that you have given me
maybe it has like a intent to move funds
from optimism to base and then it has a
requirement for two two or three user
Ops uh to execute certain you know let's
call it like this uh intent uh user op
first remove my Supply from a on
optimism then an intent uh move this
usdc from optimism to base and then a
user op Supply to a on base which is
basically let's call it a rebalancing an
a position in a single single
transaction super transaction um and
this is kind of let's say this can be
done by a single node but for for just
for um for an example let's say a
thought experiment let's say that the
node doesn't know how to trigger an
intent it doesn't know how to front
liquidity what can happen essentially is
that one of the leaves of this Merkel
tree can be the root of another Merkel
tree and then one node can commit to
another so essentially this is a data
structure for a new type of transaction
which is recursive by default and which
has multiple elements of execution by
default uh we are trying to essentially
push this to become the one of the main
if not the main um data model for
transactions within a chain abstracted
world because it Bridges gaps between so
like the leaf can be a Solana
transaction it can be an ethereum
transaction it can be a vasm transaction
uh payment can be like an onchain
payment it can be an offchain payment um
offchain actions for example you can
trigger call to some API then require
this to generate a ZK TLS proof that
something has been executed so it's very
extensible very modular it uh really
effortlessly achieves all the elements
of chain abstraction like uh gas
abstraction single signature multi-chain
stuff um and yeah also what we are
building is a modular execution
environment U which is a permissionless
execution layer for all of this but you
know I wanted to keep this Technical and
not Shilling our own thing so um yeah um
this is it for super transactions and
modular execution
environments thank you
MAV and now we have time for questions
raise your hand if you have a question I
know you do don't be shy
yes all right so I'm gonna throw you the
box get ready to catch it yeah and go
okay uh how do you ensure like
transaction atomicity in a multi chain
environment let's say uh you did a
transaction on optimism and Main night
and then something happened to op
optimism and someone claimed that the
rollup was faulty and the block reverted
what happens to the transaction which
was was settle before so the um super
transactions and modular execution
environments are just technical Concepts
They Don't Really guarantee or not
guarantee atomicity so a example of a
modular execution environment can be one
which guarantees atomicity so we are
currently working with uh certain block
Builders who can like build blocks on
top of multiple blockchains at the same
time so you can get like a
pre-confirmation whether or not it's
going to get executed everywhere or
nowhere um a lot of things don't really
require this type of hard atomicity like
for example this case that I said with
AA like the worst case if a piece of the
transaction fails you'll just retry the
transaction on the destination chain and
then so even like a super transaction
can contain also retry instructions so
you can pre-sign all of the retry
instructions that that are needed uh in
our experience like
99% of everything goes through uh but
yeah for certain cases let's call it
maybe trading or or defi positions where
like
maybe you want to do a cross chain flash
loan or something like that where
atomicity is very important there we are
already in active conversations with
certain projects which do like block
building on top of multiple rollups at
the same time and then yeah you
basically get a precommitment to to
inclusion of all of the transactions
within the super transaction
hash right thanks we already have
another question lined up uh yeah my
question actually was the same uh as
about automic so in general it's U like
convenient way to uh put all
transactions together and uh do you have
some ways to uh prescribe uh sequence of
transaction so let's say uh this
transaction should happen before this
one or some mechanisms like this so in
general they are sequenced by default um
so a node will not execute a transaction
if it simulates a revert and also there
is like this entire trustless protocol
with staking and slashing that actually
ensures the liveness of all of this but
let's call it like if you are bridging
to base and like the transaction on base
requires 10 100 usdc until you have a
100 usdc on base like it will not like
the node itself will not execute that
piece of the transaction the secondary
part which you can do is you can set
conditions with onchain variables so for
example let's call it
um transaction on optimism triggers a
cross chain message onto base which
updates an onchain variable which gives
permission to the second transaction in
a row so um we are actively working with
a few cross chain messaging protocols to
enable this functionality uh the entire
idea is that you should be able to write
let's call them smart contracts in only
front-end code where it's like you put
um you know if else conditionals just
call this transaction if output is
bigger than this then write to this
chain set set this transaction we're
also building an SDK called abstract JS
that's going to enable all of this uh
but so essentially the nodes use reverts
for sequencing so until the transaction
reverts nothing gets executed and then
you can use onchain variables to control
the sequence flow but let's call it for
this a example and for a lot of other
examples that we have sequencing happens
automatically because like until
conditions are met nothing gets executed
and like sequencing is implicit in the
flow that you have already set
out lovely that's all the time we have
for questions thanks a lot give it up
for M
[Applause]
love all right all right so our next
speaker is radina talanova a product
owner at L2 beat and radina's talk is
called chain abstraction is risk
abstraction so the talk aims to provide
a Nuance view of whether chain
abstraction truly enhances user
experience or or introduces new layers
of complexity and vulnerability let's
find out which one it is welcome
radina hi everyone uh I'm ADI and today
I'll share with you my thoughts on chain
obstructions and the associated
risks so a quick refresher what is chain
obstruction
um and its main goal uh so the idea here
is to provide a user experience um that
is all about enabling users to use
applications without having to interact
directly with Bridges or
chains so uh what can possibly go wrong
here uh this is a very simple example
where uh poor implementation of
obstruction uh led to a user losing uh
some fonts due to slippage what happened
here is that uh user tried to bridge
from digent chain back to base and
because the UI was using an external
Bridge instead of a canonical one uh it
first had to slap funds to eat and this
is where things went wrong so the user
incurred an 87%
slippage um and the thing is that this
wouldn't have happened if economical
Bridge was used or maybe if the user was
informed that an external bridge is used
or if they had the option to choose uh
so this example is trying to show the
pitfalls of account obstruction of chain
obstruction when implemented on the
wrong
level so how how can we do it
better um there is this example of an
intent based protocol and there are lots
of different designs but the idea here
is that part of the risks are moved away
from the user uh so here we have this
entity called solver uh that basically
once the user deposits funds the solver
almost immediately provides the funds to
them on the destination chain the idea
here is that the user still has to trust
the solver to not censor them and the
escrow smart contract on the source
chain uh but apart from this they don't
have to care about uh finality and
settlement because those are risks that
the so is taking instead of them
and uh there is this concept of chain
obstructed balances uh this is the third
example um the thing here is that if the
user only sees uh one total balance uh
that they have across all chains they
might um not realize uh that for example
most of their funds are on a highrisk
chain and this is because um the assets
that you have uh inherit the risks of
their underlying assets which depend on
the bridges and the chains that were
used this an example with uh AP on AP
chain but there are lots of different
examples and here um the token that is
on AP chain uh is basically inheriting
security from the canonical Bridge as
well as Slayer
zero um so the point that I want to make
is that um first of all uh if there are
any risks uh uh where the user can
[Music]
um that can still affect the user and
they can potentially lose funds they
should be shown to the user they should
not be hidden and in the example with
the chain um abstracted balances uh I
believe that at this stage we are not
ready to hide the risks uh just because
the most of the chains are not secure
enough um so chain obstruction should
not be risk obstruction in a sense where
uh there are risks that um the user is
not protected from and they are not
aware of them and they might cause funds
to uh get stolen or
lost but chain obstruction uh should be
risk obstruction in the sense that uh we
should try to protect the users from
those risks and this can be by uh
limiting some uh actions on the front
end or by introducing some additional uh
entities who would bear the risks
instead of the
users and um as a last thing I want to
say that we at L2 beat um want to um I
mean we believe in transparency and we
also like red warnings so um we
introduced these two called Insight
where you can check all the risks of
your portfolio uh by inputting your
address uh so in this example you would
see all the underlying tokens of Apon AP
chain and all the risks that come from
the canonical Bridge or lezero or the
token itself uh and this is mostly
targeted towards regular users who want
to know how risky the assets they hold
are but if you are um developer um and
uh you want to make the best decisions
on behalf of your users you can also
find this useful so uh make sure to
check it out once it's live
thank
you thanks Sardina all right we have
time for some questions who wants to ask
one raise your
hand don't be
shy you can do
it if not I'll ask a question and I know
your your questions are better yes
amazing hello
you and catch
um I want to ask like for a simple
Finance product um like a very very
simple one without all the sophisticated
stuff what would you recommend to devs
um obviously when you're onboarding
completely newb users you you don't want
to expose everything what would you
recommend devs
to yeah so um I think that uh when if
the developers want in some way to
onboard users without introducing them
to the complexity of the CHS and Bridges
so using some kind of chain obstruction
um in case they don't want to surface
all the risks because it can be
overwhelming they should make sure that
they make the best choice for their
users so it can be something like
limiting the chains they support based
on the risks that uh they might
introduce or limiting the assets or uh
maybe doing some kind of summary of the
risk like high uh medium low and then
profiling their users uh to show the
risks depending on um yeah their user
profile thank you cool we have time for
another
[Music]
question anyone yes
here another question is that for the I
think the chain abstraction definitely
great user experience and also you meion
the risk mitigations as well but in
Beyond like the Insight what are some of
the kind of mechanisms which should you
guys put in place to increase the user
like you know trust the confidence on of
the reliability of the abstraction on
that uh so the question is what
procedures should be followed uh uh Prim
what other mechanism you put in place to
increase the credibility and I increase
the trust from the user for the account
abstraction
um all right so uh I think that uh when
implementing chain obstruction and um I
guess we can use this example with the
uh intent based protocols uh in this
case for example if uh the user has to
put some Trust on this new entity codes
over uh we should uh make sure that it's
reliable so um maybe we can do something
like decentralized uh solare networks so
um for every trust assumption that the
user should make we should make sure
that this entity is to be trusted and it
is decentralized
enough cool and there's time for one
more
question let's see if anyone has
it I think someone has a question yes
yes
yes no that's okay uh thank you so much
Rina give it up for Rina
awesome and next up on the stage we have
Conrad Orban with a talk called chain
abstraction but I want to know where my
tokens
are yeah about
right so uh Conrad is a co co co-founder
of peanut protocol and we'll talk about
how we should think about where assets
live give it up for Conrad
[Music]
hello hi this is not going to be
nice um I'm here to tell you that it
will be your fault if things go wrong
and I will explain that um in Greater
detail I think our it's such a nice
segue to have um rina's talk earlier
because exactly what I want to talk
about is the responsibility you have
when you abstract chain and when you
curate the infrastructure that you have
so about me um I'm the peanut brain at
peanut protocol and we've been doing
chain abstraction when we still called
it chain agnostic payments so we do we
do chain abstract payments you can do a
payment let's say in 10 usdt on optimism
and someone can receive 10 usdt on
polygon uh we don't use um intents we
don't use fancy solvers we use Simple
Bridges um to make the that happened
we've been around for a while now um so
yeah um for generalized chain
abstraction I think it's important to
ask like why why should I even care
where my tokens live so I think I
personally care because the risks are
very different to something like a
traditional centralized financial
institution when you think about a bank
you have legal guarantees and you have
bailouts um that secure your funds and
you don't need need to worry about the
exact Capital the underlying Capital um
of the bank you can be pretty sure that
you are able to withdraw um your funds
in any mature economy in crypto well we
don't have legal documents to back us up
we have Smart
contracts um so I want to talk through
two dilemas one is simple ux and like
very strip down ux and exposing all of
the
risks so L to be when Bridge
beat um I think I think it's um yeah uh
a slide that I stole from radina that I
briefly want to talk about um look at
all of the risks that are um involved in
such a simple thing as just having usdc
on orderly um well getting usdc on
orderly you not only have all the circle
risk then you get like the the mantle
risk get the canonical brisk RIS layer
zero and so on that's crazy um so let's
make the pizza green um and let's talk
through some ways we can communicate
these risks to end users so we have this
first generation of chain first two eyes
which emphasize the chain um and then
and then the acid so that's like
metamask where you have to pick your
chain and then it only shows the acids
on that specific chain then we have acid
first UI so Rabbi I think has a is a
really nice example where um it shows
you the assets it will even show you um
the the the uh uh um Network
um um as separate entities but it will
show the asset first it will show the
the network as a small thing in the back
um well how should we do it as as
product people um what should a product
person do should they just like slap
thousands of warnings everywhere uh
surely that's not a good way to onboard
um users it gets even worse when we
abstract everything and we just have
like a final balance and we just assume
that everything's going to Route it
everywhere right yet we have to
expose um these things somehow um
especially that with chain abstraction
essentially what happens I would argue
is that the fat protocol thesis kind of
stops existing and the middleware thesis
plus the app thesis become much much
broader um which means that you are much
much more responsible for curating um
the infrastructure and the middleware
you're using and what you're exposing to
the end user so there is this phenomenon
I think that we'll see um with mass
onboarding and very simple apps where
we'll have a race to the bottom in terms
of not showing these risks right like as
a business especially as a startup I
want to move fast and break things and
yeah I'm it is a disadvantage is it is
objectively a business disadvantage to
be like warning this thing is at risk
warning that thing is at risk um which
means that it's even more important to
internally as a product team to vet the
infrastructure that you're using and
consult um uh tools and and people like
L2 beat and uh maybe Bridge beat in this
in the future um one thing that I wanted
to emphasize is that the market doesn't
seem to price these risks um strongly
like one eth on some random L2 is going
to be exactly the same dollar value of
eth on Main net um so it seems that um
the market just doesn't doesn't price
these maybe because we haven't seen a
catastrophic risk yet uh a catastrophic
failure yet so yeah uh if you ever want
to chat about interoperability for
payments uh DM me I will send you money
um these are my uh
details thank you
Conrad and you can already talk to
Conrad right now if you ask a question
incredible right you can ask your uh
question by raising your hand and I'll
get the box to
you yes oh that's far maybe it's easier
you do it from
there no no it's okay you can you can
you can stay okay I like standing up
anyway so I understand about the
counterparty risk of the bridge uh
introducing you know different risk to
the bridge asset but in the far future
if we have soft smart contract security
and all that with like ZK or whatever
people are using do you foresee it being
at risk parity across all the chain and
therefore chain abstraction is
viable I think when we say chain
abstraction it's still some basket of
chains that you as a um product creator
cure rate right so they I I think maybe
there will be a world where all this
Tech will go down to zero it will it's
going to go it's going to be very very
simple to have like really really really
good um tech there um that where we
don't need to do all these um audits
essentially um but uh yeah it's it's up
to you to curate I think that's my my
main arguments
yeah all right we have another question
in the far future yeah sorry yeah yes
for someone that's new into the space me
here oh for someone that's new into the
space in building doesn't have like a
plor of knowledge of
existing third party risk that exists
with Bridges like how do you actually
assess and price in that risk when
building where's the best place to do
that yeah really really good question so
albut is a great place um I think my
main message would be again it's you as
the product owner or or even like
co-founders um who have to make that
decision about curation if you want to
hide the risks like you you're faced
with this dilemma of like either you
expose the risk and you fair to the user
and say well it's going to be your own
fault you're you're responsible which
creates wui or um you curate it for them
and then um don't get surprised if uh
people will spam your support email if
they uh lose their funds and they will
hunt you
down oh we have time for another
question anyone wants to ask
one maybe you do maybe don't yes you do
fantastic get ready to catch and
go good catch and do you say if this
going to create the barrier of entry for
like new l2s to enter because like the r
there's a r in a new
players I think it's the opposite so I
think with as with any research project
um there's a first mve disadvantage
because you're pouring in millions and
millions into the biggest rins of the
industry to design a new infrastructure
and then anyone else can just folk that
or build a very similar copy um yeah
whilst inheriting all of the niceties of
the first
mover but you would then apply for if
they are using a new technology for
example yeah sure if you're building
something new then you need to convince
everyone that it's good Tech and you
need to really pitch yourself I think
that's also a message to all infra
projects like pitch that pitch to apps
that you are the the best option the
secure option for your users because app
developers have this responsibility um
towards their end
users of curation yeah lovely that's all
the time we have for questions thanks
again Conrad give it up for Conrad
[Applause]
fantastic so how is everyone feeling
good yes energetic
tired hoping for better things happy
that you have all the good things you
have yes all right we're experiencing
emotions we are alive I think um so if
you want to go to the bathrooms there
are at the right end of the hallway you
can do that you can take pictures if you
want to just make sure that they're
without Flash so that you're don't
distract our wonderful speakers and
speaking of wonderful speakers next up
on the stage is Greg the Greek the CPO
and co-founder at chains saafe and a
co-founder at Sigma labs and the talk is
called the endgame wallet when does
obstruction go too far so Greg the Greek
will make us wonder how far are we
willing to go in the name of efficiency
something to ponder and while you ponder
that please welcome to the stage Greg
the
Greek hey everybody um yeah my name is
Greg uh or Greg the Greek if you know me
online uh I'm one of the co-founders at
chains safe and as well as Sprinter we
recently Rebrand a few days ago from uh
Sigma um today I'm going to be talking
about end game the endgame wallet uh
this is coming from about a year over
well over one to two years wor of
Standards work that's something I do a
lot in my spare time um and it's
something that we focus a lot at
Sprinter is driving how we can look at
like multi-chain um and getting the ux
there right we don't have a wallet we
don't really do wallet infra we work in
solving as well as we've been doing
multi- Building Bridges since 2018 and
building prot we're protocol engineers
at chains safe and I was one myself for
eth 2.0 uh
so I'm trying to remove as much bias as
possible I'm objectively looking at the
standards when we go through
here so where let's do a little I want
to do a little Memory Lane I want to
like you know bring it a little pain you
know when was I don't know if many of
you remember the world before EIP 1193
but this was when you download a new
fancy wallet and then all of a sudden no
app would ever be able to work with it
or communicate with it if you were an
app developer you had to manually code
in communicate with like metamask or
communicate with fancy new wallet there
was a time when you couldn't even have
multiple browser extensions and that was
pre multi- injector provider there was
also I mean this is still a problem
let's be honest we're still getting
we're getting close to aggregate
balances that look nicer so your usdc is
better or how about Network switching or
even you know you go to a Dap immediate
wallet popup we've been iterating and
fixing a lot of the ux challenges we see
and we see that the improvements that
have been happening over the last couple
years these iterations have all come
from erc's eips and capes and that's why
they're really important that we start
adopting them but frankly where are we
going right now we're actually like
right now the chain obstruction space
has kind of us
um we are right now selling application
developers that we they need to deploy a
smart contract wallet for their app to
get the best features in the guest users
if you hear that statement frankly for
my opinion you're going down a road
where you're going to have to do a very
ugly migration path with when six to 18
months and it's just the wrong way to be
dealing with smart contract wallets
unless you as the app developer are
willing to deploy wallet infra and when
I say wallet infra I'm saying like a my
crypto website like a full Rage Quit
mechanism so they can migrate to
something different to someone better
you're just vendor locking them inside
your own system maybe inside the wider
system of the employer who gave you that
cuz frankly are you well equipped enough
as an app developer to deploy
preferences for the user smart contract
wallet if they want to say exess because
we're going down an intense system are
you willing to express a preference for
them to
ensure that if they say I want one eth
always to exist on Main net never take
away that one eth you know if I have two
it can go down to one are you ready to
deploy that type of preferences and
those type of feature sets to them
because if you're not you shouldn't
never be giving them a smart contract
wallet you're setting them up for
failure and you're setting your users up
for a awful ux experience down the
road and frankly it just creates
fragmented balances and it doesn't get
us anywhere and the biggest problem we
still have today is that it do we have
any mobile app developers
here have you ever tried to communicate
with a smart contract wallet that was
deployed by another
team yeah it doesn't work it's
impossible we work with game developers
they can't connect to a remote account
accounts it's it's literally impossible
and that's because we've moved into a
world of pass Keys pass keys are domain
separated you if chains safe issues you
a pass key only the chainsa doio domain
can ever access that same Pass key so
you need a way to talk to them and
that's where I'm going to be going with
this um a quick note and I'm going to be
very you know this might be a bit of a
lie but like I think we're getting there
within one to two years we're probably
going to see 90% of transactions will be
solved there's no doubt about that they
it we are going down that path and
that's going to happen um so with that
in mind we have to think there's this
big debate of smart wallet versus like
dumb app and so and so forth frankly if
the app is going multi-chain and you're
interacting with different contracts on
different chains you are smart you have
to be smart you have to know how to
actually make and Bridge those
connections otherwise the wallet's
always smart let's be real they need to
be the one to ensure that the user is
there because they need to be deploying
that wallet for I was describing
earlier now let's do this endgame I'm
going to verbally abuse you with erc's
and that's totally fine there's going to
be there's other sessions today that
will help you learn about these erc's
more in deep I'm going to go over them
as quickly as I can as effectively as I
can and use web two examples so you can
understand why they're important these
eips and erc's and capes are written by
well over 20 plus people so when I say
there's like no bias in here I'm just
stitching the stuff together that we're
talking about in the wallet meetups at
every
conference okay here's your general
interaction right dap wallet very
simple we know we want to deploy 4337
everywhere that's a given it's the best
ux we can get because we can't get
native account
abstraction we know pass keys are the
easiest way to onboard a user because
seed phrases are too complicated private
keys are difficult and frankly the whole
experience that we've been doing before
is just because we in this room frankly
are ahead of the curve it's not going to
work for most people pass keys are a
must and they live at the wallet level
the next way to actually broker this
system is to realize that your dap's
never going to actually have a wallet
like a smart account your dap's going to
use an embedded wallet why you can blind
sign in the background as long as you
have permission that means you can
actually maintain the same web 2
experience you thought you needed this
means that you don't need to go and make
a job posting that says hey I need a web
3 designer no no you just need a
designer you need a really good designer
that knows what they're doing and that's
it you can build Web Two experiences you
can get a per desk that looks like Robin
Hood there's no reason you can't do that
the embedded wall allows us to have that
control we need to know how to register
people now this is one that a lot of
people don't realize the capes chain
agnostic Improvement proposals Green
Field playing field for not just evm but
the whole spectrum of blockchain
Standards Cape 275 basically says how
can we get to a oneclick onboarding you
type I type in Greg theeg greek. eth it
looks up to see who deployed my smart
contract wallet for me and from there we
generate a slug for an HTTP request or
an iframe or whatever and this is where
the magic happens ERC 75 75 is the same
thing as ooth it's the idea that it
links you when you click sign in with
Google it links you out to Google right
we because I looked up in the registry
who deployed this wallet I can actually
go in directly to that user so I can use
that pass key to get access to that 4337
account and now I can use it with the
embedded wallet on my
app but permissions
7715 we stack a permission across the
wire protocol by stacking a permission
across the wire protocol what you end up
getting now is you can be expressive hey
my per desk wants to spend a th000 usdc
per hour and make it expire in 24 hours
what does that resemble a jbt token
something we're used to we're making the
app development cycle easier
here finally
7579 Ryan Stone team big shout out the
idea here your app wants to be a little
bit more expressive the smart account
isn't what you want it to be so you can
develop a plugin directly link it onto
the smart account that you don't really
know about finally 7811 if anybody keeps
up in standards here you probably
haven't kept up with this one it got
announced last week and there's going to
be a lot built up on top of it the
simple gist I want to know from the
wallet what are the assets I don't want
to use an indexer anymore I'm tired of
having to go and quy you know an RPC
node on a for Loop over the assets I
want to know about just tell me what do
you have what's the balance of it it's
single chain we're going to take it
multi-chain there's a lot of other erc's
that go on this but the interesting
thing the one thing to keep in mind 7
triple 5 it's super ambitious very
ambitious we're not there yet we're
really close we need all these other
eips to get standardized on top but once
we do the one thing we get is we get
this communication channel that we've
never had to a remote account the same
way we do with oos so when a web 2 user
comes into the web 3 space it looks like
you know Google asking for an app asking
Google hey can I borrow your calendar
information but in this way it's going
to register plugins it's going to ask
for permission on how to spend wallets
from your funds this way we're not
depositing funds into you know poly
Market instead you're just they're
borrowing
them and I think I'm running out of time
there's a timeline here I'll skip to
when end I don't know I got quoted two
two years from now the other day I'm not
going to lie I think we can be a bit
more ambitious frankly we're not
protocol developers I was one previously
we don't need to go slow we can go fast
we can break a bunch of along the
way and we can get to what we need thank
you so much and you can find me
here thank you so much to Greg the Greek
unfortunately we don't have time for
questions but feel free to speak to Greg
the Greek after this talk and we're
ready for our next speaker our next
speaker is abim Manu abim Manu is a
co-founder at Epoch protocol and we'll
give a talk titled putting intent and
users together the stock will explore
how we could approach intense in a way
that users will adopt more readily by
leveraging the latest standards and eips
give it up for ABI
[Applause]
Manu hello everyone I hope I'm
audible yeah all right uh I a human new
and found of ug protocol and I'll be
simply talking about how we can make
intents actually approachable for end
users so to start with I'll simply tell
you like what intents actually are and
to put it simply or like in the easiest
way if you want to do something or
achieve something on the chain and you
don't know how to do it or you are not
sure how to do it in like a most optimal
or efficient way you can find an intern
solver who can do it for you and once
they have optimal solution you can
simply get it exec
uted now the problem here is if you give
something totally different to the end
users they are very luant to try it out
we at T protocol tried to like give
different user flows through and users
we did a lot of user experimentation and
the conclusion was if we give a user
flow that is not uh standard or what
user is not familiar with they won't try
it so how do we solve for it then well
part of it is like already work in
progress like we get intents being used
in existing user flows uh you can take a
look at like Unis swop x c swap or
across where you already see the intents
are being used but a user may or may not
realize it but it improves the
efficiency or like the rates that they
are getting the Second Step should be or
can be something like improving existing
flows or simplifying existing flows I'll
give example for this but I'll just
cover the third Point as well first uh
creating complete completely new intent
based application that should be the
last step where there are totally
different flows and which are using like
declarative input as a new paradig but
now coming back to like redu steps and
simplified flows so for this one let's
take example like there can be a dab
that requires a very specific token on a
very specific chain and you simply have
something like die on optimism and you
don't know how to get to that way
specific chain or get that way specific
token so how you do it uh you can start
with something as simple as putting a
button in the dab saying hey on board my
user in or bring my user in the right
State and behind the scenes all these
erc's and EIP would be used to get it
executed just like how it happens like
in normal transaction like you click on
a button you see a mamas popup saying
sign it and you can be done with it but
behind the scene what should be
happening or like how you can
orchestrate the entire thing is you can
start with the IP 7702 that would go
live really soon where a user can
leverage any smart contract wallet
implementation without actually
deploying it to their address through
eoa like they can send the transaction
through their normal metamask or like
the normal wallet they usually use and
they don't have to transfer their assets
out to another smart contract wallet
they don't have to deploy anything to
another smart like deploy as a smart
contract wallet they can just start
readily be using it you can abstract a
and all the other complications using
like efficient transaction bundling
through that comes with
4337 you can also make entire thing
interoperable like if a user wants to
use a safe implementation or a byon
implementation or something else you can
use
7579 what 7579 does is it gives you a
plug-in standard that can work across
multiple dabs so multiple wallets so
what a daap can do is create a plug-in
and that can work with see and by eony
wallet or the zero Dev wallet and dab
can just whenever user comes in da can
just plug in their plugin to the wallet
and uh have no vendor lock in at all and
lastly when your intent requires
something like a cross chain execution
there is ERC 7683 DS from unisoft and
across which defines like how the
standard of a cross chain message should
look like uh if there are multiple
intent solvers working on both sides of
the chains or like all the chains that
tent is supposed to be interacting with
uh this defines like a clear structured
object that says hey this is supposed to
be done on this chain and this is
supposed to be done on this chain and
that can be leveraged to uh get an
intent executed across all the chains so
to wrap it up for the users The
Experience would be as simple as uh just
clicking on a button and saying uh I
want to use my diet to get this very
specific asset and as as soon as user
clicks on it and hits sign all the
intent solvers do their work and lastly
it's all gets executed through a very
any speciic smart contact wallet
implementation using
7702 uh well that's pretty much
[Applause]
it thanks a Manu all right we got time
for questions please raise your hand if
you'd like to ask
one this is like talks you got to think
on your feet or I guess you're sitting
down think on your butts all right ready
and
go almost sorry about that hi one
question on wallet interoperability you
said that you could expect DS through
7579 to interact with the contracts but
each smart contracts account is
developing their own SDK with different
capabilities so is that possible and
also how can we expect that s to create
their own custom plug-in to interact
with different contracts and connected
to that this would any way achieve
interoperability but not portability of
the same account across DS so I was
curious about these two aspects thanks
yes uh the way I think that it this can
be easily done is something like a Dap
can create their own plugin so if you as
a user come with a safe wallet DB simply
puts their plug-in into your wallet and
then dap knows what the interface for
the wallet is going to be because they
can get those transaction executed
through their own uh API not API inp
points but contract functions
so uh they can just start calling the
contract functions they know from the
plugin but if a user comes with let's
say bony wallet next time they can just
plug the same plugin into the Bony
wallet as well and they can expect the
same interface again so it's sort of
like you create your own interface how
you want to call the smart contract
wallets and whatever wallet implement
ation user comes in with you just plug
your plugin into it and execute whatever
you want and that's it you don't have to
worry
about yes you can do it without going
through SDK you can simply make the
smart contact calls
it uh I think it's e uh your other
option is getting totally vendor logged
like with
437 with 437 users got like dabs got
completely vend loged if dab wanted to
interact with safe wallet they had to
like interact with explicitly with safe
wallet and if a user with with by
economy wallet would come they would
know how to interact with
it perfect all right do we have another
question somewhere in the
audience I know you're all curious
people you want to know
more yes
okay what do you can you hear me yeah I
think okay what do you what do you think
the kind of substrate is going to be
where intents actually get posted and
propagated too so that solvers can find
them um there are a few different
players who are working around this
thing uh we are working around the same
thing uh there is anoma there is Kalani
the idea here is one one of the solvers
gets an intent and they propagate it to
entire network with the hopes of there
will be more intent solvers who can
solve parts of it or like the entirety
of it so with us it's just like one
solver getting it and propagating
throughout the network and all of them
putting in their solution with something
like anumal Kalani it's like a solver
fulfills partially and puts it out on
the network and others can pick it up
and solve the rest of it but it's a work
in progress yeah got it thanks perfect
and that's all the time we have for
questions give it up for a Manu again
thank you much
lovely lovely all right so we are going
to have our next speaker in a moment um
in the meantime if you want to take
pictures feel free to do that as long as
you don't use Flash that's all cool if
you want to go to the bathroom at any
point you go to the right from here
until the end of the hallway and without
further Ado we're gonna welcome our next
speaker our next speaker is munir benam
Leed and munir is a Founder at Paras
Swap and LTA Labs mun's talk is called
exploring various approaches to achieve
effective decentralization for intense
base protocol say that three times in a
row in this talk mun will present the
status quo various architectures and new
trade-offs in terms of where intents fit
in the trilemma of fees execution speed
and execution guarantee
so welcome to the stage
M
everyone
okay glad to be here seems like this is
a intense morning and a very intense one
um some from lat Labs we're known for
building baras swap a 5-year-old
protocol and recently portugus that
allowed us to launch Paras swop Delta so
the first time Paras swap is now in the
intent space and and it's a great
thing um so I guess you heard a lot
about intense I believe it's now uh
something that is s in nature uh so I'm
going to jump directly to what are
intents in the context of trading on
chain um so it's basically one way of
expressing an outcome without describing
the details of that outcome for in in
simple terms so if you are a user um you
want to swap a token a for B well what
you do you sign at a an order or an
intent uh you send it to a backend API
in general like 99.99 of the time but in
behind the scenes there are what you
call solvers resolvers market makers
agents how we call them uh that will
compete for user flow and will bid um on
an auction and the best bidder is going
to be the winner um but so we have two
um entities here uh we have the user who
have a desire like I want to swap token
a for B we have solvers agents you name
it uh competing for user flow and as I
said uh there is an API in between that
uh does the whole work like I mean users
still are mastering their key this the
like the system is like work as any defi
protocol but the thing is that API which
acts as a central point of failure if it
stops working the whole system is not
useful it's not working at all um so
that's a problem and this is what we're
working on in in portugus in trying to
uh create an alternative but the
challenge is in what we are also
proposing is a way so that we can still
preserve um the user experience because
if we introduce a fancy decentralized
layer let's say in app chain well we
won't ask users now to interact with yet
and yet another chain uh that's not
going to be great it's not going to be
good for ux so the thing is we keep that
backend API that centralized backend API
but the thing is now it's optional so
you can use it you can run it yourself
so the user and the relayer can be the
same thing and that allows um us to
still uh give the user exactly the same
experience uh but still having a neutral
Network that can run um this system like
of intent
interactions so the system look like
this we have on the top left um uh the
user interaction so it means user want
to do action XYZ I talked about swap but
it can be I want to provide liquidity to
Unis swap I want to um do a cross chain
liquidity providing on another amm or
maybe I want to deposit my usdc on a and
earn yield on another chain or maybe
completely abstracting that chain um I
use a relayer I can be my own relayer it
can run literally on my on my laptop um
so I publish the auction or the my
intent
uh on the network we have an auction
manager this is the heart of the system
that we're going to zoom into the rest
of the process is the same we have a
competition the winner is going to win
get to execute the user trade rest is um
not new so we have multiple ways for
achieving that unfortunately we don't
have a lot of time to get really deep
but um there is the possibility of
running the auction manager on an app
chain um something that's not new we
have like dyds who are running the whole
order book and matching engine on an app
chain it's working well the big
limitation here is privacy because we
may be pre- leaking me on the user side
but also on the agent side on the solver
side like all the bits would be public
there are solutions yet but here we get
into more complexity like commit and
reveal schemes that can be a bit
challenging as well but it's one of the
approaches the other one uh is one I
like a lot is the te maybe or MPC or
combination of both where we can have um
bunch of notes who are running on if we
go with running on a trust execution
environment so it means like a Clos
environment a private environment so we
solve the the Privacy issue of like pre-
leaking of me and the issue with te is
we rely on a specialized Hardware issue
with NPC is a bit slower than than te so
maybe a combination of both uh could
could do the job it's something that's
still work in progress or research in
progress the other one is like the holy
grail for uh competing on encrypted data
that can be a perfect solution but
unfortunately this is the FH a full
homomorphic encryption uh where uh the
nodes can compute on data fully blindly
without having any idea of what's inside
and getting to like select like in in
this case select the winning agents
based on the best bidder in terms of
price gas you name it um but the problem
is if it shei latency is not acceptable
yet it's way way too slow it can work
like on a batch computations and not in
real time where it's very important in
the case of like trading on chain and
many other use cases so that's maybe we
still maybe a few years ahead there's
see some work on building some as6 like
again specialized Hardware which would
become a limitation but still yeah this
could be the best solution at some point
um but we're still few years ahead thank
you guys that's all I had happy to
answer any
question thank you mon all right all
right we have time for questions raise
your hand if you want to ask one you've
been amazing in terms of asking
questions so far let's let's keep it up
let's keep going yes all right one two
three is there a specific uh
service which solve this intent problem
usable by many uh Dex cross chain swaps
or each build their own um intent solers
you mean on the product side or on the a
side on the product side does it make
sense kind of to have a uh scalable
product here which is uh serving this uh
intent uh services for many many cross
Chain
Solutions yeah for crushing I think it's
it's becoming more and more like a a
normal thing between codes uh so we
seeing more and more protocols
normalizing cross chain interactions so
if that's the question I would say that
it's just matter of time we're not far
away from having making cross chain is
like the normal thing to do and Thinking
Beyond Beyond cross chain if it's a
question about having generalized
purpose uh intent it's something I
believe less that it's going to be the
case because the complexity of each
protocols makes it makes them so
different to have a general purpose um
solving mechanism so that's what if
that's the question I hope I answer
it all right time for another question
that yeah so as someone who has not
explored intents yet uh I want to ask
how to participate as a agent or a Soler
in this network like what exactly a Sol
is is it a piece of cord or like a
market maker bidding for the prices
what's that yeah it's uh definitely too
broad uh it can be it's always a piece
of code anyways like someone has to
write a code that will um answer a user
intent between callede like user desire
to do something the simplest simplest
case is I want to swap token a for B and
the one who provides the best price is
going to be like coding uh and competing
with others like you may run a fanasy
algorithm and connected to many
exchanges Texas by of course and running
this algorithm that will answer the user
instead but it can be other things like
nobody has uh a integration of a that
will let let any user uh put usdc cross
chain on another chain and earn a better
apy that's also a use case that can be
like fulfilled by an
agents all right uh I think we don't
have time for another question
unfortunately but feel free to catch man
after this and talk to him about
everything you want give it up for man
again for the wonderful talk thank
you lovely lovely all right how's every
I'm feeling energized yes let's let's
hear it you can do better come on come
on yeah yeah awesome so I hope you're
you're pumped for our next speaker our
next speaker is going to be MAA CI who
will give a talk titled wallet infra 101
and where Innovation needs to happen
meta is currently um a product uh person
for UNIS swap labs and in the talk MAA
we'll go over the infrastructure stack
of a standard wallet and then also go
into where in the stack Innovation
should happen or is already happening
and why that's exciting all right
welcome to the stage
[Music]
maida cool hey guys so as you can see I
actually changed the title of my talk
really last minute um but my name is MAA
gari and I lead product for all of the
wallet related things at Unis swap lab
so in this talk I want to cover uh some
of the incredible infrastructure
innovations that have happened over
recent years and why I think they're
going to bring in the next wave of users
in
crypto forgot my little
thing so when we talk about onboarding
the next billion users often The
Narrative online is focused on blaming
crypto ux for why we haven't had Mass
adoption yet but what does better crypto
ux really mean like if you look at a lot
of our apps they're already beautiful
they're clear they're comparable uh to
web to and based on recent breakout
successes for daps like poly Market or
trading Bots or whatever you use I feel
like it's safe to say that users are
willing to overcome a lot of friction to
do what they want um in my opinion what
crypto often lacks is more opinionated
products and what a lot of these
infrastructure innovations that I'm
about to highlight do is give developers
optionality to build more opinionated
products historically I think we've put
a lot of burden of choice on users for
every micro decision whether whether
it's how they store their seed frays
whether it's how they pay gas whether
it's what chain they're on everything
else so I find a more useful framing for
the crypto ux problem is how do we make
it easier for users to do more with
their balance before I get into these
Innovations I kind of wanted to set the
framing and identify core problems to a
really quick case study so for this I'm
going to use my dad as an example he's a
software engineer he's technologically
savvy he trades a lot on apps like Robin
Hood and trade for stocks and he knows
what Ethan Bitcoin are and holds some
but doesn't really know much about it he
doesn't really know about ER c20s l2s
the underlying technology anything else
so he somehow finds out about a token
this actually happened a few months ago
let's call it blah token and he asked me
for help um and so I help walk him
through how to how to buy it so I walk
him through the process he only has
crypto in his Robin account a Robin Hood
like centralized exchange account right
now and so I had to guide him through
downloading a non-cone wallet explain
what that non-custodial word meant and
then what a seed phrase was and why it
was so important and then I had to walk
him through transferring his eth from
the centralized exchange into this new
wallet but oh turns out the asset was on
base and he didn't have eth on base to
pay the gas and so I had to explain what
Bridges were what l2s were what gas was
and then we had to bridge his eth over
to base and then he was finally able to
swap the asset using Unis swap but of
course he had to reserve some of that
eth for gas
that took so many steps so much
education so much time and one of the
biggest issues I think all of us see in
the space right now is onboarding and my
dad specifically in this case was a very
high intent technical user and it took
him several minutes to create a wallet
and was thrown so many new Concepts
right up front currently I feel like
we're taking High intent users who
probably come in wanting to do something
wanting to try out a wallet or buy an
asset whatever and we end up surfacing
so many friction points for them that
they end up churning before even
completing the action that they
initially set out to do luckily though
there are so many infrastructure
advancements that have been made um
already that make this whole process
easier there are quite a few but for the
sake of time I want to focus on four so
the first one is account abstraction
specifically through EIP
7702 so account abstraction and smart
contract wallets have been in the
Zeitgeist for a while now but one of the
biggest issues with most of these
implementations is that they're not
compatible with eoas which are the most
popular form of existing wallets 7702
basically allows EAS to get some not all
of the benefits of account abstraction
without forcing users to fully migrate
into a smart contract wallet so while
this isn't fully comprehensive account
abstraction it does two things that I
think are really exciting one is gas
abstraction so in my dad's case he
wouldn't have to worry about the concept
of gas or gas tokens Etc and another
thing it does well is batch
transactions second is this growth of
multi-chain Standards so it's very clear
we're going through a multi-chain world
block spaces are getting more and more
specialized and I feel like we don't
give enough credit for how much ethereum
has evolved here like I remember just
even a few years ago going from one
chain to another was so so cumbersome
but now with intense based standards
like ERC 7683 which a couple other uh
speakers before me talked about and with
block space standards like the super
chain that optimism came up with and
just generally more options for
different types of bridging we have way
more of a unified experience for cross
chain interactions that are happening on
chain so now it's up to DBS to figure
out how they want to represent these
multi-chain interactions like how much
they want to abstract and how much they
don't but it is so so much
easier um the third thing I want to
mention is embedded wallets so as I
mentioned before onboarding is a huge
huge issue in the space right now and
all the Innovation happening around
embedded wallets allows users to create
wallets in seconds and also users can
use familiar Concepts like email or
social off or even pass Keys which are
becoming increasingly popular outside of
crypto and sophisticated Traders are
already taking in advantage of this Tech
when they're using certain telegram Bots
and things like that or daps that are
using things like privy or capsule under
the hood the last one that I want to
talk about is AI so can't forget that as
much as our industry is innovating so
are others everyone I think is aware of
the massive impact AI is having on
consumer apps right now and I'm pumped
about the Confluence of that and crypto
and I think there's a ton of stuff here
that I could talk about with AI
obviously but the ones that I want to
focus on are context and Discovery so
with AI we can rapidly give users more
context and information on the actions
that they're trying to do on chain as
well as the assets that they're trying
to buy a big issue another big issue I
see in crypto right now is Discovery and
I think fine-tuned AI can really help
with this so clearly right now is a best
time to build consumer apps in crypto
because of all this infrastructure
Innovation that's been happening so I
want to end with a call to action to
builders especially new Builders all of
these like new consumer apds um I hope
you guys build more opinionated apps
utilizing this tool chest of
infrastructure to give users the most
smooth experience possible thank
you thank you
MAA and we have time for a
question let's see okay and there you go
got it thanks for the talk very
inspiring I would like to ask like maybe
a meta question like if there's a top
Street app because we want you want to
build what will be the top three you can
recommend advice to build on that did
you say top three dabs I would recommend
building did I get oh yeah yes it's more
like your want to get your thoughts on
that for sure that's a great question um
let me think about
this um there are so many exciting
things right now I would say one is just
like a better information aggregator so
something that's like more personalized
based on your trading history and also
like assets that you own in a fun way um
I think that would be really exciting um
another one is like a multi-chain Dap
that's like super completely abstracted
so I saw some demos for this um that
some optimism devs did and I think stuff
like that would be really cool where the
end user doesn't have to like care about
the chain that they're on um but they're
able to interact with people who are
using multiple chains
um yeah thanks for the question lovely
we have time for another
question yes just speak
oh in your opinion what's the biggest
drawback to
7702 oh that's a great question um I
think there's two one is smart contract
risk so you're introducing just more
smart contract risk since you're
delegating to a contract um and then the
second one is just lock in so if we
don't um stay standardize the 7702
implementations that wallets do it could
lead to a case where like let's say I
have a seed phrase on like unisoft
wallet and then um it implements 7702
and I get all these like cool features
like gas abstraction but then I export
that private key and put it into like
let's say metamask or coinbase wallet or
whatever um and then suddenly those
guarantees are gone if they're not using
the same 7702 standard um so that's
something I do worry about thank you
thank you for your questions that's all
the time we have for them thanks again
MAA give it up for
MAA
lovely all right all right so for whom
is it their first
Devcon okay not not too many
second
third yeah
fourth ah oh nobody nobody's been to
Defcon four times no oh maybe next time
will be your forth fantastic so hope
you've been enjoying the talk so far
because we still have a couple coming up
before we take a break on the stage and
our next speaker is fuk Tha a researcher
at Ronan network fol is giving a talk
called from MPC wallets to Smart
contract accounts which will outline a
path for Mass adoption of smart contract
accounts by using an MPC wallet as a
transition
solution so we're going to find out all
about that from F welcome to the stage
F hello everyone uh my name is fuk Tha
I'm from sky so today I'm going to
talking about uh how to uh from MPC
wallet to rection so I think from the
previous talk uh we already understand
that uh the there is a lot of issue with
the current e is that it's were to
complex for uh some non non- Technical
and even technical users uh there's
inaccess inacessible uh Rec recovering
mechanisms uh so uh to solve this
problem we has qu um a few solution in
place already and uh I'm going to want
to highlight two uh uh main thing is uh
MPC wallet and AC rection so both of
them can offer uh a lot of help with uh
onboarding new users offer social login
uh op uh key Rec recovery and some uh
trans and policy so the differ between
NPCs and ation is uh most of the thing
uh MBC do a on the offchain including uh
uh kre and trans policy wise on account
tractions uh it have uh more
transparencies and everything can happen
on chain and with account rection we can
also uh do uh have more user can also
have more flexibility in uh a lot of uh
feature for convenience such as uh bing
transction gas sponsors uh and
Automation and uh something uh but um a
is Rel relatively new compared with the
MPC Technologies it is uh 40 technology
already and uh it's ready to be adopt
right
now
so uh yeah uh so the the pro one of the
problem with MPC that um users uh user
cannot have the Eno the flexibility uh
that account an offer but um with the
int introduction of 7702 uh we can uh
actually combine it with MPC to uh offer
a great have uh so this is a picture
from uh vitalic blocks that as we can
see here uh with MPC and
7702 we can active most of the goal uh
all the convenient goal that account
still uh can be active and some of the
security goal uh so suest like here we
can see that U automation can be done uh
if we can uh delegate the the the the
ACC to uh some uh the the Kissa that
start on the server uh uh G attractions
uh sponsor uh B and everything so so the
reason that uh 7702 can be a great
combinations with MPC wallet is that uh
the current infrastructure of MPCs uh
already in place that can have uh with
the sum of the feature of
7702 uh so one of the key thing I want
to highlight here is that the privilege
the escalation that uh in MPC we had uh
multiple Kat that stall in the user
device in the server uh that we already
had a system in place for this and with
7702 we can uh we can set the MPC
account to uh to set code for that
account to enable uh
delegation saw some access to the gyat
that in either in the client uh device
or in the the server that can do uh some
of the uh some of the uh operations that
user can do dayto day
and so another another thing that I want
to mention here is that uh one of the
problem with current MPC is that uh when
we select a thread hole for uh MPC we
usually need to invol a trade off for
example if we use like two two out three
thread hole some can be side without the
user knowing but if we use two out two
threat Hole uh then if the the every CH
need to be Side by user but uh the user
uh it the key cannot recover recover if
the user lost their sh the key shot and
they have not have any back up so uh
with the 7702 we can introduce a time
lock on chain key recovery that uh we
can had a uh either key shot can be
uh gain full access to the to the wallet
if it
and then the the other one do not had
challenge that in let's say a 30-day
periods so I think that's that it for
everyone thank
you thank you f we have some time for
questions so raise your hand if you want
to ask a question and I'll get the the
box to
you or if you're further in the back a
colleague of mine will do
it I know you want to know things this
is your
chance if not then I'll ask a question
and trust me you don't want to hear my
questions they're they're not going to
be that
good okay well I'll still do it um if
you want people to come away from this
with one thing and start implementing
that in their work what would that
be can you can you elaborate that a
little bit so we all go back home after
Devcon and you want people to do one
thing what's the thing that you want
people to do uh so I think the thing I
want people to do is to push our 7702 as
soon as
possible yeah cool
cool anyone have a
question or shall we call it
today yes amazing all right I think I
can do it
maybe yeah okay and one and two and
woo ah
almost okay so my question is uh a
little more on the gas abstraction part
I I know MPC wallets can be um connected
to AA wallets and um yeah uh my question
is is is there another solution that is
more sustainable compared to just
sponsoring the gas for every
transaction uh yeah can you can you
elaborate it a little bit uh yeah so
some some wallets because uh the most of
the non- Crypton native users don't have
a concept of gas that they have to pay
for each transaction uh a lot of
protocols and applications sponsor this
gas so that the user can uh can continue
continue with uh with using the
application and the way they do it is
that they fund the pay master and that
pay Master uh pays for the user
transaction fees and uh yeah my question
is how are there any solutions that you
think can make this um this sustainable
for the
applications so I think
uh so that is a good question but I I
think uh the the sponsor so this is uh
come from that if the the app uh
developer that they want to be more
convenience for the user so they want to
uh onboard more users so one of the
thing they can do is that they can ease
out the onboarding process and pay for
the gas for the user so I think that can
be a great help in in this
case all right uh that's all the time we
have for questions thanks again fol give
it up for fol for the wonderful
talk lovely lovely so uh this is going
to be the last talk before we take a
longer break on the stage uh but don't
don't go anywhere just yet there's still
one more and trust me you want to you
want to be here for this one and um
after that we're going to have an
hourlong break until 1 p.m. so enough
time to to have lunch enjoy some some
Thai food I don't know about you I'm
really loving it I live in Germany where
black pepper is considered spicy so I'm
really having the time of my life
enjoying things that actually taste like
things um fantastic so our next speaker
is going to be Nuno Nuno is a senior
product designer at the ethereum
foundation and the talk is called my
mother will not use
it right it's it's a great title so in
the talk Nuno will cover the different
mindsets designers need to improve and
optimize the work for web 3 so without
further Ado welcome to the stage our
last speaker of the morning session
[Music]
Nuno hey hey hello nice to see you all
so let's started I have a lot to cover
let's go back so my name is Nuno
designer at the foundation I work for
ethereum.org mostly that's where I spend
all my time and this is my talk I
submitted my talk based on this tweet
from Wesley that he said my mom will
never use crypto trying to optimize for
her is a waste of time and this
triggered something on me because I used
to on my other talks this is for each
prag uh back in June I guess I had one
slide with the same title amongst the
other things that I normally do and um
it's something that I it's a rant mostly
why that this this is something that we
hear a lot out there in other like
conversations out there like say my
mother will not use it oh this app is
not for my mother it's not for like it's
is something that always get me rank
that's why my mother why the Elder
generation would use this that's
something that it's almost around so
let's start with a question when did a
mass adoption of a technology started
with an NA generation can we pinpoint
something can we like from top of our
mind I can't that never happened I would
say never ever happened like take a of
salt I did not research this I'm just
saying out loud like might be something
out of this but I would say that it
never started and we are on the brink of
reolution so let's break even further so
why who is my mother let's try to
Persona who is our mother so this is my
mother my mother Deon Deon my mother
she's a lovely lady from Lisbon so nice
to meet you all she doesn't know he's
here so don't tell her I'm doxing
her so again let's see who is our mother
our mother might be like roughly if
average 30 years old in the audience if
she G gives birth at 25 she might be 55
plus something like that let's try to
put her in this um in this level she'll
be around this gap which make her a bit
a baby boomer and a genx beginning Gen X
probably halfway through Gen X but it
this is probably our mother collectively
like classify this like the generation
that we are sometime thinking of who's G
adopting so she watched this you know
what film this is show
hands okay some do she grew up this
technology this was the technology that
she was exposed at an influential level
like all of this probably some of you
still use this who got one show of hands
yay some so was impactful but in the end
like drilling down that analog
generation High trust in institutions in
the sense that they grew up like
trusting corporations trusting
governments in some countries I know but
like looking forward like post offices
Banks uh other corporations was um
something that was trust trustworthy
like um limits access to to um to
technology like they don't know how
things work they all I ask you probably
to you folks how things works and it's a
cultural shift for them to on board new
technology new stuff in on the digital
world so this is my second conclusion
why do we even bother thinking about
them when we are building products for
web 3 so I'm almost sure and that
everything that we will build will start
with a youngster generation and this is
one of the key points that I want to
bring regardless of what we build they
will follow so let's stop talking about
then my mother will will use it so to uh
Wesley's point this is a waste of time
probably to think about them has user
profiles has personal on how to Target
our audience of our products and even
more to all the genes and Alphas out
there there's a bunch of out there that
points out you guys and all your friends
and all your relatives about the same
generation will be the ones that going
to use a web project that we are
building right now they will have the
financial upside very soon so there's a
bunch of information that the great
wealth the great wealth transfer will
happen very soon because of the Baby
Boomers through the other Generations
they will have the financial incentive
to do so so it's not a question of money
to Target someone that has money so we
need to focus on the younger generation
to build the new set of products they
will be the next buildon users so let's
focus on them once and for all so let's
stop saying my mother will not use it
let's start saying the youth will not
use it my kid if you're a parent a young
parent my kid will not use it probably
like the ticktockers will use it
probably the swifties who knows they are
the ones that will probably use our
products so this is the key point that I
wanted to bring you guys let's start
building because this is to you and for
you above all and think about them and
don't think about your mother parents
grandmother whatever you think like this
and that's what I have to you today
thank
you thank you
Nuna we have time for some questions
raise your hand if you would like to ask
one it can be about your mother it can
be about nuno's mother don't ask me
about my mother you don't want to hear
that yes yes
yes come on last last push there is a
break after this ask a question and then
go out into the world knowing you've
accomplished great things at this
session question
question okay while you're think
everyone is hry I think so I know I know
while you're thinking I I'll ask one
question of my own uh so same as the one
I asked before if you want people to
take one thing from your talk and go
back to to their normal life what's the
one thing you want them to to take away
mostly as a designer I Target like
designers as well other builders that
are thinking new products keep critical
thinking on the way we approach I think
we take from Granite everything from web
2 and I've seen a lot of talk even one
before us that's always like let's do
web two way of doing web 3 and this
mostly one of the topics that I've bring
in in my talks probably I'm a little bit
older probably it's my generation I've
built something of of well to I was
around and we've did a lot of mistakes
and sometimes we are passing those
mistakes to web 3 as well so be critical
think uh a little bit beyond just what
you it's presented what it's easy to
present to the user and this is one
example if if the maturity of f
technology that we're building is going
to be like three five years in a row
like start building for the generation
that will use it not the elders not the
ones that probably now have the funds to
invest on you something like that
targets the ones that probably we'll use
it those will be the next billion that
was the thing that brought me to the
talk perfect thank you
anyone has come up with another question
in the
meantime yes amazing oh that will this
will be hard can
maybe okay yeah let's do it this
way this is a microphone okay it is yeah
uh what do Tik tokers
want that's the real question that we
all need to figure out that's that's not
an easy but we kind of know what's the
what they look like we can profile them
at this point and that's one of the
highlights like we know how they use we
know the interactions we know what
engage them to to probably use the
product that you're building we like
profiling like as a users we kind of
know them already so we need to
understand them
better all right another
question
nobody okay
in that case we'll conclude this
morning's session thank you so much for
being here thank you Nuno
again all right you've been a wonderful
audience thank you so much for
participating enjoy lunch enjoy Devcon
enjoy Bangkok the stage will have a 1H
hour break and it will be back at 1 p.m.
so don't miss out thanks again
[Music]
he
n
[Music]
B
o
[Music]
he oh
o
[Music]
you
n
[Music]
m
o
[Music]
sh sh
oh
[Music]
wo
o oh
[Music]
you
n
[Music]
B
o
[Music]
oh
he
[Music]
oh
t o
[Music]
I'm
you
[Music]
oh
o
[Music]
oh
n
[Music]
m
B
[Music]
o
oh
[Music]
the
oh
[Music]
o
B
[Music]
m
n
[Music]
w
B
[Music]
o
m m
[Music]
o
oo
[Music]
o oh
n
[Music]
to
B
[Music]
o
oh
[Music]
you w
m o
[Music]
o
I'm
back I'm back
[Music]
you
he
[Music]
o
oh
[Music]
a
you
[Music]
oh
Ro
[Music]
o o
C oh
[Music]
o
oh
[Music]
o
oo
[Music]
BL
m
he
[Music]
w
o
[Music]
m
nah
[Music]
oh
oo
[Music]
o
oh
[Music]
he
n
[Music]
bu bu bu w
o
[Music]
oh
n
[Music]
to
he
[Music]
t t
[Applause]
hello everyone welcome back to Dacon
stage workk this is a third day and this
is our afternoon session uh we're
starting this really in 10 stage right
now you know that this stage four it's
going to be a lot of lightning talk it
means that we'll have a lot of different
interesting idea come into come into to
us and we'll be rushing it a little bit
through so each speaker they'll speak
for a little bit and then you will get
to ask questions so when the speaker are
speaking remember to think of something
that you want to interact with them you
want to ask them you want to comment or
whatever we will have time for that um
my name is Vivian and I'm going to going
to be your MC for the whole afternoon so
bear with me I'm a little bit sick now
it's too cold in a Defcon venue but I
hope we can get through this all
together the first speaker in the
afternoon we're having is Tina Baker
Tyler and she is the CEO of Venice AI
it's a private permissionless and
generative AI platform and her talk is
going to be the future of AI why we need
private uncensored and permissionless AI
let's welcome
Tina hey guys I hope you're having a
great Devcon um it's great to be here
I've got five minutes so I'm going to go
really fast um bear with
me so imagine a small group of companies
control access to the most powerful
machine learning used by billions of
people worldwide they record all your AI
conversations monetize your data and
share it with governments on demand
everything you share is attached to your
identity
forever they record whoops what's going
on
here okay sorry about
that through
politicized content policies their AI
models are trained to coddle and
redirect you when you explore topics
determined to be taboo they restrict and
redact information and influence your
thinking based on their view of the
truth does this sound like Science
Fiction it's not it's already happening
the current AI development path leads to
a few powerful companies controlling the
technology and becoming the Arbiter of
Truth the race to dominate the consumer
AI Market is on open Ai and by proxy
Microsoft have a head start their
partnership puts AI in the hands of 1.5
billion iPhone users the Biden
administration's policies entrenched AI
development in the hands of a few
powerful entities accelerating
centralization that favors incumbents
it's notable that the newly appointed us
artificial intelligence Safety and
Security Board doesn't include any open
source or decentralized AI
leaders I believe AI should be
optionally private our interactions with
AI are personal and intimate this isn't
the polist this is not the right slide
either sorry
guys um this isn't the Pol social media
version of us it's raw honest
intellectual exploration would you share
your diary online that's the level of
vulnerability we expose when we use AI
without privacy
safeguards popular AI
tools store your inputs and outputs and
in many cases the platform owns the
outputs you create as I mentioned
earlier these inputs are attached to
your
identity platforms are vulnerable to
hackers which continually lead to
breaches does anyone remember Equifax
information held by governments is
equally vulnerable and the authorities
making the privacy rules can't even
protect their own data a recent EU
Parliament data breach expose sensitive
personal data of more than 8,000
staffers your data doesn't need to be
leaked to expose you to manipulation
Cambridge analytica demonstrated how
information can change the tech Giants
sorry the information you share with
tech Giants can be scraped without your
consent to create campaigns designed to
influence your
views we need to stop volunteering our
data and take control over what we share
with
AI I believe AI should be censored
centralized platforms censor according
to often opaque content policies
influenced by the values of those who
control the platform hidden behind
system prompts that are only revealed
through
jailbreaking users think they're
interacting with true machine
intelligence a calculator programmed to
do statistical inference on language in
reality they're engaging with
proprietary partiality within guardrails
imposed by humans who have their own
biases at best we receive nonsensical
outputs like Gemini producing black
vikings at worst human adulterated AI
can perpetuate the silencing of public
discourse no entity public or private
should monopolize or contextualized
truth open access to AI is under threat
Biden's AI executive order requires
licenses for large models that restrict
the number of parameters allowed
California proposed an AI bill which
includes criminalizing certain
open-source AI
developments the eu's AI Act is more
permissive of Open Source but strict
large scale but strict on large scale AI
I the authors the AXS author himself has
raised concerns that the regulatory bar
has been set too high a stark example of
excessive regulation backfiring France
based mistol and meta both recently
withheld their latest Open Eye Open
Source AI models from the EU preventing
an entire region from accessing
advancing AI politics Will play a role
in AI some push for tight controls
others Champion open source development
the back and forth highlights that ai's
future should not hinge on political
whims when confidence is when confidence
in our political leaders is waning do we
really trust them to regulate
intelligence AI is being adopted rapidly
a recent Harvard study found that nearly
40% of all us adults between 18 to 64
have used generative AI but unlike many
but unlike money sorry uh or social
media we don't need to change our
existing Behavior but we do need to
start as we intend to continue we must
seek out and use alternatives open
source permissionless AI evolve through
thoughtful iteration is impervious to
political fancy ideology and the
antidote to gate kept curated and
censored AI it's pretty easy for a
developer to run a small model privately
locally using olama or a similar Service
open source models are rapidly becoming
competitive surpassing closed Source
models on many benchmarks you can find a
plethora of Open Source models on
hugging phase I've listed a few here for
those who can't or don't want to run AI
locally we created Venice a generative
AI platform that embodies the principles
of permissionless you can chat with some
of the leading open source models too
large to run locally generate images
create and interact with AI characters
and write and debug code all in
private Venice uses decentralized
infrastructure to run the platform all
of your Venice activity is stored only
on your browser Venice never shares your
data with anyone we simply can't because
we never had it in the first place use
it anonymously and for free if you want
greater amount of inference or to access
the API you can upgrade to
Pro there's no doubt that AI would
change humanity and we should engage
with it but through mediums that are
optionally private uncensored and
permissionless
thanks hello okay that's amazing this is
time for question right now uh we
probably have time for one question
anyone have any burning question at the
moment about per permission AI it's kind
of an important part of uh oh we go yeah
uh one question
uh one question uh how do you how can
you in that system run lowas and run
your own your own uh lowas and your own
uh ER how was it called uh tuned tuned
models can you do that since do you say
you do not have the data on your servers
yeah so we provide access to open source
models we host those on our service we
we have a proxy service so when you send
in your prompt to Venice it's encrypted
sent bya proxy to a decentralized GPU
the response is also encrypted via proxy
and sent back to you on your browser so
nothing persists on Venice servers we
don't see your prompt we don't see the
response and it's never stored uh so I
cannot upload my own luras after I did
my own training um you can't upload your
own lauras um for training but just this
week hopefully later today so I might be
front running myself um we are uh going
live with image to image so you'll be
able to upload your own images and then
then you'll be able to Tool them on
Venice and recreate new images with a
base
image thank you that is our time for a
question thanks please connect with Tina
more after the event you'll be will you
be around I will be around and if
anybody wants a Venice t-shirt please
help me out because I have a backpack
full of them and I don't want to carry
them around anymore amazing and then we
are yes another round Applause for Tina
next we're welcoming our second speaker
of the afternoon we're following the AI
conversation this one will be sudir
UPA I hope I'm pronouncing correctly he
is the head of engineering team uh K
kinix by Morgan Stanley and he's going
to talk about privacy enabled smart
contract driven fair and transparent
reward mechanism in Federated AI sounds
fascinating that's welcome so
[Music]
there hello all thank um thank you
tatina for opening this because that's
that's something that I want to carry
forward what you just discussed um but
before I do that first of all I mean
it's a privilege and honor to be
speaking at this conference and one of
the most dynamic talented and perhaps
vibrant ecosystem developer ecosystem so
thank you Devcon for giving me this
opportunity to speak about here um so my
talk is based
on um so my talk is based on one of the
research work that me and my team had
done earlier and this paper received a
number of citations both from Academia
and uh you know industry combined so I
thought maybe this is a good opportunity
to share uh some of the thoughts that we
had around it with this community and
hopefully uh whatever we have started
this community can take it forward and
also you know um take it to completion
uh because some of the things that we
have started uh these are uh you know
solving some of the complex challenges
and I strongly believe and very much
optimistic that the if this can be
solved there will be this
community so
uh uh before I go further uh one of the
key things that I wanted to highlight
is I know there are a number of
discussions and topics around
decentralized AI you know pretty much
decentralize everything uh but in this
specific case uh I'm speaking about
something slightly different uh it is
about fed AI uh this concept uh is
something that started few years back by
Google where uh just giving you a quick
primer on this that there are multiple
multiple organizations uh can train uh
the data uh sorry machine learning
models locally and then they can share
the models not the data and this is a
very very important concept especially
with the privacy and regulations where
no institution want to share their
respective data but they are at least
willing to share uh the insights from
that data set in form of a model and in
this setup if you can see there are
multiple organizations each train
locally and then the share with the uh
you know aggregator which combines it
and hopefully the Bel is that a combined
model is much better performing than the
uh you know single
ones um how do we achieve it right um so
one of the Sol proposed solutions that
we have in the paper by the way a lot of
the details is in the paper itself at
this point I'm just highlighting a few
of the key top points and also some of
the challenges but one of the challenge
with adoption of this kind of technology
is everyone would like to know what's in
for me and how do I get get incentivized
for something that I'm actually
contributing towards a global model so
the the solution that we laid out is a
smart contract based contribution
analysis framework for FedEd learning
then we also design and develop Tech
techniques for FedEd contribution by the
way this fed contribution term to the
best of our knowledge did not exist
before so we think we actually coined
this
term um and then we also have enhanced
security for private messaging between
the contributor if you saw the prior uh
prior slide and the aggregator using uh
Dynamic key generation it uses
traditional cryptography and finally
leverage ethereum to build economics of
onchain reward and penalty just in case
some of the contributors are
malicious um one of the key things I
wanted to highlight and one before I
went to this uh you know this is the
stock Falls right in between
intersection of blockchain and AI so
some concepts are uh you know some of
the slides you'll see it's purely
machine learning and quickly
highlighting the uh ml part of it an ml
model at the underlying you know um at
the pretty much Foundation layer is uh a
set of metrics with set of numbers which
you can actually you know um which are
uh laid out in this
format uh in case of fed computation so
we have a number of metrics if you can
imagine in this in the diagram before we
had a number of contributor giving their
respective models and how do do we come
up with one single number that
identifies the contribution from each of
the contributors so we use fited
computation and if you some of you are
familiar with linear algebra uh it's
about leveraging uh provenience
normalization that two takes two metrics
and merges the two and comes out with
one single number to give us the number
final number finally how do we calculate
it so within the aggregation layer after
each round of aggregation Federated
contribution is recorded on chain each
of the clients receive that contribution
the client goes back and does the
evaluation again of that model against
its own data set and sends back the
performance the uh the actual
computation performance back to the
chain and then there's a smart contract
that picks it up and does the comp as
does the analysis of
that uh the the framework is fairly
simple I mean again the all the details
are in the paper however uh from a high
level perspective there's one smart
contract that manages the entire stack
there are three different functions and
one of the key functions in that is uh
how do you actually set the contribution
which is right at the center of the uh
you know
slide okay I think I just five minutes
any questions ex some answers maybe any
questions
it's quite a fascinating topic about
documenting the contribution any
question from the audience
yes we got one yes I get to throw this
amazing hi um so speaking of uh what
you've done your research on what is um
still open where um you maybe just name
a few Fields within Federated AI where
research still has to be done or are we
done oh yes actually this is a very very
active area of research um and some of
the key topics that are being researched
around identifying the malicious actors
U finding a way to incentivize what I
just described is how do you incentivize
the contributors to the global model um
and also like there are different
algorithms that are being discussed on
how do you optimize the end to-end
Communications so broadly speaking there
are a number of challenges at the same
time there are a number of opportunities
uh which are being explored at the
moment
we have a uh one the guy in a white
shirt
yes hi thanks for the great presentation
can you uh talk about some best practic
on incentive design how to get clients
to
contribute checkpoints that are
improvements and not going backwards on
the original model uh that's a great
question um in fact one of the the main
challenges in identifying the right
rewarding mechanism
is the how do you actually assess the
performance of the you know of the
global model right so one of the
challenges that we ran ran into uh was
each client can have a different data
set the quality of the data set could be
different uh the size could be different
uh the number of iterations could be
different uh and so one of the potential
practice or one of the potential
solution that we identified Again by the
way just just for a disclaimer some of
the work that we did uh was in a
permission uh Network um and that uh
normalizing some sort of global
normalization of uh attributes the
parameters and the training um
algorithms uh could bring uh could be
helpful in uh you know normalizing the
the or maybe come up coming up with the
the right metrics to combine otherwise
you could see very varying performances
which could be misleading um you know
um could give you misleading results
yeah we have time for one more question
oh actually time's up all right thank
you so much thank you again that was
very interesting uh so this day today we
actually had a lot of conversation
around real world uh ethereum
application and I guess disin AI is
actually a part of it right now next
we're also following the AI conversation
and then this one will be on the rise of
AI in web free development user
experience which is a very specific but
important topic the speaker is Stefan
tet sing uh Stefan is the AI software
engineer and a researcher at the
Forefront of integrating artificial
intelligence with with uh web Frey
that's welome
[Music]
Stefan yeah hello everyone my name is
Stefan tessing and I work with the remix
team and my talk today will be about the
rise of AI in U web predevelopment
area I will be much more on the
application site
site and yeah regarding at the uh at
what uh the AI can actually bring to the
web environment these are actually the
main application fields that AI can
bring a lot to first of all re the user
experience where we can incredibly um
enhance uh how the user actually
perceived the platform and also the
decentralized governance that I can
actually help to much more incentiv
incentivize this uh this term also the
creation of digital assets Al deals and
we cannot also we cannot speak about AI
in web Tre without talking about fraud
detection and also the
security aspect so actually in uh
enhancing the user experience is pretty
much easy here we have an example of the
remix platform where we have code
completion code explaining those are
pretty much low hanging fruits for those
who knows how llm works and yeah this
actually also already provides a lot of
yeah a lot of input for the user a lot
of value and next stage of uh providing
uh value for user is by having um
automated uh automated chat boards like
also AI support which are integrated in
the platform here again a remix example
where the AI chatboard is aware of what
the user is doing is always one step
ahead in order to kind of provide the
user a much more better experience and
so
forth yeah also the AI can be used for
creating um personnel I contain user
feeds creating also AI boards that will
be serve as Oracle for contract and also
provide investment
recommendation in create Digital Arts
which as we have already seen with nfts
and uh automatically generate metadata
for Market visibilities on different
platform without yeah sharing the
asset regarding at the security uh
aspect of how AI can actually improve
how we develop uh a web threee
application uh the it can actually
provide a much more secure development
mechanism just think about it when
you're about to deploy a contract and
there's a AI around it that kind of that
kind of pass the uh the contract and for
vulnerabilities and check pretty much
everything what goes around it and also
trans transaction there's AI maybe
sitting somewhere watching the
blockchain out the real time and kind of
flagging um fraudulent transactions and
so on so the AI sitting somewhere and
kind of doing um behavioral analysis and
profiling everything and yeah flag bad
stuff okay the last thing I will be
talking about is about agents agents is
like like a software layer on top of
yeah AI model which actually can perform
autonomous uh actions and having
interaction with AI in order to get out
out in order to provide base values and
those agent are actually able of kind of
doing uh
vulnerability scans uh help into
improving the decentralized governance
and also regarding the uh decentralized
Finance we can automate uh that U that
aspect of the web tree environment by
kind of providing uh best trading pets
best price best
algorithms for for that and also the
smart contract automation that the agent
can actually help with and
yeah I think that was pretty much my
talk
I am very much open to questions yes
thank you very
much anyone with question I see the
gentleman in the very back I don't think
I can throw that far thank
you uh
hello so I had basically two questions
my first question would be regarding the
remix AI so I actually you utilize remix
a lot um for contract development so
what I wanted to ask was like the
answers that remix AI provides how how
does remix handles like hallucination
over it the second is like so remix
remix AI on the back end uses like llm
so is that llm open sourced and what are
the basically things on which it is
trained at like Are there specific
contracts on which it is trained
at uh first of all regarding the har
ination uh I think it is a problem that
you cannot actually avoid with the noway
stage of development but we aim to kind
of reduce that uh uh by utilizing
uh state of the art models and to be
much precise regarding also the second
question that will be the open the Llama
model we use the latest llama model
which are available on hugan face and
yeah the are deployed on our backand and
very soon they will be able you will be
able as a private person to run it
locally on yeah at your own risk as I
would
say another gentleman over there yes uh
sorry I'm thank you very much very nice
box thank you uh I hear hear a lot of
things that a lot of people are talking
like how we can do better contracts how
can we do better chains and uh I feel
that we are talking too much about uh
the core layer like how to make the
things run and uh we're not talking
enough how to build a use things over it
like web apps Journal apps do things
that AI can uh improve here too or like
will it be more bring bringing more to
the table for a client part and uh high
level Builder part or it will be
bringing more to the table for lowlevel
like blockchain and Contra
I think it will be much more on a high
level perspective I that I will bring
that
value okay got it
thanks I think we have time for one last
question if there's any one last
question over there there's a gentleman
there you yes
amazing hi my name is Morris I'm working
on 42. money we're trying to generate
front ends for smart contract
specifically um what is your vision on
web 3 uh generation of UI uh we see a
lot of big players in web 2 but in web 3
there's not really uh competition
yet I mean my vision or my the way I say
it is that the future there is very is
very much bright we are right now at the
beginning of a of the era of mean AI
casing the web pre environment and and I
think it is pretty much opened you can
do pretty much everything you you would
like to do yeah okay
thanks okay amazing time's up for the
questions thank you again for being here
it was a incredible discussion thank you
let's give him a another a round of
applause next up we're rushing through
as you can see rushing through the
prison ations the conversation has been
good following AI continuing the AI
thread um the next presentation will be
about AI as an interface to the game
Roundup and our uh the person who will
be sharing this his name is not showing
on my screen right
now oh
yanis let's welome youran I hope I
pronounce it right a round of applause
to you Hest
[Music]
welcome hello my name is uh Johannes
feffer and I founded a company a project
called hyro that builds human Centric AI
agent systems and I'd like to talk about
a few aspects of AI as an interface to
blockchain so in February this year
there was this article article by
vitalic which spur this uh presentation
it's called the promise and challenges
of crypto and AI applications who of you
have read the article hands up
please okay only I see I see like four
five right well in the article um
vitalic has identified four main
categories of AI and crypto intersection
which with with which I agree a bit and
sometimes I disagree but let's go
through them real quick um so he sees a
as a player of the game as an interface
to the game as the rules of the game and
as the objective of the game right that
is these four uh categories I will have
to speed through the initial ones
because this is a lightning talk but
yeah well AI as the objective of the
game it means that the goal is to create
models that can compete with anthropic
and that com can compete with open AI
right and AI needs a lot of money to
develop and crypto start startups have
shown to be able to raise a lot of money
and large sums and this could actually
be a chance to create a competitor that
is better aligned with you with Humanity
right and there are great projects doing
this uh for example the sentian
foundation but also bit tenser and more
projects are coming up and I I'm I'm
like really looking forward because we
all need these models then uh there's AI
as a rules of the game this is something
I will just only very briefly touch on
the goal here is to be able to run and
call into a trusted Ai and so that Dows
can use AI for for example as judge
because we can prove the the computation
we can keep things secret we can prove
the training data and we can trust it
right we're not very far on that in that
area yet but uh yeah hopes are up and
the last two categories or the first two
ones uh are these AI as an interface to
the game and AI as a player in the game
and the goal here is to act on the
blockchain but how right so first you
need to give the AI tools you give them
research tools access the web and ICS
maybe scam detection maybe even
transaction simulation lots of apis and
then you also need to derive onchain
actions from intentions of the user and
that results in basically a unified
interface to blockchain
apps um but why are we excited about
this it is because there is no way that
humans can manage the complexity of our
ecosystem on our own let me illustrate
this a little why do we even need AI as
an interface well let's say you're just
a random dude or a random girl in this
world and you have heard there must be
an infinite Garden
somewhere and you go looking for it
right well you dive a bit deeper and
there it is ethereum Bitcoin salana gosi
1,000 blockchains 400 al2s 10,000 apps
or more and you're like wow but what
happens next is kind of sad because most
of the people that join this way they
either get scammed they buy a meme coin
and then they leave or they get confused
because it's all so much and they don't
understand it and they leave or maybe
they get rich and happy but
unfortunately the last category is
rather a minor
percentage the complexity is just huge
the human brain cannot comprehend it
fully even after many years in the space
and definitely not when you're new and
the space of change is only increasing
the speed of change is only increasing
most people that are uh new don't even
have a concrete intention yet right they
don't want to bridge from optimism to
fuel but they do smell the opportunity
they might have a notion of being part
of a DA or discover the infinite Garden
or say maybe I want to get rich but they
don't know how to get there and here
comes the thing autonomous agents are in
exactly in the same position the agent
and we have the same problems and likely
the same goals we and the agents are
using the same tools the same apis the
same everything to achieve these goals
so I argue that player in the game and
interface to the game is converging with
each
other from the perspective of the
blockchain there is no difference from
the perspective of the blockchain there
is no difference between a human player
and an uh an agentic
player the blockchain is agnostic to
that it is a neutral layer but there is
a difference on another dimension and
that is autonomy let's illustrate these
differences there let's Place existing
projects on the Spectrum so terminal of
truths is not really autonomous Andy is
curating the tweets before they get
posted but it's still some of the stuff
is foring autonomously hyro the product
I build is humancentric we're trying to
give control over the agents to humans
and coinbase based agent system that's
just an SDK you can build anything on
that Spectrum so let's take a step back
and see what this means if agent systems
and interfaces are converging and the
main differenti differentiator is the
degree of autonomy in what type of a
world will we live so here's my first
take in any complex system with
thousands of tools and especially in a
system that is neutral and uncensorable
we cannot compete with agents agents
never get tired they scale well and they
you'll never see a wor a worse version
of them than now the only option we have
if we don't want to give up our own
agency is to make use of Agents we will
most mostly use agents and agentic
interfaces to do stuff on ethereum and
on on all other corners of the internet
too and our best bet is that the
combination of humans and agents is more
effective than agents alone if that's
not the case then humanity is a big in
big
trouble so let's build agents for humans
and let let's make sure that humans are
not sidelined in permissionless systems
such as ethereum I want humans to play
in the infinite Garden
and that's what I'm building towards and
with this my time is up and I thank you
for listening if you're interested in
blockchain versus AI agents follow me on
Twitter and check out the human Centric
a agent system that we're building at
hyro thank you thank
you I love the way you concluded it it's
all about human and agents together uh
any burning question from our audience
oh Mary and there's a yes
hello uh great presentation I just
wanted to ask that if we as humans give
uh agents the whole permission is there
a way to control them because if we give
them the whole like transaction power
they can do transactions that we do not
want as humans to be executed and then
we might be in losses and then we might
wake up and see our whole account to
zero I see yeah of course very good
question and I'm not just say that
because it is one of the central
questions when uh we're trying to make
humans use AI agent systems right if the
agent is autonomous then we don't care
right if they lose their money and if
they do something well they are
autonomous but if we want to be in
control there has to be a lot of checks
that what the agent wants to do for us
on chain is actually what we want to do
on chain so our approach is uh to have
another model that uh basically tries to
match the intent of the user and the
transaction being suggested and score
that right so that but yeah the problem
is not solved with that it's just the
first step I think we have a long ways
to be can to be able to be 100% sure
that what the what an agent suggests and
wants to do for us is really what we
want to do I mean if you say that the
agent is autonomous it means that it can
take actions on its own right and it's
also responsible for its own actions
right that's the fully autonomous
version okay we have one over here yes
um my question is essentially uh could
you explain a little bit more about how
AI agents are an improvement over
something like robotic process
Automation and those kinds of thoughts
right so process automation is uh
something that we've done to to tackle
complexity too right but process
automation is not creative it turns out
that agents are really good at something
that we thought would be a domain of
humans and that's creativity coming up
with new ideas it a of what has already
been done and uh that's like if you to
automate a system in robotics or in
process control you actually have to do
a lot of work right you are doing the
work and then after that you you you you
gather the fruits from that and you uh
you have lots of efficiency but uh
agents because they are creative they
can actually do single tasks that you do
only a single time right and they
automate specialized tax and that's a
big big difference
uh one last question a quick one uh are
there any eips or ercs that are like uh
based on agents or are there any eips
like uh propose proposals oh um I'm not
really sure that if there are yet any
any eips because what that I know there
are several prod projects that are
trying to solve the problem of using AIS
from the blockchain calling into but I'm
not sure sorry I don't know okay no wor
thank you and that's it for our question
session I guess we can reach out to
yanes yes after this and let's give him
another round of applause thank you so
much for the
sharing uh next up we will have Killian
Kean is the senior computational
scientist at The Innovation game and
he's going to talk about the
coordinating intelligence open algorithm
development for science Ai and Beyond
that's well welome
kilia hello hello um my name is Killian
thank you for the kind introduction and
I'm going to talk about the Innovation
game um unfortunately the founder John
Fletcher couldn't make it due to
scheduling issues so I had to jump in
last minute um we are a Project based
out of Cambridge University um myself
I'm a PhD candidate in in astrophysics
and Dr John Fletcher is a applied
mathematician also from Cambridge so
what is the Innovation game well our
theme or our mission is to incentivize
algorithmic Innovation well what does it
exactly mean you may ask um if you look
at the scientific literature uh you see
that um most
problems um such as the traveling
salesman problem that you might know
right um finding the shortest distance
between let's say 20
this kind of problem is a hard problem
to solve and you can only solve it
through like various types of algorithms
what you see in this graph is on the
x-axis um the year on the y-axis you see
like some kind of performance metrics
when you run these algorithms so for
instance uh in the first let's say 1940s
to 1970s for let's say the traveling
salesman problem people have been just
brute forcing Solutions which is not
very efficient right so you have for
instance uh uh a performance of one a
constant right but then people started
to innovate on the algorithm site um and
what they achieved is like um magnitudes
of order of performance boost just by
having an algorthm for instance the red
curve you see um it is two to the power
40 more efficient to innovate on the
algorithm sign for a given problem
versus uh another algorithm like the the
blue ones and then the green ones as
well why do we care well you can achieve
a lot of breakthroughs
just by not just by optimizing Hardware
but we by um innovating in the algorithm
space right um and why I'm talking about
that in in the blockchain conference
well our protocol is there to
incentivize this kind of algorithmic
breakthrough and how do we do that we
actually using blockchain technology
um you may know that uh blockchain is
more about like transactions Etc
and how do we achieve that kind of like
algorithmic Breakthrough and how do we
incentivize that right uh we are
actually using the proof of work
mechanism such as um you might know from
Bitcoin and basically
having uh many algorithms together um
and then Benchmark those and find the
best ones for a given problem right so
let's say you have for the traveling
salesman problem you have four uh
different kinds of algorithm people have
been implementing and then you use the
benchmarking process which is the proof
of work mechanism where you mine for the
best algorithm right and once you found
the best algorithm you basically reward
uh the people that have been providing
the IP to our platform but also the
minor who has been uh providing Computer
Resources so on the right side you
basically see how our system works um
just as a S note of course we also need
to verify that the algorithms uh that
were submitted to our platform also
correct so that means uh is the solution
correct but also is the method correct
right um and how do we capture value for
the innovator well we can basically
um uh run uh two licenses for the
proprietary or for the open source
algorithm one the open license uh open
data license that means any algorithm
that is found through our platform uh
can be used for free if you also publish
the data why is that relevant well
imagine you have a scientific paper in
biology would you trust the paper if
you're not providing the data as well no
right it's very
unscientific um so we are following the
AOS of Open Source or Academia through
this license and the other license is
okay I don't want to publish my data but
I can use uh pay a small fee like a
license to access the
algorithm and what we are basically
doing is we are combating through the
Innovation game uh the centralization
risk uh through Aid driven algorithms so
what does it mean nowadays you have
large language models and it is possible
to Now look for um solutions by using
large language models which is not very
good because that means uh suddenly your
um hard um Innovation is directly
dependent on the amount of compute you
provide which is um bad because most of
the large capital for these Computing uh
platforms are at meta Google Etc but we
are based at The Innovation game we are
the only protocol as of now that can
incentivize and combat this type of um
AI driven algorithm development by um
incentivizing and rewarding the people
that provide our IP to our platform
thank
you thank you
Killian you have have any questions from
the audience for
Killian one over there you want to try I
don't think so I'm
[Laughter]
sorry okay time to work out Kean thanks
for that uh so on that chart of
algorithm development over time I
noticed there were quite large step
functions do you expect that algorith Al
algorithmic development is continuous
enough for the rewards to actually
incentivize the actors um yeah so we
fact that most of the people that use
our platform are probably not innovating
uh they are more like benchmarkers or
like they look at existing algorithms
and then optimize the code a little bit
so we expect that it's very difficult to
innovate but we want to incentivize this
behavior um and
the um challenges that we include in our
or let's say mathematical
computationally challenging problems
that we include our platform are various
sorts of for Relevant for blockchain
would be for instance ZK proving
mechanism right it is uh hard to compute
a proof generally but it's easy to
verify right so this is very um very uh
relevant for let's say the blockchain
industry um if people are innovating on
our platform other areas could include
AI that we also work on um and yeah
other uh theoretical computer comput
computer science um problems as well
thank you we have time for one more
question it's over
there I have a funny one so you maybe
people don't hear know but there was a
mess up and everyone got an email about
the Innovation game all the speakers so
did it uh do anything for awareness of
what of the work that you're doing or
did it have no effect because I'm here
because I got that email too of the
Innovation game could you repeat the
question I couldn't so from the Defcon
committee there was a an email that was
sent out to everyone who uh ever applied
for a speaker slot and that included uh
it was a it was an incorrect email but
it it included The Innovation game so I
was just wondering did it do anything
for the awareness of what you're working
on or did it have no effect cuz I
thought it
would sorry I couldn't catch your
question could you please like close
speak closer to the mic or you can come
after a talk I'm sorry I couldn't
understand it we can come we can talk
afterwards
yeah it's okay I guess we'll have
private conversation around that
question after the session uh anyone
else we still have a little bit of the
opening for
question one over
here I'll just ask a very general
question um what would you like us to do
with this information sorry what do you
want us to do with this information now
like where do you want us to go research
in or so you can reach out to us if you
have any hard problem let's say in Defi
and you want to formulate let's say a
computational problem you can reach out
to us or if you're Hardware or like
benchmarker you can use our system to to
mine and Benchmark these different
algorithms so there are two approaches
either you want to provide a challenge
for us um or you want to provide compute
or maybe you're a developer you want to
provide actually an algorithm so there
these
tracks amazing that's time for us thank
you again kilan uh another round of
applause for
Killian okay next uh we actually have
hir sidiki she is the CEO of polarity
Network a project aiming to create
self-managed and interoperable profiles
fostering personalized experience in the
decentralized uh digital landscape uh
and she's going to share about the
abstract wallets and chained fruit
profiles that's
welcome
[Music]
herea hey everyone I'm H I'm co-founder
of plurality Network can you guys hear
me at the back as
well okay perfect so today we are going
to be talking about profiles and wallets
and specifically how we can abstract
wallets and chains through profiles but
before we do that let's take a trip down
the memory lane over the past two
decades we have seen an immense growth
on the internet we started in early
2000s with the web 1 phase of the
internet where users could just read and
consume information just like in a
newspaper then came along web where not
only could users uh consume information
but also interact with the information
online this is the first time in the
history of internet where users actually
existed on the internet as individuals
and also when people actually started
having meaningful connections on the
internet and that is why we saw a huge
growth in this phase of the internet and
now everyone here we are all working
towards building the foundations of the
third phase of Internet which is web 3
where users could not only read and
write information but also own a piece
of the
internet so we've been talking a lot
about onboarding the masses to web 3 but
web 2 already did that and it did it
pretty well I mean it had its problems
but um the majority of the world is
already on web 2 so how did they
actually do it how were they able to
actually engage and retain so many users
and the reason for that was the unit of
interaction the key component the unit
of interaction of a web2 platform is a
profile profiles have three distinct
functions these are identification of
users contextualizing their interactions
and personalizing their experiences
however it's all inside one platform
where the profile was created so
identification means you go to a
platform you create a profile you put up
your profile picture your username some
information and then everything that you
do on that platform gets stacked to that
profile so that's how web2 platforms
identify the users
contextualizing their interactions means
that every profile has an attached
context and reputation so for example if
there is an account that has a huge
enough reputation then the content
that's coming from that account has more
trust more credibility as compared to an
account that has no reputation attached
to it so even if the information is
actually the same you're more likely to
trust a one that has more
reputation and then profiles could also
personalize user experiences so every
person on the internet is unique we all
want different things we all have
different interests different
preferences and profiles could actually
help personalize the experiences through
curation so uh showing you the content
that you want to see recommending you
the content that you are most likely to
engage with or like and helping you
discover the content of your choice
easily and quickly and this
personalization was actually one of the
biggest reasons why web2 platforms were
so sticky and
addictive but all of it was siloed
inside one platform it could be censored
your profile could be deleted at any
time and you had absolutely no ownership
over your own
profile and this is how the unit of
interaction in web 2 looked like now in
contrast let's think about what is the
unit of interaction in web 3 that is
actually a wallet so what is a wallet a
pseudonymous address which can sign some
transactions what a wallet does not have
have is any semblance of user
information interest or preferences
reputation social graph or anything of
the sort that a profile had and that a
profile used for creating engaging and
retaining um experiences and that is why
we have this cold start problem and
retention problems in web
3 the little context that gets generated
in web3 for example through buying an
nft or doing a transaction gets further
fragmented across the hundreds of layer
ones and layer twos that we have built
which makes this problem even
worse so therefore I propose to change
the unit of interaction in web 3 to a
profile as well and to do that we are
building a decentralized profiles
protocol at the intersection of identity
data and wallets these profiles are
self- custodial and interoperable
amongst any blockchain or any web2
platform even and the data in these
profiles is sourced from the various web
2 and web 3 sources where the user
already has a
presence the idea is you create your
profile once and then you use it
anywhere the wallet and chain related
complexities are all hidden behind the
profile and you give the users the same
user experience that they are already
familiar with and what they've been
using for the past two
decades we call these as smart profiles
which are privacy preserving
interoperable self- Sovereign and they
completely abstract away wallet and
James thank you that's all thank you
Hira this is a fascinating sharing and a
very important issues that with a lot of
people has been trying to solve recently
um do we have any question in the
audience for okay the
one uh I think he want to do
it hello I'm angel from open World um
what's the benefit to a user
uh in creating one of these profiles and
then second what's the benefit to
someone like open world uh which is a
defi platform to having that profile
available to us to kind of you know use
yeah so for the user it's easier because
like right now interacting with a wallet
is very difficult you have to download
wallet you have to figure out free
phrases you have to figure out and then
when even after you do all of that when
you go to a platform it's like an empty
slate it's like you're starting from
scratch if you already have profile you
just create it once you can take it
anywhere and you don't have to worry
about wallets or chains or anything like
that because the abstraction layer that
we are building comp it it it has chain
abstraction built in uh and liquidity
aggregation as well so user does not
have to care about any of that so from
the user perspective it's easier ux from
the platforms perspective so for example
you mentioned defi so of course
different platforms can have uh
different kind of needs for what kind of
data do they want from the user so one
example could be like reputation or
maybe the kind of Trades that the user
already has done so you can actually
show them more relevant content on your
platform and there is a golden rule for
websites is called the 7c rule so you
have only 7 Seconds when a user lands on
your platform to actually show them
something that catches their interest
and you cannot do that if you if you
have no information about them and this
is what web two platforms have been
using in order to use the same uh tried
and interested proven principles in web
3 it cannot happen without having any
information about the user user so
that's why profiles are
important anything anyone else yeah
yes um how are you hoping that this will
incentivize folks who are not in the web
3 space at all don't have a wallet but
have profiles to essentially join the
space yeah so what we want to do is like
uh how do you how do you explore a new
web two platform for example you just
see somewhere oh this looks really cool
and you just go there and you you know
connect sign in with Gmail or whatever
and then you just enjoy that platform
why can't we have the same experience in
web 3 so let's say you saw somewhere on
Twitter or wherever you are you saw some
place or maybe some some friend told you
oh this is a really nice game or this is
a really cool platform or this is a
really cool uh social media and you just
go there you sign in with your Twitter
let's say you maybe connect your
existing Instagram or Facebook or if you
have a lens of farcaster whatever
whatever you have and then boom you're
in and then you're enjoying the platform
without having to worry about oh I'm on
Solana so I need Solana tokens to do
this oh I'm on this so I I I I need
another token for this or even thinking
about I need this wallet for this
platform and not this wallet but this
wallet for that platform all of this
needs to go away and when we actually uh
we believe that profiles are uh are a ux
experience that everyone is already
familiar with so it would not even uh
look clanky or feel like users do not
even feel the friction they would just
use it as any other Web Two web two
website thank you um we have little time
for one more question but that's that's
thank you so we have 5 billion people
using uh social media yeah and
approximately they spend 2 hours daily
it makes 36 days in a year and we have
800 million people in crypto okay yeah
so if you go outside of this building we
have billions of people not using the
web threee wallets and whatever we talk
about it here so how you see the user
Journey how you see the on boarding the
people who are not aware and do you have
any Clear Vision of uh let's see the
migration of the web to users to your
platform so I believe that the users
should join web tree because they're
getting something interesting there
right so at the end of the day it comes
down to the applications that that get
built because the value acral should not
be that oh it's web3 it's cool just join
there it should be about something about
the platform or the app that they are
joining because web3 also introduces a
lot of incentivization mechanisms like
ownership or Rewards or tokens and all
of this stuff but the problem is that
you even if you build apps that are good
enough for or or have enough um you know
functionality for people to join the
onboarding journey is still very
difficult so you have two problems to
solve one is the onboarding journey and
the second is the application Level if
you can build the applications that's
something that the community has to do
what we are trying to do is once there
is an application that the user finds
interesting then the onboarding should
be as seamless as any other website so
you don't need to bombard them with with
all the web3 related technicalities so
that's our thesis at least and that's it
for our time today thank you so much
give up that way let's give her another
round of applause and then next up we
have James Morgan James is the
engineering director for eBay web free
team and he's going to share eBay and
web free powered digital product
passport and what this could mean for
the future of Commerce let's welcome
James
[Applause]
hi everyone thanks for coming to me see
my talk so I guess we got straight into
it we've only got seven minutes
yeah yeah so who am I so my name is
James I am the engineering director for
eBay small but hopefully impactful web 3
team uh I came from an acquisition about
two years ago of an nft platform called
known origin now really myself and my
team are really interested in looking at
the web three landscape looking at the
eBay machine as it stands now and seeing
how this technology can potentially
impact them and find value for buyers
and sellers and today I'm going to talk
about a topic called digital product
passports and why I intrinsically
believe web 3 is the right place for
them um and I'm going to touch on four
topics today uh a topic called connected
products digital product PR Sports we'll
talk about web 3 and we'll talk about
Commerce but first I want to set the
scene and provide a little bit of vision
of what Commerce could look like so you
got to bear with me with this right so
you walk into an office you see your
colleagues stood around a board maybe
you're discussing the latest mem coin
you've got your Vision Pro 5000s on some
AR enabled glasses not only that it's
looked in your address book and it's
noticed the pfps of your colleagues and
displayed them on screen you know shout
out to any x copy or squiggle holders in
the in the room not only that it's
noticed that your friend Dan at the
board has got a killer watch and the
latest greatest in sneakers these
products are connected you've got to
find out more or you double tap your
fingers some Machine Vision or AI Vision
scans these items uniquely identifies
them and starts working out exactly
which unique product they are not the
product skew the actual unique product
after that the digital product passport
pops up a digital layer linking the
physical product directly in your face
now this is a vision piece only right
but you can see the potential you know
and and you might notice as well this is
very much similar to how maybe nft
platforms uh looked trading nfts a few
years ago from this digital link you can
see ownership you might see if it's got
a warranty you might see trading uh
activity on the secondary Market
traceability servicing in uh insights
this is the vision that I want to talk
about today and this is my vision and
potentially the Future Vision of how
Commerce might look in several years
time but wait before we go on I think
it's worth touching about some of the
problems and challenges in Commerce at
the moment and you know the first three
topics you know the supply chain the
supply chain is very difficult to
Wrangle for physical Goods aggregating
lots of disperate information maybe the
digital passport is the perfect layer
for this you know circularity I bought a
good on the primary Market how do I sell
it there's many websites many
marketplaces all have different pros and
cons maybe the product passport is the
place where circularity will start maybe
it will also tell you how to recycle
this good at the end of its life maybe
this product passports the place where
you'll get additional utility after your
first transactional engagement with that
brand or with that shop and finally the
last three um there's some emerging
regulatory uh um insights coming from
the EU so from 2026 2027 the EU will
mandate digital product passports in
things like batteries fashion white
goods Collectibles now the goal is to
make things more circular and give
consumers more Choice maybe a tokenized
digital product passport is the place
where that will happen um the last two
digital physical experiences a lot of
the nft space sort of tried to tackle
this over the last few few years with
some mixed success maybe starting with a
physical and adding on a digital is the
right approach and then interoperability
for your items for the things you own
physically how do you interrupt with the
wider world again maybe this digital
layer so this is the vision I've
presented slightly wacky really lowf you
know this is not what we're building
this is a vision piece um
but really what does it enable it
enables a digital lir on physical which
is interactive product experiences
realtime information about your good you
know empowering customers um and then
interoperability where you you know you
can take your physical good and use it
anywhere and this is again what these
could enabled and then really quickly
I've only got a minute left last but not
least what is this so first of all uh a
physical item and a product connector
really a connector comes in many forms
QR codes RFD NFC chips you know Machine
Vision we spoke about and then you got
this digital layer and this is what I
talk about uh for digital passports and
this could be you can own this thing
right that's what crypto enables
ownership of digital items um quickly a
few industry examples 30 seconds left
there is already people playing in this
game in the fashion space in the luxury
space you know maybe onchain is the next
online and this change in consumer
Behavior will be a big driver for web2
adoption Beyond training stons and mean
coins um and finally W eBay care it's
massive we've got to be ahead of these
Trends and Y web 3 it's credibly neutral
it's a base layer for enemies can play
together lots of composable great
standards to build on and
interoperability and ownership and
that's it thank you very much okay thank
you that is very very interesting in a
very real world um uh do we have any
questions in the
audience let's see anyone okay
cool
o hello James hello um quick question uh
when do you imagine a plat a global
platform like eBay uh showing its
regular users as I don't know an icon
and some verified as something that says
this come with a DPP and of course you
can check it visually but when you
acquire this pair of sneakers this watch
whatever uh well you will also acquire
this this digital
passport is there some form of a
estimate timeline or yeah so I guess you
know we may already be playing in this
place uh this place in Pilots but you
may not notice and you know we also go
down the Mantra of you know eBay users
don't really care exactly you know what
we're doing as long as they get lot of
Great Value from it so maybe we're
already doing this and they don't know
and maybe next year it'll sort of be
pushed up the ranking
and things will become clearer so but
there's also lots of luxury Brands
already playing in this place is the
reality just right over there oh nice
hey James um based on uh eBay's uh sales
numbers and and that what throughput do
you think that you need from the
underlying technology to to serve your
users well that's a good question well I
guess you know to get to eBay scale you
know the the end game you know it's hard
to really talk about it's a reality it's
hard really say stuff in public but you
know eBay is a big huge user base
billions of products hundreds of
millions of users you know in the last
two years with the rise of l2s there's
an an act credible path for actually how
to achieve the throughput and the scale
that eBay and that's what we'll be
keeping an eye on you know as that space
emerges one more question and the last
one right over there the uh gentlemen
the
cap it's going to be from over there yes
beautiful um
I forgot to admit I'm a bit confused as
to what would be the advantage for for
the end user this feels like a lot of
overwhelming
information that might not be tangibly
beneficial and it also frankly seems
like a bit of a privacy nightmare I I
can see how aggregating all of this kind
of information in a not centralized but
central point of identity could could be
problematic so are there any
do do you also Envision the level of of
privacy associated with that yeah so
privacy first very true you know we we
think about this a lot and you know
there there's is it right that you know
this wallet owns 10 Rolexes probably not
you know but we look at Technologies
like uh you like providing proofs
selective disclosure you know zero
knowledge stuff you know that's really
where I think this will go and it'll
ultimately be at the behest of the
holder of how much information that they
should disclose I do agree that privacy
is a big issue in this physical space
much more than in digital is the reality
um I can't remember your first question
sorry okay so that's it for our question
session today and can please reach out
to James if you have any further
question any discussion you want to
continue thank you again thank
you next up we have Edwin Aoki admin
Aoki is the PayPal tech technology
fellow in the city of of PayPal's
blockchain crypto and digital currency
unit and today he's going to share with
us uh stable coin technicalities
Innovation challenges and the
opportunity that's welcome that's
welcome
[Music]
Edwin good afternoon can you hear me
back there all good
you know when we at PayPal started
thinking about building a stable coin
that was going to form the basis of a
new way to pay it was obvious to us that
it was going to launch as an
erc20 because after all the
programmability the ubiquity the
strength of the developer community and
the bread and the commitment to
continual Innovation and evolution of
the core made it an obvious choice for
us to launch for a token that we knew
was going to become a global Mass Market
adopted activity
we had this hypothesis that by combining
the combining the structural advantages
of a open-source distributed
decentralized network with the kinds of
innovations that can run on top of a
foundation of uh fast secure lowcost
transparent transactions would be a
GameChanger for financial services and
how we move money around the world
because most of the time that money
moves today using Technologies and
systems like a networks correspondent
Banking and wire transfer systems that
are literally over50 years
old and when we actually launched in
August of 2023 with PUSD we were pleased
and actually somewhat relieved to find
out that that hypothesis was correct the
ink was barely dry on the virtual sort
of press release that we did before we
started hearing from Regulators from
crypto enthusiasts from from press from
media uh and from uh uh normal customers
and and Merchants that we were on to
something and that was especially
interesting because these are not
audiences that typically tend to agree
especially when it comes to things like
crypto what we found at the time was
that the uh promise of what we were
trying to
offer through that was actually quite
interesting and the community started to
follow shortly thereafter
and that was particularly noteworthy for
us because actually the road to
launching PUSD for us was a little bit
Rocky at least in The Last Mile because
you see PUSD as a token is regulated and
green lit green listed by the New York
Department of Financial Services the
reserves that we have are held
bankruptcy remote in a limited purpose
trust in the name of token holders and
both PayPal and paxos our issuing
partner are regulated financial services
companies in the US and elsewhere and
what that meant was that before we could
launch we actually had to seek a lot of
regulatory approvals and what that meant
in turn was that even though it was
widely speculated that PayPal was
working on a stable coin for some time
we couldn't actually talk about it to
anyone until literally the day before we
launched which is not great from a
product launch
perspective fortunately the community
all of you delivered and within a few
hours after launch you could move your
py USD from your PayPal wallet to your
metamask wallet you could explore
transactions using your favorite
blockchain Explorer you can embed PUSD
into your existing environments and daps
our friends over at yellow card
integrated py USD pretty quickly and
they allowed for the movement of funds
from a venmo wallet for example to
Yellow Card in Africa where the cost of
moving money from 100 sorry the cost of
moving $100 from venmo in the United
States to Malawi was 40% less than
equivalent operation through traditional
payments
rails uh fire blocks integrated it for
businesses so that businesses that
wanted to take advantage of digital
asset payments but were waiting for a
trusted well-known and well understood
Financial brand to be able to get on the
bandwagon could finally do so in fact in
the few weeks after launch over 150
countries had access to py USD through
dozens and dozens of Market participants
in
exchanges but of course ethereum isn't
perfect yet anyway right gas fees can be
unpredictable and are known to spike
from time to time the transparency that
we love about ethereum makes it
difficult to perform certain kinds of uh
sensitive Financial transactions like
payroll or businessto business where you
don't necessarily want to expose the
salaries of all of your team members or
your intimate business records to the
public internet and of course the ease
of use that we talked about in terms of
being able to bring PUSD online for us
meant that it was easy for scammers to
go and create impostor coins or other
kinds of fake airdrops that would
attempt to separate people from their
hard-earned
money and that comes back to all of you
because you are the lifeblood and the
power that actually drives Innovation
and why we are particularly interested
in tracking the eips around things like
extending account abstraction around
faster times to settlement and new
capabilities that are bringing online in
De core the things that we need to
extend py USD for payments we're excited
by what's going on the L2 space that
allows us to address some of the
scalability and Performance challenges
that I mentioned earlier and bring new
kinds of tokens uh to light and we're
excited in particular about being able
to partner with the daps the defi
applications and also more importantly
for us the trafi companies that are
really uh like sap and ey that are
really set up to create Market fit for
the entirety of global Commerce and
that's one of the reasons why we are
committed to and being proud to be part
of this environment uh we have announced
recently that as part of that commitment
that we've just launched in conjunction
with uh our friends at paos and layer
zero a bridge that will allow for the
interoperability of py USD on ethereum
to salana uh you can get that on Galaxy
today and we think that that is going to
extend and further expand the utility
and the interoperability of py USD for
both Commerce and defi
we're just getting started so we invite
you to join us in going and and
revolutionizing digital Commerce through
digital uh assets and and defi thank you
very much thank you Edwin we probably
have time for one to two question right
now anyone with any question this is
fascinating
sharing any audience one gentlemen over
there okay let's let's try this please
catch
uhoh this is the most entertaining part
is watching I know I um you were
mentioning like uh like business
transactions payroll where privacy is
important uh what's what's your path
what's your road map with pay all USD
what where direct which direction you
see or what you working on to to help
for that yeah so we're working with the
various protocols including um uh the
folks that uh are are part of the
ecosystem to incorporate more of the
Privacy preserving Technologies into the
substrate of both the core and the
application layer of what we're doing
one example of that um I know this is an
ethereum conference one example of that
is that salana has recently implemented
a confidential transfers token extension
which allows for amounts to be masked on
chain and that is actually really
important because that means that
although you can still have the
transparency of seeing that transactions
are occurring things like amounts and
and certain other details are encrypted
and kept uh away from prying eyes so
that's an example of the kinds of things
that we're working with the rest of the
community and that we invite all of you
to help us support as we really try to
uh optimize these uh protocols for
payments great one last
question one last question
anyone in the audience one over
here I was hoping to have to throw the
box like into the back yeah no one
raised their hand all right um so just
um you mentioned sap um earlier I
couldn't quite get that can you maybe
speak or elaborate a bit more their
position what you think that's
interesting yeah so sap uh announced uh
a couple of weeks ago maybe about a
month ago that uh PUSD is now a
invoiceable currency in their uh digital
Hub and what that means is that any of
the fortune 1000 companies that are
using sap zrp system today can without
changing their back end start to invoice
their customers uh with PUSD and collect
that in through um us or coinbase or
other uh interactions that they may be
uh connected to now what's really
interesting about that is that you know
when we talk about being able to reach
the next billion or two users um habits
die hard and that's especially true in
large Enterprise and so the more that we
can plug into existing systems and
existing ways that CFOs and corporate
treasuries and accountants are working
today the more that we can get that in
there and as an example uh PayPal is now
starting to pay its invoices to
companies like ey with py
USD oh suddenly we have two over there
but we're actually I'm okay let's take
one more uh the gentleman at blue shirt
last one last one it's going to be a
quick one um where are our
box it's over
there yay thank you if you can rate from
1 to 10 how decentralize the token
is well as a reserve back token where
there is a single store of value and a
trust uh and as I said a trust account
that's there it's you know that aspect
of it is not decentralized obviously the
uh base level protocols which allow for
the movement on chain are you can move
PUSD into you know your own personal
wallets you can uh use them in defi so
on that standpoint um there is
decentralization there but when you get
a reserve back stable coin um there's
always some component of centralization
to that thank you thank you another
round of applause for
Edwin and that's a wrap for the first
session in the afternoon at state for we
will start again at 3 3 p.m. sharp we're
not going to wait for anyone just
starting at 3 p.m. please remember to
come back after that we'll have
discussion around the centralized
identity different organization
Innovative funding mechanism look
forward to seeing you here thank you
[Music]
G
m
n
[Music]
the
o o o
[Music]
I'm
oh
[Music]
B
o oo
[Music]
he
to
[Music]
he
o
[Music]
see
you
[Music]
oh
B
[Music]
o
up
[Music]
n
oh
[Music]
o
oo
[Music]
n
oh
[Music]
dou
o oh
[Music]
o
you
[Music]
this
he
[Music]
oo t t
o I'm
[Music]
m
n
[Music]
it's
oo o
[Music]
back
oh
[Music]
to
B
[Music]
o oo
he
oh
[Music]
he
o
[Music]
e
you
[Music]
he
o
[Music]
I'm o
o
[Music]
n
oh
[Music]
wo w
o
[Music]
is
hello everyone thank you for joining us
back at stage four of deathcon this is a
third day and this is the second session
of our of our stage uh today we're going
to have so many different interesting
topic to pack including identity co-ops
and different funding mechanism it's
going to be awesome before we start
please note that this is a lightning
stage which means that all of the
sharing will be in a shorter man manner
uh each speaker will have five five
minutes to share what they want to share
about and then you'll have three minutes
to think uh to share the question and
then interact with each other so
remember when the speaker is sharing pay
attention and then think of what you
might want to ask them or comment or
anything
and uh in a session we'll have 10
different speakers talking about
different ideas let's dive into it first
we'll have our first speaker yanis yanis
is a software engineer at the psse team
and right now he'll be talking about
bringing real world identity on chain
let's welcome yanis
hi everybody I hope that you're super
excited I have uh five minutes to um
convince you that we can we can turn
this uh into this so basically uh what
I'm going to introduce is um the concept
of like signed digital identities um so
in the world you can find a lot of
digital identity programs and usually
like um you will find them in the form
of like a signed um identity document um
usually it looks like something like
that so you have like the government uh
here it's Alice and the identity Al of
Alice is like represented as a
concatenation of some attributes her
name her date of birth her address uh
then we Ash this all these attributes
and we sign them so the government use
his own private key to sign them um then
he puts it into a passport into like a
card um or in the form of like an an FC
chip or a QR code and so basically Bob
the verifier needs the signature the
message and uh the public key that is
publicly published on the government
website to verify the signature so
that's great that's uh I that's what uh
how things are processed like at a
border uh basically but the thing is
that if Bob want to know more about Alis
like if he wants to like know if she's
more than 18 years old for example then
Alis would have like a to disclose her
wall identity um so how can we solve
that um we can solve that actually using
znar so um I'm not going to introduce
znar but basically like you can set some
input of a function as a private and in
that case we are using znar to like in
our same verification process we are now
hiding the signature and the message so
now we have like a way to verify the
signature that is inside your identity
document in a privacy anding way and we
are now able like to access some data
inside of snark and extract it and then
selectively disclose so I can um set
aover and say hey um I want to like
extract the date of birth and compute
like uh something such as like is the
data is the age um super uh to 21 and
then Bob the verifier now just only need
like a SN proof and to get the public
key of the government to verify uh this
proof
so uh now let's talk to anadar the
project I'm working we are working on um
so anadar is applied to Adar Adar is the
biggest identity program in the world
with like 1.2 billion people having
another
identity and basically so we developed
exactly what I showed um and in a um you
can U you can integrate it like in a
very um fast way under five minutes we
build a world SDK a World Experience
about how we can use this D snar to
authenticate people um instead of using
Google Google authentication for example
so now the user has to like um input his
QR code add our secure QR code as in the
form of a PNG um and then can connect
and then you have like a comprehensive
interface um saying what's the prover
like is going to reveal to the verifier
and so now you can see like in that
example there is no selective disclosure
but um the user is going to sign his
proof with like his own ethereum address
for example
so what are the use cases so um as I
said um I wanted to convince you like
that it's a good authentication
mechanism um so you can Target specific
countries uh specific ages um it's also
like a way to have like anti mechanisms
on chain because now you can securely
bring bring your um personal identity on
chain securely through znar um you can
do kyc U so you can um verify that a
certain person for example comes from um
uh a certain region or a certain country
and uh you can also like bind it with
some account obstruction to have like a
wallet wallet recovery mechanism based
on like your
identity and um we uh also did like a
program before Defcon to incentivize
like Indian hackers to come to um to
Defcon and so you were able to redeem
like a discounted vure if you are able
to prove that you were from India using
anadar what's next um next we are
tackling digil Locker so basically digil
Locker in India is the application where
you can store all your official
documents your driving license your
degrees uh your bank statements and it
it is this is actually signed data so we
know how to snacky it and we know how to
generate proofs about it so now you can
imagine like authentication mechanisms
that are like very deep but still have
like a very strong PRI privacy
layer and this is um so so I'm working
on anadar but here is like a a sample of
all the other digital identity programs
that could be also snack
fi thank
you thank you
Janis so we have three minutes to take
questions uh anyone from the audience
any burning question for
Janis I have one gentleman over there
and then one over here
hello um so I wanted to ask uh by
proving the ZK identities and only
exposing data that is needed for that is
needed for an application uh would you
say that uh digital identity systems
like this can be used in applications
where government compliance is required
for kyc purposes is that something that
this project aims to solve yes I think
that's a discussion that needs to happen
uh but basically what you're doing is
that you have like the insurance which
is the government and then you do like
some kind of import you're importing
this data through a zar verification
then the question is like how you export
it then like because as a government
like you generated a signature and then
you received this world format like
saying grow 16 whatever they don't know
how to handle that so yeah of course
like there is a lot of discussions uh
about like what should be like the way
to standardize this type of proof how
can be can it be consumed by a
government or like another third party
so that's actually like something we are
working on and uh yeah that's a good
question then the gentleman a purple
shirt hey um firstly thank you for
creating an Anon Adar I think it helps a
lot of people including myself and so
many other Indian developers to come
here um the question I have is I think
Adar is a great example um and I think
the infrastructure for adhar is set up
for something like this what about other
places where digital identity platforms
have not been set up generally how would
you see something like this coming up in
those kind of countries yes that's a
good question so I think there are like
the design landscape now that ZK has is
way more advanced like um the design
landscape is like quite broad I would
say that if you have like any form of
like digital identities like a signature
inside of a document that should be like
the main way to go but if you don't have
that you you have other ways like for
example in Nigeria they have like a a
secure endpoint IPI endpoint that you
can Target and they will uh give you
like ass assigned response um not
assigned response sorry but you can like
use for example something like TLS
notary um which is like wrongly called Z
kls but you can generate a TS a TS proof
that you have like some identity from
this API you can also use maybe ZK email
to um prove that you have an email that
state that you have you you pass through
um a Ka process from another provider uh
yeah and in that case if you don't have
all of that I guess that other seems are
like exploring like Biometrics and this
type of infrastructure uh to prove uh uh
the fact that you're human yeah thanks
okay then that's it for our question I'm
sorry our we're really short on time
thank you again yanis let's give yanis a
around another round of
applause next we're welcoming Li he is
the co-founder of matter toown and today
he'll be sharing the blockchain and
economy of online information let's
welcome Theo
hi everyone thanks for coming um so
today we're going to talk about um the
incentive mechanism for online content
so we all know that the incentive
mechanism is very important right
because it determine what kind of
content do we see online and blockchain
has the potential of becoming the
incentive mechanism of our internet so
it's really important for us to
understand how does content actually the
economic of content how does it actually
works on the internet we can roughly
classify um the monetization method as
direct monetization and indirect
monetization the direct ones are like
substack patreon the ones I see on the
left the indirect ones are the ones you
see on the on the right and
interestingly most of the Web projects
the nft projects are for under the the
direct monetization part where it's
Community token nft Marketplace
membership things like that they are the
ones that the consumer directly donate
subscribe to the content creator uh
whether it's public content or exclusive
content but the indirect monetization
such as ads and referral and live
streaming there are still majority of
them or actually all of them are still
controlled by the web two companies and
if we take a look at the revenue or the
amount of um of transaction on those two
different type of monetization we can
see that the indirect or the so-called
attention economy is much more bigger
than the direct monetization um and it's
it's actually the indirect monetization
that kind of make up the the internet
that we would typically call internet
the user uh generated content ones the
ones that heavily on the direct
monetization are things like Netflix
apples um or or or like the Amazon um
movies so it's a very interesting
contrast right if we have the majority
of the internet on the attention economy
why haven't we tried to do anything with
it in the web three World well I guess
one reason is that attention economy has
a lot of problems we know that it's kind
of uh problematic it's kind of captured
in this quote that if you're not paying
for the product you are the product
right so we try as much as we can to
avoid it and it's attention economy is
actually turning into something bigger
right because we have the capability of
tracking people to to predict how people
behave it also become something bigger
called the surveillance capitalism and
it's becoming more reasons for people to
avoid it but the interesting thing that
we have realized in the past few years
is that information has this very
interesting property which is captured
in this quote by St brand that
information wants to be free but
information also wants to be expensive
because the cost of replicating
information on the Internet is so low
that we will always in most cases get
used to receiving and sending
information in a free way so that makes
the fact that attention economy will
always be the majority of the internet
it doesn't matter what kind of
underlying technology we use it's almost
the property of human nature and how
information Works in general so instead
of avoiding attention economy we start
thinking about the problem that can we
actually turn its head around and make
it work for us for the content creators
for the readers is can we make it into a
protocol right because blockchain is the
mother of protocols so can we actually
standardize attention economy and get
rid of the problems that it has and make
it actually work for us so the attention
economy we see today are something on
the left it's active it tracks our
Behavior it sells our impression
directly but we have another kind of
advertisement which is passive in the
ones I see on the right we see that
every day on the street it's not
problematic at all sometimes it's
actually interesting right it's very
colorful the big difference is that the
one on the left does not have a boundary
to see where our privacy is but the one
on the right is actually passive so some
of the experiment we start doing is that
we're basically just minting on line B
Bo into nfts and we trade those nfts on
Harbor attacks so it's exactly the same
way as the B Bo Works in real life for
example the one on the right over there
is just actually nft and whoever bought
that nft can put on their content as
advertisement and that Revenue string
then go back to the content creators so
I think this is just only the beginning
because the attention economy on the
Internet is such a big industry that
there's a lot of opportunities in that
and we're only starting to scratch the
surface so thank you for your time and
let me know any questions thank you I
always enjoy your sharing okay attention
economy anyone with any question any
audience we have roughly time to take
two to three
questions any
questions hi so you're auctioning off
nfts that represent ad space and the
revenue from that goes to the content
creators on your platform and does any
of that money go to the platform as
reinvestment to improve
platform yes in our particular case uh
80% goes to the content creator and 20%
goes to the to the platform or the
application Builder but I think it
really depends on the application itself
uh whoever build the billboard has that
choice how manying of that should go to
the application how many of that should
go to the content creator we expect that
because the competition is quite severe
um it will be the percentage that goes
to content creator should be higher than
for example what Google AdSense does
has that been enough to sustain
you um if so for this particular case
the traffic is actually too low now but
uh if the traffic grow by around three
to five times it will be enough to
sustain any other
questions I'm also personally curious
what is your strategy for the uh for the
traffic to grow three to five times yeah
that's another uh topic but that's
basically the grow strategy well I think
the fundamental part is like how do we
make the application to allow people to
have deeper real connections and that's
I think that's fundamentally why people
will stay on the application B he
continuing what you're doing right now
yeah okay we get we have time for one
last
question
anyone okay one over here
it's a tricky one this is the only room
where we throw the microphone is it like
some something like in mify what is
planing to do
mify sorry on ha mify positive magnify
no yeah I guess you don't mify I guess
they are trying to do the same thing uh
can you hold it closer to you yes yeah
they are trying to do the same thing
like uh you can actually uh have the the
revenue model based on like what um like
you can post you can be the promoter of
the things rather than we actually
giving the money to the uh companies to
promote your so the more you promote on
the social media social media L protocol
the the content the part of it goes to
the contribut so I guess it a bit
different but seem to like what your
indirect way of I I didn't totally
understand the description but I guess I
can Lear FR you
later thank you and that's it for our
questions feel free to reach out to go
after the after the event he'll be
around he's always around thank you
again let's give uh him another round of
[Applause]
applause so uh as I mentioned today we
have many different interesting real
world discussions
and then different topic next we're
coming back to the identity thread so
our next speaker his name is Muhammad
and uh Muhammed has been working on
something very interesting edgy and then
uh I guess something many of us would
like to learn he will be presenting the
rohinga the sensualized identity and
Community Building let's welcome
Muhammad
[Music]
okay hi everyone thank you very much for
the stage
uh how's everyone
today it's about to go dark a little bit
thank you very much for the stage my
name is Muhammad n I'm a rohinga myself
from neighboring country Burma Myanmar
as a rohinga
uh today I would like to talk uh two
aspect of uh identity of course one part
which uh uh being how a technology can
help a marginalized community and how
that can be as a model for the rest of
the world so moving forward uh uh we
started this project called the rohinga
project moving forward so before we go
into the project I would like to
differentiate between two aspect of a
lot of people uh talk about number one
is a refugee a a refugee a person that
migrated from their own country for
multiple reason religious persecution
political persecution and many of those
things and stateless is person which a
person that is not recognized by the
state or some sort of fall into the
crack of any system that does not have
any sort of identity so according to the
un uh this is not exact but there's a
about 120 million refugees across the
globe and that is also increasing and
about 20 million
stateless that um include in many parts
of the world and uh unfortunately we
happen to be one large portion of those
stateless
people moving forward what is the
rohinga and who are these people rohinga
are the indigenous ethnic minority of
Myanmar formerly known as Burma mainly
residing in arakan state which is a
rakan state the rohinga people have
endured over four Decades of
statelessness displaced and genocide and
Homeland and many of these victims which
has been recognized by the International
Community in many of the uh
International jurisdiction call as
genocide ICC and icj uh some of you
might know and the estat less has left
there are about 3 million people now
people living in diaspora that uh
consist of Bangladesh and which I will
uh follow so these three million people
over three million people have no
documentation have no birth certificate
had no passport and so that they so have
no access to any any kind of things
moving forward so this is a kind of a
rough map where the rohinga are located
across the world so this is like about
300,000 Plus in Saudi Arabia in UAE in
Pakistan in India and Bangladesh is one
of the largest which is 1.3 it could be
1.4 and Thailand Malaysia Indonesia and
many uh other countries uh regardless of
Australia Japan and uh Europe and us and
so on and so
forth moving forward just to give you a
glimpse how the refugee are living this
is a aerial short of Bangladesh refugee
camp is extremely harsh condition
there's no sanitation no food and
there's many NGS trying to help and
there's no infrastructure just to give
you closer Lim this is how it look like
it's all makeshift camps every time
there is burning fire and many uh of
those uh
issues to go quickly so those are the
harsh condition of the ranga people so
because of the statelessness we are uh
trying to identify a few things uh so
because of the uh B so they don't have
basic rights and basic access to any of
this which is no ranga can go to any
University education or even simple
School uh social any kind of social
functions or financial is something
really really big no rohinga can even
receive money from something like a
Western Union forget about opening of a
bank account and of course identity is a
major
issue uh quickly moving forward so we
started this project called the rohena
project uh the rohena project is a
grassroot initiative uh dedicated to
preserve and promote rohinga identity uh
through a decentralized identity using
blockchain enable will access to
learning and skill building and unlock
some sort of opportunity so the way we
we are uh uh going forward is of course
one of our vision is because being
rohinga has been margin marginalized in
many different parts of the world so it
is our vision to how do we restore Roha
identity uh and dignity as
well the four component in the ranga
project component number one is a
decentralized identity so this can be an
a uh unlocking for rest of this and
second is education and skill we have
built number of it as well which I will
show you and a community exchange where
we we use multiple token technology to
incentivize Community uh people and then
we have a a a Heritage archive that
actually uh preserve our identity and
Heritage and and uh all sorts of things
and moving forward so this is a quick
glimpse of what we do in Heritage
archive audio visuals and Community
exchange P2P transaction Aid
distribution is another one uh so uh in
the decentralized identity we are using
something called Community Based
verification since we don't have any
Central Institute and we are one of the
largest centralized uh Central in victim
of central uh centralized
Institute moving forward this is what we
are targeting in terms of uh sustainable
development goal uh so my time is up so
I'm just quickly going to show what our
our road maps are we started in 2018 so
we did multiple collaboration one of
them is University of Washington we did
a pilot in
2019 uh and then we have did educational
pilot historical archive as well and
this year we have launched the uh Art
Academy so this is what basically we won
and uh this is where we have finished it
this is what we're going to build now in
the future uh some sort of
infrastructure development and MPV and
so on and looking for Community
engagement and looking for partnership
that's all for me thank you very much
thank you Muhammad I took one extra half
a we have time for question but if you
guys don't mind I want to ask a question
myself first uh can you share a little
bit more about the communitybased
verification system right since we do
not have any Central uh Authority and
neither we have any kind of a passport
or anything that can they can rely on so
it's based on for example if I say I am
from this particular place in Rak state
I'm a Roha and those local villagers
will verify me saying that yes I know
his family I know him through the
language through the uh and stuff like
that so we have a very strong Community
Based verification that we are placed uh
to verify how many people verify you for
you to become a part of the uh it could
be from simple from two to three people
uh that knows you can be verified thanks
for sharing that any more question from
the audience we have one to okay please
catch
nice okay um how do you handle the
challenge of uh having mobile devices or
internet access for this or do you have
a A failover system that doesn't require
any kind of a mobile device or internet
access right right so uh since our as I
have shown you the map our diaspora is
across different parts so those who live
in Thailand and Malaysia they are fairly
in a good infrastructure have some sort
of a good access to the phone but those
who are in Bangladesh cam they might not
have a good access to the phone and
internet so we are trying to build a QR
code uh offline so that they can use
with minimum uh charges and we have a
lot of offline facilities that we're
providing so it can be assisted and we
are trying to deal with the very
marginalized and uh sorry to say
illiterate community so we have to do a
lot of uh uh uh you know a lot of spoon
feeding and handling on the
ground hope that answers your question
hey uh thanks for your presentation I
have a couple questions uh first
question is I'm curious where you are
getting the funding to uh do this
project second question is your goal um
to uh with this decentralized identity
is it to get um you know countries like
normal countries to recognize this
identity right thank you very much so uh
the way we are now funding ourself is
through a community funding which is
really like a boost strapping uh we did
couple of crowdfunding we haven't uh got
any dedicated or organiz ization funding
which we are looking into it uh that is
one and the second one uh uh what was
the second uh question just now you
mentioned I think it's whether you want
to be recognized by other by by the
authorities so uh Roha decentral
identity meant to be a secondary
Identity or a kind of community identity
rather than a legal identity so in any
state you have a legal identity like
passport and ID then you have license ID
to you know have a specific services
this is meant to be a community identity
to access some educational and financial
services but that is a bigger goal in
the future where we would Lobby once we
have enough number to recognize and
moving forward on that yeah so that's
part of the plan yes got it one last
question short one yeah you mentioned
about communic Community Based
verification but uh the number of
persons three or four it two more
actually I think so is there any
mechanism for like if you want to abuse
this mechanism you can like like say I
am this person even though I'm not this
person but is there any mechanism for
avoiding this yes yes they are so uh the
way this happens is that when you put an
application the first thing you do is
you record yourself one minute ranga
language video so say I'm from here blah
blah blah and the community verifiers
will look into it if they are not
satisfied they will have an one to one
online call to make sure you are talking
you have the language so we have five
major test cultural test language test
this is only thing we can rely on since
we don't have documentation so really
you
know geographical knowledge of the place
and so on so forth so it is extremely
hard for any non- ranga to penetrate but
it's extremely easy for any ringa to get
registered thank you that's it for our
question time please please reach out to
Muhammad if you have any more questions
about it it's a very interesting uh
project and fascinating sharing thank
you let's give Muhammad another round of
applause thank you very much thank you
Muhammad so the next the next person I'm
introducing it's like very interesting
for me because I've been collaborating
with him for the past two years uh the
person we are welcoming is David Casey
he's the CEO of funding the comment and
he will be sharing blockchain's unique
potential transforming lives and
humanitarian sector for Refugee solution
let's welcome David Casey
[Music]
thank you so much Vivian all right hi
everybody my name is David Casey and
today I will be presenting on real world
use cases uh specifically Last Mile
humanitarian aid for Refugee
populations so a little background about
myself um I've been playing with crypto
and blockchain for a little over a
decade uh the first use case I found was
while I was building my first startup
which was an Airbnb style uh
transformational experience booking
platform um with about 800 locations
around the world Eco Villages Retreat
centers Etc and we were trying to uh
find ways to off-ramp merchants in the
global south from uh stripe to local
Fiat and uh we came across Bitcoin it
was like email for money and that was
about 2013 14 and I was hooked um a year
later we started playing on the colored
coins protocol B launching uh barter
currencies on top of the Bitcoin
blockchain and eventually that evolved
into something I launched in 2020 on the
cell blockchain called the resource
Finance protocol and that was a cashless
multilateral uh B2B credit clearing
Network or in other words um
asynchronous multilateral barter for
businesses um I also work with C on the
Venture side as a scout um working with
entrepreneurs building Last Mile uh
fintech and payment Sol
Solutions um more recently I run uh two
parallel uh sister Brands called funding
the commons and Earth Commons um it is a
uh public goods funding event series
incorporating conferences residencies
and hackathons and we just worked with
Vivian and the pagota team on a
residency in changai that just closed
out yeah um last uh last late at the end
of last month
uh yeah so we work with uh Builders
funders and researchers academics and
the public sector bringing together uh
conversations around uh how to better
fund public goods so got very little
time so I'll skip over that um we've
been looking at uh how to Pilot
blockchainbased public goods funding
infrastructure in the real world and we
think that um humanitarian aid for
refugees are a very interesting use case
for a few reasons um one ident refugees
are often stateless as you've heard from
the last speaker um banking Financial
inclusion access to the financial system
um opportunities to access uh money
income Aid Etc in cash and not vouchers
um Safety Storage of Transport across
borders during conflict And archiving um
as you also heard in the last talk um we
think that uh refugees also help solve
uh use case issues for the blockchain
industry at large um I think blockchain
has a lot of interesting potential use
cases but um it hasn't delivered on many
of them over the past
decade uh so briefly going into a couple
Pilots um we are just completing the
first one in Uganda where we funded uh
two music studios using the Bitcoin
blockchain actually which we H we hadn't
used in a few years and um interesting
to retouch it and see that um it is kind
of the the place of most liquidity in
parts of Africa still uh we uh are
building two music studios and the these
music studios are starting to uh produce
uh music songs that we um have a plan to
Mint as stories and share with the world
um which I'll tell you more about in a
minute um there is uh some pictures of
the studio and the
activities um this is a Burundi Refugee
community in Uganda
uh okay getting to Southeast Asia so we
have been doing a pilot here in Thailand
and Myanmar um over the past few weeks
and we have some very interesting early
learnings um so the first thing is that
crypto regulation here is different than
in other places um peer-to-peer payments
are not legal in Thailand or Myanmar um
so that's one interesting fact when
doing crypto Pilots um ethereum mut does
not have direct off-ramps into Fiat um
but the Stellar ecosystem does and that
makes it compliant inside of Thailand um
in Myanmar the areas of the country that
are not under government control um
don't have regulation at all uh
essentially um except that to be
sanctions compliant um according to the
US you can't deal with um any uh
military entity on the Burmese side um
so the other challenges in Myanmar are
vast um the government is bombing
internet cafes you guys asked for real
world crypto so here it is um and they
have undercover agents arresting uh P2P
off-ramp and liquidity providers so um
it's a pretty gnarly environment to work
in in terms of crypto humanitarian Aid
um and more uh learnings to come
soon uh upcoming we have a pilot with
the cell ecosystem in Africa uh that
we're preparing right now and uh where
is this all going so we are working with
uh kickstarter's new crowdfunding
protocol which is being launched on the
C blockchain early next year um and we
are building a decentralized
crowdfunding and storytelling platform
uh for refugees around the world to
crowdfund for infrastructure and
specifically infrastructure that trains
them how to uh generate media videos
music journalism art Etc so if that's
interesting to you um please come talk
to me David Casey thank
you thank you David
interesting anyone uh any audience with
a question for David it's uh really
amazing seeing the project growing over
the past couple of months it's very new
but uh solving real world issue is
something I feel like we all have in our
heart really appreciate that um any
questions from the
audience one over there oh let me try
oh okay I'm
sorry thank you sir thank you so much
yeah you were talking a bit about the P
P2P payments being illegal um but then
how is it being executed like like how
do they work around this because I guess
like then that means mobile app stores
are also not compliant or like they
don't would not allow apps like that
what what are the workarounds how can
you actually execute do do you mean in
Thailand or elsewhere yeah you said I
think Thailand Myanmar is illegal like
in Myanmar uh more than I don't know
half the country is not under the
control of the government and the
military government in Myanmar is
actually not recognized by the US
government um so compliant crypto
actually means not dealing with the
government and Building kyc Systems that
can exclude uh military actors um so
that's like kind of like a reverse
compliance uh which is a really
interesting uh situation in Thailand um
as far as I understand crypto P2P
payments um direct wallet to wallet in a
cryptocurrency or stable coin are are
not legal in the current regulatory
environment however um using an off-ramp
like Ste like using the Stellar
blockchain sending usdc um to their
MoneyGram offramp and having a Tha
person pick up at moneyam In tha bot is
uh compliant so that's the the current
uh way to use crypto in this country as
I understand it you can trade and
speculate on crypto um that's that's
fine on a centralized exchange like bitb
um but yeah not not the actual use of
cryptocurrency we have time for one last
question over there hey thanks for your
presentation um my main question is in
this world what does crypto give you
that web 2 does not if the um if the
regulations are making crypto payments
like hard or illegal uh does that also
apply to like you know noral be payments
great question so I can use the example
of Myanmar um the banking infrastructure
and all web 2 apps are under control of
the military government as well as all
the Telos um so like a fully independent
infrastructure using starlink mesh
networks and crypto um are really the
only option that that many people have
to actually get money into the country
um and not have it uh at risk of being
frozen or confiscated and them being put
in jail
and that's it for our time together on
stage thank you again David thank
you I know that was a little little dark
that's year
around cool uh the next one we have is
going to be a a very interesting topic
this is also at the really core of my
heart uh the next speaker is atushi
Hayashi and he's going to share about
tackling East Asia's population client
issue with local co-ops subsystem for
local governance let's
welcome
[Music]
aushi thank
you okay so uh I believe that the most
important thing is to implement new idea
and mechanism in the society if you ask
me the way to start is implementation in
the real Society I will answer in rural
area of Japan where the population is
rapidly
Decline and Japan's population peaked in
2018 and has continued to decline and it
is fair to say that Japan is one of the
countri in the world with the most
declining aging
population
and and if if it it will be the serious
issue not only Japan uh but of East Asia
also Thailand is about to Center time of
the population decline the map of Japan
is colored by Red by local governments
at that uh predict dat to likely
Disappear by
20150 about 40% of the more than
1,700 basic local governments are in
danger of
Disappearing we have decided to focus
our attention uh on Japan's local
community and local government to
develop and imp Implement a new
community operating system local coup by
Taking Back the loads previously left to
government agencies and putting them in
our own hands we will build a foundation
for the more flexible and fitting way of
life numer small community will be
created and the people who move freely
between them will solve problem and
create a new value through the
co-creation and the mutual
assistance local C is a true real
mechanis for the founding the local
Commons where by local assets such as
bacon houses and the best forest in a
community can be be accessible and
neutal as Commons while raising funded
external resources the goal is optimally
redistribute and invest Commons and
common fund with the involvement of the
former government or Council in
governance now let's describe their
specific case study the first case is am
Village a type of depopulated area in
Japan current Yash Village has a
population of less than
770 and is facing difficulty is
maintaining the infrastructure that is
essential for daily life with a sense of
Crisis that the village will be
disappear if nothing is done we are
contacted by the villagers about 3 years
ago and then offered this
proposal let's let people around the
world know what is going on makosi
Village and GA our friends so let me
show the video
[Music]
this is the rural community of yamakoshi
Japan in 2004 a massive earthquake hit
this part of Japan many left and never
came
back to help deal with this pero has got
some ideas in the digital
space when you buy an nft it's almost
like your passport Bea digital villager
how many do you have
now there's a thousand and
halfs it's worth not underestimating the
value of that Legacy and I hope web fre
technology can help bridge The Divide
between young generations and historical
Legacies
currently the number of the digal
villages both domestic and international
ex 1,700 more than double the number of
the real
Villages the second is about the
relationship between the sustainably
regenerated nature and sustainable local
community we have focused an abundant of
nature in Japan 70% of the country land
is forested and their archipelago is
surrounded by the Sea on the other hands
as a result of the decline of the
forestry and the other industry planted
Forest have become uh desolate creatures
are
disappearing fish are harder to catch
and the risk of the landslides and other
disaster is increasing it is important
to guarantee economic feasibility while
restoring the cyc of nature s makes it's
possible to rise fund for the
maintaining of Japan's local FL in the
oceans by allowing preh holding rise for
the carbon credit to be created to be
exchanged on the blockchain by using the
fun by using the fund raise to maintain
natural resources carbon credit can be
created the project is also promoting
the Dem democratization of the emission
trading so that individual as well as
companies both domestic and
international can participate in the
trading as our first site for creating a
carbon credit we have a partnership with
a on the other hand carbon credit and
not only things generate for from the
forest maintenance we working to create
biodiversity forest and the restore the
nature that human have destroyed to
create a watershed where diverse
creatures and can return and the
disaster are less likely to occur the
forest is now is uh uh uh now in the
position to generate carbon credit worth
3,000
30,000 sorry 330,000 ,000 us per year
this model we which can be def financed
while carrying for the local nature is
beginning to be deployed in the other
regions local coup uh is a uh the
practice is still in the process but we
H have the discuss with a specific
example we are forming the common fund
with a study stream of the funds and the
resources through the mple channel That
common funds matched using methods such
as quad funding in Japan we are
currently conducting demonstration in in
four four areas and they plan to conduct
demonstration outside of Japan in the
near
future local coup is a strategy to start
by creating a subsystem of local
government in Japan which is facing the
rapid population Decline and it's an
excellent opportunity to design the
original radical
self-government we intend to develop
local Coupe as the main system to
implement a plural world where people
freely move between mer community and
help each other creating the communities
that are self sering but necessary for
survival thank you thank
you it's very interesting cuz some of
the community members in Taiwan actually
uh gather resource to buy one of the mft
so we're technically one of the
villagers uh any questions uh from the
audience anyone okay de
I'm going to throw
it oh oops very
far nice uh thank you so much for the
very brief uh you know overview I
wondering if there's ways like for
people outside of Japan who maybe don't
have a Japanese passport uh to
participate in these kind of schemes is
there part of the conversation is there
any way to design in digital Nomads to
come in and experience even for short
period of time uh in Japan there's some
kind of discussion about the digital
noral Visa ID but it's kind of separated
so now we are uh just a uh for example
nisho nft is just a uh digital uh
resident certificate nftd so you can uh
participate the discussion and then you
can persp the voting and also you can
visit to the village and stay and talk
with a local resident and people and
participate a festival something like
that and uh it's it's interesting uh
there's so many elderly people over 80
90 years old but they all
realize digital villagers so if you a
digital Viller and go to the yamak
Village probably elderly the little
obachan grandmother Grand
and ask you where are you from are you
dis wow welcome to yamakoshi that's
happening they don't know they have no
idea about blockchain ethereum but they
realize the relationship between the
local legent and the you know outside of
people dig vill that's wonderful I think
thank you for your question thank you
I'm sorry but we only have time for one
question thank you again let's give him
another round of applause it's it's such
an amazing project always so
heartwarming thank you thank you next up
we have someone sharing oh also another
interesting topic uh we have Giza Giza
is the founder and CEO of circut teria
and she's going to share about
leveraging ethereum for Sustainable
Solutions in Southeast Asia let's
welcome gessa
good afternoon my name is Gaza and in my
talk I want to take you on a journey
through southeast Asia where with the
help of etherium we can create a more
sustainable
future let's start with zzak a young
farmer in rule Thailand every year he
suffers from unpredictable weather
patterns unfair market prices and a
constant need to increase his shield by
using pesticides zzak story is not
unique it's a reality faced by millions
of farmers across southeast
Asia and besides Farmers a lot of more
people are affected by climate change
with rising sea levels deforestation at
an alarming
rate and um energy demand Sky rocking
southeast Asia has now the fastest CO2
emission growth in the
world the consequences you can see
here and when I arrived here in Thailand
actually over one month ago I wanted to
go to changai but I couldn't because it
looked like
this after I could make it finally to
changai I made my way to Vietnam to the
very north of the country close to the
border of China where I encountered
situations like this I made these
pictures and then talked to the local
people this is the very last spot um
where they could find fish and you could
imagine how this will um look like if it
if it continues um with the
DRS but how do we change an um a system
that is uh facilitated by um economy of
scale where a lot of people suffer and
only a few benefit
economically um for this let us
understand the the um fa just better so
the reason for many of our our our um
social and environmental issues are
indeed coordination faes issues that
could be solved through better
collective decision
making this is where crypto economics
comes in as it brings it with it all the
aspects that could solve these
coordination issues the key question is
how do we Design cryptoeconomic Systems
so that they are um enable a sustainable
future let us remind us what what
sustainable sustainable means
sustainable means the res the resources
are steady um the resource availability
is um not depleted over time and the
system is steady the concept of
regenerative however goes behind beond
sustainability as resources are
regenerated over time the capacity is
built up sustainably while being
resilient to
shocks and this is a concept
regenerative Finance or refi builds up
on and this is something we want to
build
on let's see how eum can help to achieve
this vision of a regenerative future in
Southeast
Asia so um platforms like iser Risk
offer insurances against Natural
Disasters um they give automatic payouts
to Farmers like
zzak renewable energy trading platforms
like power Ledger or ar cream um offer
peer-to-peer energy trading that means
households with solar panels can sell
excess energy directly to
others and besides these projects there
are a lot of more promising refi project
in Southeast Asia considering the time I
leave you with this overview but if
anybody's interested feel free to get in
touch with me after the talk and I would
also highly recommend um The Regan Hub
where um many of these projects are um
yeah present
yeah with ethereum we can go uh Beyond
sustainable and Empower regenerative
systems but let's return to szak and see
how we can help
him so as mentioned before smart
contract Insurance zza can use to um get
get um payouts in case of um um natural
disasters then he could also list his uh
list his Harvest directly on the
Marketplace he can G um also gain better
prices by verifying the quality and a
peer-to-peer energy trading U platforms
can help him um to gain an um additional
income stream by selling um solar
energy thanks to ethereum Solutions zzak
now um gets fair market prices adopts
regenerative farming practices and sells
so
energy but um many of these Solutions um
doesn't exist yet so that means we need
to build them and now is the the best
time to do that the reasons you can see
here and yeah uh with this I would like
to end and um the the tools are here the
need is clear and the time is now so
let's build the regenerative future we
all deserve
Don
kit uh very happy to see some of the Tha
projects in uh on the slide uh like
happy ground just happy to see them uh
any question from the
audience one lady over there
still couldn't hear you maybe try this
one so much fun everyone should get a
chance to throw
it it's still not oh it's not working no
no it's working oh thank God all right
it's nice to have that help um I was
wondering just the a piece on your
presentation about um access to the
information of the market right because
I think that's one of the major
challenges of farmers in the global
South is actually being able to see
what's being sold at what price range
Etc so I I love the idea here I just
want to understand more of our how are
folks incentivized to share that
information that I find it very
challenging for people to openly share
what's being produced and at what
cost um so you mean um the transparency
from the pricing to to get that
information how how to improve that um
yeah of course this is something um we
need to need to figure out I mean there
are already some um some existing
Solutions data right um yeah that are
connected to blockchain I think we can
collaborate with them but um otherwise I
think that's a great topic for the
upcoming
Heaton for sure
[Music]
any questions in the audience other
questions
anyone okay oh one over
there catch
it hello hello oh yeah um so you
mentioned the different things that um
based on ethereum that can help with
coordination like Peer to-peer Energy
trading and and the marketplace and
things like that um I think the reality
of many local change makers is that like
time and Tech skills are also a barrier
how do you see or in what ways do you
see that going forward kind of ethereum
and the issues on the ground of change
makers coming together or converging how
do you see that moving
forward time on Tech skills um yeah uh I
mean of course we need uh more
developers but I think um people from
all uh kind kind of fields because uh
often you need also people to bring in
new ideas and to develop these Concepts
right um and I actually by my own um
attended a lot of heatons um and I first
thought I can't attend them because I'm
U I'm actually not a developer but um in
the end you need this diversity at at
heatons right and um to really um yeah
bring the right Solutions um to the
market and and also attract more people
yeah because you need um to communicate
the vision um and and to bring in more
people from all kind of fields and I
think this is exactly where we are right
now also with ethereum that we open up
and um yeah um attract people with by
showing
um the positive outcomes and future um
we can
create and that's it for our question
time thank you again
gissa next up we have Charles haml he is
the head of product um at mini pay at
Opera and he'll be sharing SC uh scaling
crypto there's an app for that on
boarding millions in Afric with mini pay
let's welcome
Charles all right hi everyone um I'm
Charles from oppra um leading the
product team for minip and I'm here to
tell you about how we're onboarding
millions of users in Africa to crypto
and to stable
coins oppra as you may know is a browser
company um we have many apps
and we have over um 100 million users on
the on the African continent oppra mini
is our most popular app it's a browser
that allows you to surf the web but in a
very efficient way that means that you
don't have to buy as much data um to
browse the web so people love it um and
minip is built right into oppra mini and
distributed through um through this
channel uh We've launched about a year
ago uh to five African countries
um and we've been getting a tremendous
traction minip is not only built inside
oppra mini but it's also built on the
best of c and it's different in many
ways to other crypto wallets mini
doesn't try to be a Swiss army knife
that sees all your assets and all the
chains and all the swaps it's really
focused around a payment use case using
stable coins and cell is perfectly
suited for that um it allows us to use
phone numbers instead of wallet
addresses um so as similar as to mobile
money systems already in market today
it's super fast and almost free so
typical stable coin transfer on cell is
0.1
Cent so we don't need things like
account abstraction um to really get the
the user benefit of gas
abstraction it also has automatic key
backup so when users uh activate minay
their keys are backed up they don't lose
them which is a common thing in in self-
custody
wallets and it's a UI that's really
tries to speak to users with familiar
terms and has this web 2 experience to
it with the full power of web
3 and the last part which very few
wallets do is really have a localized
approach to on andof ramp by working
with smaller Partners to really make
sure that it's possible to buy and sell
stable coins for very low amounts um
using local payment
methods zooming in on one of these um
differences um the phone number to
wallet address system is actually built
on social connect with the which is a
cello protocol that allows us to map
this in a privacy preserving way from
number to address but not the other way
um and it really improves
discoverability of you can see who you
which one of your friends is already on
Mini pay and it makes
copy pasting addresses a thing of the
past another interesting feature of of
oppra mini sorry mini pay is that
although we've added support for more
stable coins dollar stable coins we
wanted to make it easy for users to uh
move in and out of them uh if needed by
having this concept of swaps using
Pockets so you can simply drag and swap
from one pocket to the other uh one to
one and we use mental protocol for this
which allows us to have super low
slippage and um excellent uh
fees as this is a developer conference
I'll mention that we also have mini apps
which are web apps that are integrated
within minip we have over 10 of them now
uh also getting tremendous traction
since launch and this is something that
um you can do and you can build uh using
existing web and ethereum Technologies
uh and the cell team is is there to to
assist also in in uh making this a
reality I'm happy to share that since
launch we've activated over four million
wallets uh maap to phone numbers and uh
as of October we've done over a million
uh during October we've done over a
million P2P transfers between those
users thank you
um you know going past the tech and the
um the numbers right we're starting now
to tell a bit more of these stories that
we're seeing in Market using minay I'll
go a bit quick now I see time's running
up but um this is a story of a
freelancer getting paid in Stables um
and being able to to use them uh locally
this is another one in Kenya being able
to use usdt and pay local Merchants for
groceries um interacting directly with
the payment system locally and PESA so
it requires no Merchant
integration this is is another one um
someone has lost their wallet in Kenya
and was able to basically pay for
everything during a week uh thanks to
minip and this uh integration with the
local payment
system minay is now growing outside of
Opera Mini so I'm also glad to announce
that we've made available now the
Android app as a standalone app so you
can just go on the Google Play store and
try it out it's enabled in over 60
countries um and we basically ramp up as
as we have good cash in and cash out in
those
countries this is what it looks like
really trying to focus on the dollar uh
use case and um the payment use
case and we foresee that you know users
in country in Nigeria or Kenya will
invite people to from outside Nigeria to
the Standalone app and you can imagine
uh crossb payments being uh powered
through this
system also happy to review feel that uh
the iOS version is coming very soon um
so if you are Keen to be one of the
first to try minay on iOS scan this QR
code sign up the form and uh we'll be
sending invites to the test flight uh
very
shortly and if you want to build on
minay please reach out to us on X at
minay or at
cevs and the Cod devs uh are organizing
bounties during e global so if you're
joining the hackaton make sure you check
it out thank
you thank you
Charles that was incredible all
attractions any question from our
audience any questions okay well a few
um I see the the gentleman in the red
shair
first so uh my understanding is that in
Africa there's not much of a savings
culture because uh many of the
currencies are uh you know losing their
value every year so um there's more of a
borrowing culture than a savings culture
uh with access to stable coins in mini
pay are you seeing more of a savings
culture develop are people using this
for savings and acing those savings over
time uh what sort of uh data are you
seeing around
that so savings is certainly something
that that we hear could be useful in the
context of mini pay this is not a use
case we're really focusing on now um so
for us right now it's it's a marginal
use case it's really around money
movement uh at this
point another one over
there um with using USD there is that
somehow in conflict with the local
currencies is that is that something
that you see as a risk like for example
when integrating with tax paying that
should be happening or just with local
governments not being happy that their
original money is not being used or out
that in
Africa so I mean these economies already
have a lot of demand for dollars um this
is just a different channel to to access
them um and you know users can use opo
Min in sorry minay in a way that they
can think in local currency like they
can denominate everything in local
currency so a lot of people are doing
that to so alleviate the kind of mental
friction one more over
here good job all right what is a mini
apppp is it like an iframe
or yeah it's an embedded web app yeah
it's not an iframe but we just invoke
your app um and each app
is um is it within a Sandbox so we only
allow known uh blockchain interactions
okay is is the outputs um like is it
dumping HTML or is it yeah this is
existing web technology this is existing
web 3
API
um it's not it's not exotic anyway but
it's packaged in a way that users don't
have to connect their wallet it's
integrated and um the signing process is
very human readable okay cool I see that
there's a few people wanting to ask more
question but we are the time is up for
for the session feel free to feel free
to reach out to Charles for further
discussion uh let thank Charles for
another thank you Charles that was
incredible uh before I jump into the
next uh speaker I want to point out
since we're on topic for the for Africa
uh there's actually a GM Global majority
Community Hub in room 107b and then
today is Africa day so if you want to
learn more about Africa all sorts of
cuse cases meet the builders go to room
107b for the community
Hub and then the next one we're
welcoming David David uh he has he is
the ethereum nexum fellow which we just
met yesterday at the event and he's
going to share like how to run ethereum
node in Africa let's welcome David
[Music]
um
hi
okay
um okay I want to start by asking a
question um who how many of us want to
be here um in the next let's say 10
years 20 years to see um that AUM has
gotten to um the great potential it
should be how many of us okay good
awesome so I think we are all in one
Spirit um I'm David um I'm David uku
from Nigeria and um I'm here to really
SP our hearts to see how we all come
together to make ethereum truly
decentralized right and I'll be talking
on um from my own perspective as a
participant and as a user and someone
who who who believes in the future of
the ATM network um what I'm trying to do
and how I'm doing
it um so I live in AFC in Nigeria Africa
and
um Africa has some few unique challenges
and um it has a lot of potentials so
today I'll be talking about uh running
no in Africa and um other few things
um so yeah why geographical Geographic
decentralization um vital um sorry why
Geographic decentralization is vital for
the for for the
ethereum
um if AUM has to move like if AUM has to
be truly decentralized it means we need
to have U these nodes the inform
infrastructure points right um
distributed right and it has to be
distributed from a geographical
perspective so in currently right now in
the world we have like seven continents
right and Africa is one of it right um
and just to also add I believe in one
day um that some of us one day possible
me or you might go to uh might go to
Antartica to actually run a node um
right now in Africa we have less than 1%
of node operators um in Africa
but other part of the world um we have
more than
30% um in other part of in other side
part of the worldall and that's not true
decentralization true decentralization
is where we have a good balance to these
um infrastructures right running
together um the interesting thing about
um AUM vision is um it has a vision of
security trust with resilience but all
of this can happen if we don't have true
decentralization because one if we have
an imbalance right it means the majority
will actually give um have um High um
rules or policies which might not favor
the rest so we all have to be like we it
has to really be decentralized for us to
really have um this Vision come to pass
um geographical diversity is also um one
thing um one of the vision
um or cor visions of the ethereum um um
Network itself right seeing ethereum
really really being decentralized is
what um um the network
needs so um this is just a map showing
us like uh the the the notes we have in
in um globally just like I said we have
less than 1% of notes in in in Africa
and also Latin America so these two
these two continents kind of have
similar unique challenges so I'll be
talking on some of these challenges
also um one question also I want to want
to or another thing I will be talking
about is Why will why are we why should
we also um think about um or supporting
Africa in trying to run notes right
because of the potentials um at the
moment in Africa we have about um
approximately about 1.7 billion um um
people right and majority of this um a
good number of this um of this number is
um they are all youth right um and one
thing I love saying is in Africa we have
a lot of challenges right um where there
is challenges that's where you talk
about finding solutions to solve this
challenges and one great solution right
now it's the ethereum network it's the
eum blockchain which Sol challenges we
face in Africa so that tells that
there's a great potential in Africa and
that's why also we want to see more news
running in
Africa building a decentralized future
um our work at NB so um in trying to
solve this issue of true
decentralization from my own standpoint
um I came up with a community called
node Bridge right the idea right now is
just to see how we kind of have more
home node operators right sport people's
mind to also be participant of this
network in a way to really make this eum
truly decentralized
right um some few challenges we have in
Africa is um education um lack of um
internet infrastructures um lack of um
um Power infrastructures economical
issue right so and in know in my own
small way right we one of the things we
try to do at nodeb is to also break this
barrier right and um we find a way to
also break this barrier by for instance
doing workshops right I've been doing a
lot of workshops around um so in some
few African countries also educating
them finding a better ways to actually
um tell them that yes we all have to be
part of this Network making this network
resilient again um and then also um
Power so because we have to find a way
to also like use a very small um um
system so as it's sustainable and it's
actually also solve the problem so this
is just like a Raspberry Pi running an
eum node on AR um which also um solves
that problem right so I also like custom
build all of these things so as to solve
the problem for um for an African person
who is not able to actually buy this
infrastructure um who is not able to buy
this infrastructure because setting up
this infrastructure is quite um
expensive um yeah this is some of the
workshops also um we kind of get to
do um yeah this is also some of the
setups we've seen more Africans running
these notes right so um they kind of
have different setups so actually at the
moment we also kind of use styling we
use um um power solar systems to
generate um um Power for sustainability
um and also with the custom nodes we put
together um oh so yeah this is like the
whole power power system The Styling um
some of the the node operators we have
at the moment are actually using um also
education um
so why security depends on global node
operators and solo sckers all right so
just like I said we all have to come
together right to really see to push um
ethereum to be truly decentralized um
and then the point here is
um Africa is in in Africa is trying to
solve its own problem but because we're
trying to solve a global problem which
is trying to solve decentralization we
all have to be like all of us have to
all come together like so helping each
other for instance um
there are different system right now
like the DVT system um okay so like the
DVT system which actually you could also
delegate through permissionless system
you could actually have like a cluster
to delegate also um um um your Stakes to
a particular um node that is sitting in
in in under represented location right
so we all have to come together to
actually do these things together
because it it depends on us all not just
um one geographical point but it all
depends on everybody who loves this
network and who is ready actually to see
this network in the next 50 years to
come um yeah how you could also support
like there are different ways also you
could also put um this support just like
I said um supporting node operators from
your own point of view um let's say it
might be be delegating your notes it
might you it might so it might be you
delegating your Stakes it might be you
um um setting up some um resources which
is for education and it's
like so um I also just quickly ask what
does true decentralization uh mean to
you and we can think about it in the
next session I'm sorry David but the
time is up and we have a really tight
schedule if you want to talk to David I
think the work he's doing is absolutely
amazing definitely connect with him and
then uh go to the GM Hub to know learn
more about African Builders meet more of
them uh another round of applause for
David thank
you okay cool next one is also going to
be very fun it's a
decentralized uh public infrastructure
to connect every school in the world and
our speaker is Christopher Fabian let's
welcome Christopher
hello good
afternoon all right youve about you have
a whole bunch of school connectivity
content coming up for the next few
presentations and the reason that I'm so
excited to be here um is that we've had
a long collaboration with the ethereum
foundation with the community of
Builders here um
and over the last six or seven years
we've come to a place where we're able
as a project to talk about some really
exciting things in deep in just want to
ask about my timer I think the timer's
off by a little bit um I wanted to show
you this picture this is a picture of
school connectivity this is a picture of
school connectivity in Panama um each
dot is a school on here the red dots are
schools that are not connected to the
internet the green dots are schools that
are connected to the internet and this
is the type of map and data that our
project generates about the world um
it's the first time that we've ever been
able able to see the world through the
map of digital infrastructure we have
this map now for about 40 countries um
and you're able to see in real time
whether or not human beings are
connected to the internet and that's
really important and I'll tell you why
it's important um about a third of
people in the world have no internet
connection at all that means that
they're not able we just heard in the
last presentation about the lack of
nodes in Africa for example um if you
don't have internet if you don't have
access to gigabytes uh you're not able
to be part of the economy that we're all
talking about over the last few
days and more than half of the world's
schools particularly don't have this
access our project is called Giga it's a
collaboration between UNICEF and the
international telecommunications Union
and we focus specifically on making sure
that schools are connected um we've been
around for about five years we've
connected in the last two years about
12,000 schools it's about 7 million kids
and we've helped to pull together about
$ 1.7 billion in financing for school
connect it uh in the countries that
we're working in we've helped to reduce
the cost of connectivity by more than
50% and increase the speed of
connectivity in schools because it's
often very very low where it even does
exist and interestingly we've mapped
about 2.1 million schools nobody in the
world knows how many schools there
are total we think they're between five
and seven million but there is no
complete map so when we do map schools
in a country we're often the first point
of Truth for a government um because
they don't have an exact number of their
schools and since we're working with
connectivity with trying to get people
online and young people online and give
them access to opportunity and choice
our unit of measure our commodity is the
gigabyte which is interesting because
it's one of the few G you know
Commodities assets that's fully digital
uh from end to end uh this is what I'm
going to talk about in the next part of
the presentation which is that we
can if if something is digital because
something is digital we can talk about
it in a very different way than when
we're talking about physical
assets real world assets and we're very
very excited to be launching a new piece
of Giga a new piece of our architecture
in the next year and that piece is our
connectivity credits Marketplace um I'll
spend just a few minutes talking about
what that means for us but essentially
it means wrapping the gigabyte in a way
that we can start to create price
transparency if you look at the price
for the gigabyte in Zimbabwe for example
it's about 70 times the price of a
gigabyte in Kenya um and that massive
price disparity creates huge pockets of
unfairness it's not true just between
countries it's also true within
countries poor people always end up
paying more for the things that wealthy
people either pay very little for or
don't even think about at all and so I'm
going to just walk through what we're
doing in the space of of building a
system to tokenize gigabytes uh the
exciting thing is that this platform is
now up and running in its prototype
stages in four different places so I'll
talk about that a little bit too um as
we're going through this process of of
building and our team is about 30 people
working on the tech and Engineering side
in Barcelona and another 40 people in
Geneva so it's a fairly sizable group
working on Giga um with a real focus of
about five or six of us on on this
particular Marketplace so when you
purchase connectivity for schools when
you purchase connectivity for health
centers we also work with with
governments for hospitals and health
centers we're working because the prime
minister or the head of state or the
Minister of Finance or education has
asked us to be there and to help them
create this connectivity that allow s us
to have access on the buy side and
governments spend a lot of money doing
this anyway it's just often not very
well spent we also have a lot of
cell-side companies the people who are
actually providing that connectivity
these are mobile network operators
internet service providers and
others and so what we've created as Giga
is a way to connect the buyers and
sellers of this commodity this digital
commodity and we're doing this in
various ways in various countries but an
example of that um is that you have a
government like Rwanda one of our
champion governments and herban will be
talking a little bit about the work
we're doing there uh later who is
procuring gigabytes from a variety of of
different companies in Rwanda we also
have a set of sellers uh that are
everything from a small ISP to Large
mobile network operators that Pro are
providing this and because we have a
privileged Place through the United
Nations because we're part of Unicef
we're able to negotiate on behalf of the
government for aggregated purchasing um
of of gigabytes of this commodity and
kind of create that market
the second part after you've kind of
identified what the what the need is is
to figure out what the commodity is
itself because of this map which I
described at the beginning and we've now
we've built the open source stack to
find schools from outer space so we use
high resolution satellite imagery we've
built our own ML on top of that to
figure out what a school building is
we're able to tell you in real time if
the school is connected based on both uh
some Appliance stuff that we've we've
built and uh and and things that we can
install behind the router in the school
as well as connecting with network
operators through their apis and and and
other kind of larger systems we're able
to actually um talk about a gigabyte in
situ in as it's being used and see
whether or not a school is connected you
can imagine uh already we're working
with governments to when a school turns
green to issue payment automatically if
it turns red you issue a warning that's
a sort of smart contract based under
layer that we've built as well um but we
can start to do things with this digital
asset and if you grab that the QR code
you can go and search and look on the
map you can see all of the countries
that we're in you can try to find the
school that you went to should be there
if it's in one of the 34 countries that
we've already started working in um and
if you want to tokenize a commodity you
also have to think about that market
cycle where the where the commodity sits
in it um we stole this from the carbon
credits Market carbon credits sort of
work uh they don't work all the way but
they uh they give you an idea of how you
can create a sort of recirculation one
of the reasons carbon credits don't work
that well is it's very hard to um figure
out where they're being used and where
they're being you know where where trees
are absorbing carbon the the asset
itself the metric ton equivalent of
metric carbon uh equivalent is not a
real thing it's a kind of synthetic
thing that we've created um but with a
gigabyte we can actually talk about the
asset and we can do this whole cycle
which goes from somebody saying they
want to to do something they want to
give gigabytes out or deploy gigabytes
to somebody purchasing that and we can
watch that whole cycle happen uh through
the marketplace so that's a sort of
second step is figuring out how to
tokenize the thing the third part of
building a Marketplace is actually
building the tooling itself um and so
we're pretty excited that we are setting
this up right now in
Geneva um we picked Geneva for a variety
of reasons but uh it has allowed us to
really be based in this very structured
very regulated system that is respected
around the world um for certification so
we know that if you want to certify a
farm for pulling carbon in from the from
the air uh you need to go through a
certain process same thing for a
gigabyte you need to know that a school
has has been connected a health center
has been connected and somebody needs to
stamp that in in our system we have the
United Nations and all of our partner
governments who are able to provide that
certification we're also building this
in various countries with their own
National Credit Systems if you work with
connectivity at all you've heard of
something called a universal service
fund or universal access fund those are
ways that governments uh are ready pay
for school connectivity uh in poor areas
they just don't work very well because
they're sort of black boxes and you
can't see inside to what's been done
whether the money that gets taxed from
Network operators actually goes and gets
deployed or not um we also have this
Marketplace that we're starting to
launch we've actually just sold a few
weeks ago we sold our first credits
which is very exciting it's a very small
amount of credits in one country um but
we're starting to see Buyers work with
us uh sort of offline right now but it's
but it's beginning um and then we're
looking at what the protocol and the
governance can be for all of
that um the other thing you have to do
if you're building a Marketplace is you
also have to you also have to figure out
who's going to be who's going to take
part of it we've identified in this
whole system um a set of of of actors
that's everything from the government
Ministries who are already buying
connectivity for their schools and
health centers um to the sellers the
isps new new new isps or network
operators coming in groups like starlink
to old ones the incumbent operators um
as well as investors who would want to
be part of a kind of marketplace
environment and we've already started
stacking these up in four countries um
five countries which is really exciting
so in each of these countries we're
building a small prototype of this
Marketplace which is really a onetoone
relationship between a seller and a
buyer in that country for school
connectivity and what we're saying is
essentially this if you are somebody
who's going to connect schools you're a
small ISP internet service provider or
not Network operator and you want to
connect those schools all the way over
there but they're really far away it's
expensive and you don't maybe have the
money to outlay the capital at first
will give you a credit for connecting
the school and the further away it is
the more credits you're going to get
it's up in a mountain more credits
there's no electricity more credits and
so on so you as a small ISP can go and
do all of that hard work knowing that
you're at some point going to get repaid
at the same time we go to the government
we go to the Minister of Finance others
in the government and we say if we bring
you these credits at the end of the year
and if a company brings them to you you
will go and give that company a tax
break you'll reduce their corporate tax
you'll give them some kind of incentive
for doing that the government says okay
and so between those two we create a
system where we're able to fairly Mark
that the commodity has been delivered
even before all of the work has been
done and the service provider knows that
by the time they connect that school or
that Health Center that's so far away
that nobody wants to connect it they'll
actually get paid back so we put up here
just a few of the different use cases uh
that we have for and and sort of those
those pairing of users that we're that
we're building for in in different
countries um some of them use the
universal service fund as the backing
some of them use corporate tax
exemptions and some of them use uh
things that are already in place like
National fiber as the asset that gets
paid off so for example you could say if
you connect those schools far away your
credit will buy you access will buy you
free access to the National fiber
backbone or a place on somebody's cell
tower or their Mast and this is pretty
exciting so these four or five Pilots
are getting getting instantiated now
built out now we're going to learn over
the next year what works and what
doesn't and then we get to start to
bring in a much larger group of players
because a Marketplace doesn't work with
just one buyer and one seller that's not
a very good Market um the idea is that
these credits can really become digital
infrastructure credits they can become
um used by anybody who wants to start to
connect new communities we just heard
about node bias against poor places um
if you have an interest in connecting
something in getting it on the network
in creating a node in any sense whether
it's a data center or if you're trying
to do Edge AI or if you're trying to put
an ethereum node up you need to have
connectivity and so we can start to
create a dynamic in that um which
rewards people for connecting and allows
for the things the people that need to
be connected uh to be connected cheaper
and I just want to just I'll tell you a
quick story about why that's so
important so this is a school in Kenya
this is a school in a place called n
capir which is actually it's only about
15 km that's that's not quite that far
from from Nairobi it's a it's a school
that we help to connect we helped the
Kenyan government connect it last year
so this is the school if you're looking
at this if you're kind of if the school
is in back of you and you look across
the road there are power cables there's
fiber somewhere a little bit over there
but it was never connected to the
internet it was never connected to to
electricity um and one of the reasons
schools often in warm places and sunny
places aren't connected to electricity
is that you don't you don't need it
because you're in school during the day
when the sun is out and you just have
the windows open and it was never a
thing before but with these with this
ability of ours to to work with the
government we were able to help the
government create locate this school
create the financing for it um and do
something pretty pretty incredible so
there is a server there it has the Giga
logo on it it also has liquid telcoms
logo on it liquid is one of those
infrastructure providers who I mentioned
and in order for them to connect the
school they needed to borrow space on
somebody else's cell tower and they were
able to do an internal swap of resources
with that other service provider the
ones who made the cell tower so liquid
could put up their long-distance Wi-Fi
radio on the tower and that's a a
version of connectivity credits that
happen sort of organically um in the
school itself and we see this across the
world as we're connecting Schools
attendance goes up once you start
connecting because if you're in a school
if you're a 14-year-old in a school and
you're learning nothing and the teacher
as is the case in many countries the
teacher can't even really read a
paragraph of the you know of of a text
in the language of instruction well you
know that you're being ripped off you
know that your time is being used
unfairly and you are angry so know you
shouldn't be there um as soon as there's
connectivity you're able to do something
you're able to borrow somebody's phone
do something a little bit on it and you
know there's a potential for a future
we've also seen School results increase
by mean this school is about 10% even
without the full digital curriculum
being put in place and we don't do
anything inside the school so Giga does
not do any of the work with edtech or
teacher training that's all other parts
of Unicef that do that there are experts
who do that type of work but we just
bring the kind of connectivity in and
the the last thing that's really
interesting in this story is is that
this is the main teacher her name is
Paris she said that she's able to save
about 4 hours a month because she
doesn't have to go to an internet cafe
to entering the grades and the
attendance and all that kind of stuff
that she had to do before there was
connectivity in her school um and so
that's all important that's why we're
why we're doing this work from a
technical point of view the ability to
tokenize gigabytes proves a few things
that tokenizing other traditional real
world assets doesn't I think um one is
that we can talk about standards because
in this particular case unlike carbon
credits it's very easy there's one
agency that does Internet it's the
international telecommunications Union
there's another that looks at school
connectivity that's UNICEF so together
there's really only two groups that do
the standard setting for it um often
real world assets it's hard to figure
out like the user interest of the real
world asset itself you know there are a
few of us who want to buy a very small
percentage of a physical painting and
think that's important or a part of an
apartment building uh in general that
hasn't hit retail yet but a gigabyte is
broken down into a megabyte and broken
down to a kilobyte those things already
kind of work um and you can validate
this stuff in real time you can see it
on the map that I showed all of you um
so you can see whether or not this asset
is moving which is nice for an investor
um somebody who's looking at getting
their infrastructure built out and that
you know that ability to see things in
real time is pretty
important and finally as I said in
earlier in the presentation having this
backing from the Swiss government is
very very helpful so we're hosted by the
government of Spain Catalonia and
Barcelona to build our technology and by
the government of of Switzerland and the
Canton of Geneva to set up this
particular piece of work the
connectivity credits Marketplace um
we've been we've been having the
meetings that we need with all the
regulators and legal folks um and
Switzerland is very very good at
structuring regulation which is why
there's so many folks in zoo already um
we believe that Geneva has a unique
place as a center of international um
Commerce in in Switzerland as well and
uh and so it's really a delight to be
there I wanted to leave a few minutes
for questions um before that I would say
there are a variety of ways for this
community to be involved one of them
obviously is uh just being a contributor
to the different repositories that we
have um we are delighted to to be
working with the open source community
and on a variety of levels the second is
that as we talk about impact and impact
tokens and others who are doing that
type of work they they find this layer
that we're building something that they
can build on top of so people working on
environmental tokens can use schools as
monitoring hubs and so on um the third
is you may know U folks in countries who
want to be part of this there may be
infrastructure providers that you work
with um who are interested in in being
part of this or there may be governments
who would like to experiment with a new
way to connect their populations so
really delighted to have spent that time
um sharing this project with you
harbin's going to talk a little bit more
about how we've been working with the
ethereum community on staking in a
little bit but we have a few minutes for
questions as well thank you so much for
listening this afternoon so we have 3
minutes left or question for this one I
see one hand over there oh that's a long
distance for me uh oh Sor you want to do
it I hit somebody in the head with one
of these boxes once and it was really I
know if you want me to throw it okay do
it okay out the microphone that
gentleman over there in the back
yeah wow you're so
good thank you for the introduction so I
think digital Marketplace it works when
uh we don't know who will be the seller
and buyer and Marketplace work as
interface between the seller and buyer
but in this case uh I think you already
know who will be the buyer buyer will be
the government and seller will be the
telecom companies but if do you have any
other reason that you're introducing the
marketplace here it's a great question
so if I'm just if I just want to sell my
goats to you we can start off that way
and at least we know that the goat is
worth something right and before I sell
you my first goat and you give me the
money we have no idea that the is
actually worth anything but after that
we've established that there is some
transaction we're at that stage now so
we want to just see and know that this
commodity can be moved digitally because
right now the way it's accounted for is
terrible but the idea is to open that up
and to have a lot of different goats and
a lot of different buyers in the next
phase it's just you can't start by
building that unless we at least price
out the goat and know that that trans
first transaction can work and so that
is the government and the and the ISP
but later on it becomes the people
around the ISP the other the folks doing
data centers all of that who can be on
the buy and on the sell side
probably sorry but we're on a super
tight schedule uh and that's it for our
question for this session uh the next
sharing will will also be about Giga so
after the two sharing maybe you can
gather your questions together and then
go to Chris over there let's give Chris
another round of applause thank you
Chris uh next one we have gerbin he's
going to talk about how Giga uh stake
for School connectivity let's welcome
[Music]
Gan uh hello everybody can uh can you
guys hear me well good um thanks to the
organizers for putting me right after
Chris it saves me a lot of introduction
for what Giga is and does uh quick
summary so we're a project about
connecting every school in the world to
the internet and every young person to
uh information opportunity and choice um
a little bit of a summary of what we've
uh what we've achieved so far um we've
connected about 14 and a half thousand
schools benefiting almost 8 million
students and we're currently active in
34 countries uh so it's a big uh big
operation one of the um one of the
opportunities that we found one of the
challenges that we have is in uh once
the schools connected to fund the
operational expenses of this school so
we're kind of looking for a sustainable
financing model and one of the projects
that we've looked into uh is around
staking so I thought it'd be interesting
to talk to a crowd that's very familiar
with staking and talk a little bit about
the challenges that we faced in
implementing this in the real world so
um what we want to do is we want to
create uh staking nodes uh and use the
staking rewards to pay for the
operational expenses of uh of internet
connectivity so it's kind of like an
endowment um
a little bit about the size of the
opportunity or challenge that we have uh
we did a case study a few years ago
where we looked at uh what it would cost
to connect the 86,000 schools in the 17
countries that we were active in at the
time and uh we discovered that it would
cost approximately $35 million in
operational expenses so it's a very
significant problem that we're looking
to solve for um but the benefits also
speak for themselves so with sustainable
funding about 25 and a half million
students and teachers will be able to
benefit from
connectivity uh what we've done so far
is uh we started with setting up a
staking node and uh loading it up with
32 eth so the you can look at the the
the validator note there but uh and what
we are using this funding for is to pay
for connectivity for one particular
School uh in the M uh the mama Primary
School in uh in Rwanda so about thousand
uh students in Rwanda are better
benefiting from this uh this
connectivity at the
moment but uh we ran into some problems
so um currently we have to jump through
all kinds of regulatory Hoops in uh
making this uh uh connectiv making this
system work so we have to offramp the
eth into Fiat then the ISP needs to send
like a paper invoice to a company that
like pays this invoice and then the the
school needs to be connected so you kind
of lose track of the um um of the
payment process in that way and it's
something that we feel uh hinders the
scalability of this a lot so there's no
problem in sort of paying for one
staking node ourselves and connecting
one school but doing this for uh all the
remaining schools becomes a problem for
impact investors if you can't prove the
impact so this is where we are um we
have uh completed this pilot uh and we
want to scale but we're currently sort
of Stuck in the Middle where we're
trying to set ourselves up for Success
uh one of the things that we need to do
for that is create an endtoend crypto
flow uh in the cooperation with the
Central Bank of Rwanda uh and we have a
a pathway for doing that uh and the
second is to set up a pulled impact
staking product um but I'm here today
with a a super specific call to action
and Vivian I might like ask you where
that group of uh African uh Community uh
was was gathered uh but we're
essentially looking today for a crypto
company based in Rwanda to could uh who
could join us uh in this regulatory
sandbox of the Central Bank uh and help
us uh make this more scalable going
forward I'll leave a few minutes for
questions thank
you do we have anyone from Ronda
here we not here
nobody it's okay we have the the whole
Hub okay we have one person here one I
think over there let's start with this
uh gentleman with the white
shirt yes
uh I've got a crypto company in Rwanda
I'll talk to after oh
good I told you it will
work so I'm from ymar and we are having
all kinds of Crisis so is there can you
speak up a littleit yeah so I'm from
Myanmar and in Myanmar there are a lot
of Civil Wars going on and we the the
schools needs a lot of this internet
connected issues so the first uh
challenge is that not only the internet
connectivity but also we only got around
6 hours 7 hours electricity year
so in that kind of scenario uh will the
Giger you infrastructure will be walk or
that's the first question and second is
will there be you know future plan to
come to myar to support this kinds of
you know internet infrastructure
development
yeah so this particular project was
really about like uh raising the money
for to pay for operational expenses
there's of course this whole
infrastructure question and electricity
providing question that also needs to be
solved for uh which is part of a bigger
problem I suppose um we do intend to uh
see if this uh solution will skill on
the global level uh so far we've always
hit this like regulatory glass ceiling
uh in this uh in in in this solution so
uh we are quite excited to be working
with the Central Bank in Rwanda in
trying to break glass ceiling for this
particular use case and then hopefully
using that as a um
um a pilot study to show central banks
that there's an opportunity in this
space in in other countries as
well okay but I think uh for the rer
they already have you know support of
the central bank but in myar the central
bank and all kinds of financial
transactions are always you know checked
by this dictor military so I think this
will be not happen in like uh next a few
years I believe yeah myamar sounds like
a very complicated situation I agree
with
that thanks for raising the question any
other question we have time for one last
question one over
there so um I'm from Kenya um and and I
really appreciate the work um that you
are doing with um with Chris so my
question would be in terms of um
locating for example the institutions um
he had mentioned that you have an an ml
model that helps you identify um what is
a school and what is not a school is
that model available for use uh to other
use cases so um I work in agriculture um
identity for
Farmers uh I mean the answer the answer
is yes it probably have to be a
different model uh
but we do have a data team that looks
into that and I don't know if you
mentioned it did you mention that we're
also doing hospitals and health centers
where am I spoiling something yeah so we
we're also branching out into other uh
public infrastructure like hospitals and
health centers yeah okay um I look for
you
afterwards thank you and thank you gin
thank you Giga team that was a lovely
half an
hour okay that's another round of
applause for them wonderful War okay
that's a that's a wrap for this session
but you know what we have more we are
taking a 30 minutes break right now and
then we'll be back at 5:20 there's going
to be more discussion around
decentralized public infrastructure and
different kind of public goods funding
mechanism I'll see you at 520 bye
everyone
[Music]
so
o
[Music]
oh
he
[Music]
n
B
[Music]
o o
o
[Music]
you
oh
[Music]
B
o
[Music]
got
m
n
[Music]
w
o
[Music]
sh
oh
[Music]
oo
G
[Music]
you
w o
[Music]
bu
o
[Music]
up
a
[Music]
you
oh
[Music]
B
oo o
o
[Music]
oh
o
[Music]
oo o
B
[Music]
n
w w
[Music]
o
m
[Music]
hello welcome back to stage four this is
our final session of the day we have six
different speakers today sharing like
this session sharing different ideas
from public goods funding to
decentralized public
infrastructure uh a quick reminder of
what this group uh what this stage is
about it is all lightning talk so it
means that each speaker will have five
minutes to share the IDE there and then
following with 3 minutes for you guys to
ask question or comment so feel free to
be interactive listen in and let us let
the speaker know what you want to learn
more about uh without further Ado uh our
first Speaker of this session is akid
Gupta and he's going to share about also
decentralized public infrastructure
pushing decentralization Beyond
blockchain that's welcome actually
welcome
hi everyone am I audible at the
back yeah okay awesome so hi everybody
I'm akit I lead the engineering team at
huddle 01 and we are a deepin dedicated
to making realtime communication
affordable cheaper and performant so uh
we are a deep in project so if you're
familiar with deepin deepin stands for
decentralized physical infrastructure
and uh we saw a gap in the market Market
that uh realtime communication is very
hard and it's uh it's very pricey as
well so people like Zoom like companies
like Zoom Google meet all these rely on
heavy infrastructure and uh have to host
it on cloud providers like AWS so this
is what my talk is about how deepin can
make it
cheaper so as I said deepen stands for
decentralized physical infrastructure
and in blockchain we've seen a couple of
Trends uh from the start things like
nfts have shaped like reshaped ownership
digital ownership in games you have
these skins and everything and these can
be so via nfts uh to make sure that uh
only one person owns it and stuff and
smart contracts have automated uh money
transfer as well so you can program how
smart contracts transfer money on a
based uh on based on a particular
condition so but we're still deploying
these things on centralized
infrastructure like AWS so if you were
to build a complex app which requires
heavy infra you still host it on AWS
things like storage and bandwidth still
require centralized infrastructure so
that's where deepin comes in uh we saw
this uh with filecoin so filecoin is a
really good example of a deepin project
which is decentralizing storage so
similar to filecoin we have uh it for
real-time communication
so uh charging for stocks and paying for
flows so this is a very interesting
Trend we saw and AWS was charging crazy
amounts of money for egress costs so as
you can see in the slides uh AWS charges
like 700x amount of pricing for egress
costs so say like you fill a bucket full
of water water being the amount of
storage then the the amount of water
that being transferred out of AWS which
is data being transferred out they
charge like really costly amounts for
that and not for the stocks that they
save so that's how uh AWS is charging
and it's like 700
markup so why I'm bullish on bandwidth
projects like dpnr so internally at
huddle 01 we did an interesting study
where we calculated the bandwidth costs
for hosting on AWS like hosting a
real-time communication app on on AWS
and as you can see for a single
participant the bit rate consumption was
around 700 uh kbps and for eight
speakers in a room and 20 listeners the
data consumed was around 112 MVPs and if
we were to take like 100 such rooms uh
hosted on a particular uh app you'll see
that it's it comes around 11,200 MVPs so
data consumed in an hour would be around
40,000
gabs okay so that's a huge amount and if
you were to calculate the data transfer
cost on AWS that comes around to
$400 okay so if we were to use a deepin
project and these Services were hosted
on a physical infra where people are
incentivized to run these notes then you
the price goes much lower
okay so these are some popular deepin
projects you can see huddle 01 which is
uh the project we we are working on and
some popular projects like grass are
also working in this bandwidth
department where they're saving cost all
you need to do is just install an
extension and you'll be good to
go so if you are looking to build a
deepin the best way would be to look for
a market which is super overpriced and
you can easily save costs by um
allocating that job to a particular
person who can run it on their own
machines or uh hosted somewhere maybe
with less P so as you can see the less P
the better this is one thing to follow
if you are looking to launch a deepend
project very easily and uh it's very
easy to uh deploy a project with less
spe as there's no physical part involved
there are really good projects with more
p as well as you can see on the left uh
but with less P you'll be able to run it
and uh make it
work so thank you that was a small
lightning talk uh by me and I am happy
to entertain some
questions thank
you okay okay do we have any questions
from the
audience
anyone let's wait for another 5
Seconds okay
oh do you want to throw
[Laughter]
it yes perfect so you talked about uh
essentially that the less the P the
better you need to put it it's a mic
hello hello yes oh wow yeah I know so so
you talked about a point where
essentially uh the less be the better I
just wanted to understand if you have
less B there's also a chance of
having uh more chance of gaming the
system that means verification can
become uh tricky if your system is more
digital rather than having a physical
Network for example helium it's very
difficult to game a helium system
because you have a bobcat minor uh but
in case of something like huddle it's
more of a digital Network that means you
require verification systems more like Q
systems so have you thought about that
at hard1 where you can have a qos system
implemented which can act as a similar
to physical infrastructure Network as
well so that nobody games it yes so uh
the best way to go about is to First
solve distribution as we did because the
main concern is to save costs because uh
people will only come if you save costs
but if you are to move ahead and look it
in the long term then you'll have to
come up with a ZK system which is
provable in nature so we have to look
for a way to make the compute uh
verifiable provable using things like ZK
as uh they've come and right now the way
to prove like make it provable is very
difficult as things like circom have
their uh limitations as well but the
last step would be to make it provable
in some sense yeah awesome I think if
you're able to do that then
communication becoming provable in a
digital environment will make it a
highly scalable environment and make
communication much more performant and
scalable thank you so much yeah thank
you thank you
anyone else okay one over here sorry we
have only time for one more yeah I
lookit amazing talk by the way so I got
curious to know let's suppose if a
company like Google or Microsoft want to
adopt the deepend do you think it's that
scalable right now or maybe in
future so uh if Google were to do it
then first of all they are in direct
competition with the deepend project as
they have gcp and uh they're charging
like egregious costs for those and so it
would be difficult for them to adopt but
eventually once like uh the deepen
project scales and people start adopting
it then they'll have no choice to you
know move on to these cheaper options
because it'll be much cheaper for them
as well okay thank you thank you thank
you so much for your time and I was
incredible let's give him another round
of
applause okay next up we
[Music]
B
o o
o
[Music]
oh
know
[Music]
oh
a
[Music]
B
o
[Music]
come
m
[Music]
you
w
[Music]
o
t
[Music]
she you
o
[Music]
o oh
w
[Music]
oh
B
[Music]
o
oh
[Music]
you
oh
[Music]
t o
I'm
[Music]
you
oh
[Music]
his name is Kevin aukee and he's going
to share downtown stimulus public goods
funding for mainstream let's welcome
[Music]
Kevin Hello friends what's
up I'm Kevin aukee I'm one of the
co-founders of gitcoin has anyone in the
audience used
gitcoin all right can't see it on the
live stream but a bunch of hands went up
uh I'm going to talk about bringing the
getcoin model of quadratic funding to
Main Street so how we exit our little
crypto bubble and start to do more
public goods funding downtown so if
you've been in the ethereum ecoystem
over the last couple years you know that
quadratic funding is a democratic way to
run a public goods funding campaign if
you're an ecosystem that wants to fund
your ecosystem public goods you put out
a pool of funds and then you allow
grants or projects in your ecosystem to
access those funds by raising money from
their constituents and receiving money
from the central matching pool but
there's one weird trick with quadratic
funding that makes it into a democratic
power tool and that's that the matching
is based off of the amount of
contributors to each project as opposed
to the amount that they've given so if
you raise $100 from a 100 contributors
and I raise $100 from one contributor in
a quadratic funding campaign the one
with the broader base of support is
going to get 99% of the matching pool
and this makes quadratic funding into a
power tool for funding what matters for
everyday people in these communities
because the poor and the many get to
make Capital allocation decisions
instead of the rich in the few quadratic
funding has delivered $65 Million worth
of funding in the ethereum ecosystem
over the last six years on gitcoin but I
wanted to prove that we could bring it
out of the crypto bubble and to Main
Street and so in 2020 when covid was
ravaging the world world and in my
hometown of Boulder Colorado
99% uh decrease in foot traffic for the
downtown uh was happening businesses
were struggling to stay afloat and so I
got together with my colleagues Zach
Herring and Katie Johnson and we put
together a $225,000 matching pool of
quadratic funding in downtown Boulder
Colorado and we're able to run a
quadratic funding campaign for a yoga
studio a a bookstore uh coffee shop and
a couple of other projects
downtown so this is what it looked like
downtown stimulus.com and basically the
way that we positioned this was that you
could support local businesses by making
a contribution to these businesses using
a credit card payout so basically we
took quadratic funding we took gitcoin
grants we stripped out all the crypto
and we just allowed people to contrib
contribute with quadratic funding or
sorry with uh with with US Dollars and
have their contributions matched by
quadratic funding so we had a $25,000
matching pool thank you to vitalic bin
and to local philanthropist Bradfield
and we're able to raise
$116,000 from 320 320 contributors of an
average donation of about $40 and all in
all were able to raise about $41,000
for downtown Boulder public
goods I think this is really exciting
that A Primitive that has been pioneered
and distributed in the crypto ecosystem
was able to go mainstream with a
campaign like downtown stimulus and I'm
really excited about this meme of cosmol
localism which is basically an approach
to production and governance that
provides uh a combination of global
coordination with knowledge sharing and
local manufacturing and resource use
emphasizing open source software and a
relationship between the global and the
local where the Global Services the
local okay so in what ways can we in the
ethereum ecosystem and the open source
ecosystem create a Global Commons create
knowledge and production that is in
service to the local and this is opposed
to the webq surveillance economy in
which you have Facebook Communities
going into your local communities and
surveilling everyone and tearing apart
the social fabric because it's more
profitable for Facebook shareholders
that way how can the ethereum commons be
in service of the local Commons is the
design space of cosmol localism and
ethereum localism and I'm happy to say
that downtown stimulus to me is a proof
point that this is possible we can take
the programmable money where we program
our values into our money in the
ethereum space from the ethereum space
and start applying it to downtowns uh
across the world and I'm really excited
to see what kind of experiments in
public goods funding Community currency
supporting the Arts and supporting
public goods that we can do uh when we
do that so I'm Kevin aaki founder of
getcoin that's been downtown stimulus
thanks so much for your
time thank you
Kevin hello hello amazing we have like
uh roughly 5 minutes for questions
um by by the way I'm also a big fan of
cosmal localism yeah
thanks anyone in the
audience uh the gentleman the purple
head should
I oh wow you're good good catch thanks
um yeah I love your work and all that um
I was going to ask with um things like
Community currencies and um things like
that where you might put conditions on
your money I I sometimes think that
that's obviously a restricted form of
trade that um whereas like regular fear
currencies are sort of unrestricted so
with that lens how would you say that
the community currencies can sort of out
compete Freer money if that's a right
premise for yeah so the question is how
can Community currencies out compete
National currencies yeah like how how
would it have more utility if it's
somewhat constrained into yeah um I
think that Community currencies are cool
as an Outsider but I'm not a designer of
any so I'm not qualified to answer that
question uh I think Scott Morris has
done a lot of work on community
currencies and I would ask him yeah I
guess I was riing off the um like adding
our values to our money and if you put
sort of constraints on it in that sense
to fuel our values I can see definitely
the bigger picture that that's that's
awesome and I want to see more of that
but then I also sort of play Devil's
Advocate as more so another friend does
this to me where he sort of says well I
could just do that with the US dollar or
I could do that with this currency so
I'm trying to sort of find the arguments
like other arguments that say this um
money with value restrictions is kind of
more better in a more immediate form
than I can currently argue so I'm trying
to find on that side yeah um uh I think
that uh you know one of the things that
I see a parallel between what we're
doing in the crypto ecosystem and what
community currencies have done for
hundreds of years is that what we're
doing in the cryp crypto ecosystem is
mimetically local and Community
currencies are geographically local okay
so like uh to me mimetically local means
that like gitcoin a public goods funding
uh coin filecoin is a file storage coin
ethereum is a computational coin in in
in a local mimic area and so you know in
what ways in what what we learn in
community currencies can be applied to
Global currencies like Dow currencies
and vice versa I think that there might
be sort of a cosmol local convergence
there yeah but my talk was about
quadratic funding more than Community
currencies uh I I think that they're
both cool though thank you do we have
time for one more question yes we do
gentleman over
there thank you hi Kevin hey um what do
you think or what in your mind will be
the hardest part of building some uh
version of a downtown U uh stimulus in
in in another local
finding the the initial donors or the
tech probably Tech is just foring
something or uh making people understand
how to use the system or anything like
in your experience what what you think
is is the focus should the focus be on
on if if you want to build something in
in my own local yeah great question so
uh we built a code base that you can use
to do Fiat quadratic funding rounds it's
called Simple grants. XYZ go to simple
grants. XYZ forkit deploy it in your own
local community um I should have put
that in the talk actually I think about
it um but yeah the hardest part honestly
was raising the initial
25k uh quadratic funding campaigns in
web 3 there's a lot of treasuries that
are just hundreds of millions of dollars
and we draw on those to run quadratic
funding rounds in qf but the uh the the
raising of funds to do quadratic funding
locally is sort of hampered by uh are
you do you have access to wealthy
individuals who are willing to do it and
can you crack the nut of the local
government actually funding it we
actually went around the local
government we didn't even talk to the
local government government because
their funding Cycles are just quarters
and quarters long so to answer your
question I think that raising the
initial amount of funding is the hardest
thing that you'll do if you're if you're
going to run these campaigns and
hopefully we can make the tech a little
bit easier with simple Grant St XYZ
thank you for the question thank you and
that's it for the for the time okay okay
thanks for having me happy Devcon
everyone peace thank you
Kevin okay now it's time for our next
speaker next we have garm who is the
glow dollar co-founder he's going to
share a very interesting topic
reclaiming our 8 billion funding public
goods with stable coin profits let's
welcome garm
hey Defcon I'm K and one of the
co-founders of glow dollar and I'm here
to talk about reclaim oh sorry one back
uh reclaiming our 8 billion through
funding public goods with stable coin
profits um you may not know this but
there's two tokens that are involved in
47% of all Dex swaps I am talking of
course about usdc and usdt um and
because of this they're making a pretty
healthy profit te reported 5 billion in
profits in the first half of 20 24 and
they're earning that profit basically on
the backs of the ethereum ecosystem
embracing uh these table coins and how
do they actually do this well uh tether
and circle basically have a duopoly on
all of these table coins approximately
155 billion in market cap and then they
earn about 5% yield on that which is a
lot of money um there's two problems
with this 8 billion though uh one this 8
billion is extracted from the ecosystem
and two because of the duopoly we are
compromising on decentralization and
censorship
resistance let's start with the ladder
so a duopoly controlling critical
infrastructure like this is very
dangerous um for three reasons a dwo
gives single points of failure it can
get lazy or greedy and it breaks
censorship resistance let's dive into
each a little bit closer um so when the
uh usdc deack happened during the svb
bank run we saw that there was a huge
liquidity crunch on Unis Swap and curve
and basically most tokens became
untradeable during that period this is
an existential threat to the ecosystem
because if everything breaks down if one
of these stable coins go down you end up
with a
problem secondly uh a dual can get lazy
or greedy when the risk-free rate was
about 5% tether was making 8% so they're
doing something with the assets backing
your stable coins that is more risky and
could result in it going
unstable and just because they want to
make $80 every th000 uh dollars of usdt
out there third a duopoly breaks
censorship resistance this is something
that falic highlighted a couple of years
ago basically whenever eth needs to do a
contested hard Fork uh Circle and tether
could decide which one is going to be
the canonical one and to be honest a
defy that depends on two companies is
decentralized in name
only how about that 8 billion and how
it's extracted from the ecosystem can we
reclaim it as an industry um can we use
these billions for something better than
uh basically having Circle and tether uh
by islands and jet
packs after all holding usdt is funding
tether at no cost if we would take that
8 billion uh that they are earning and
we distribute it equally amongst all of
the Devcon attendees this year every
single one of them would get 600k that's
a ton of money we can do something
much better with it unfortunately giving
the profits directly to you is il legal
in most countries so we need to find
something else we could fund the
ecosystem we could pay 50 times ethereum
Foundation yearly budget with that uh or
75 times optimism's retr funding
spending today or triple all ethereum
validators income cover all ops
expensive expenses of l2s we could
outspend the Pharma Lobby which is the
largest Lobby on the planet and still
have two billion left that two billion
we could then direct into things that
improve the state of the planet and have
crypto in a good light for once and
graduate from a cockroach of the economy
to a flagship through Lifting for
instance people out of extreme poverty
providing meals or buying malaria
Nets so next time you're faced with
using a stable coin you can choose
between big stable coin which keeps all
the yields and buys Islands or you could
use a yield bearing stable which is
illegal in most countries and thus
forced offshore which is riskier or you
could choose glow dollar a US issued and
regulated stable coin that uses its
profits to fund public goods and
Charities um so after all low dollar is
funding public goods at no cost so we
call this autop pgf automatic public
goods funding at zero cost uh we're
already doing this so we fund
organizations like protocol Guild uh
gitcoin optimism retr funding cell
public goods endowment give it every
month uh we started this a year oh sorry
uh you can do this in our dap uh and you
can just easily select but after you
collected your connected your wallet you
can select options like optimism retr
funding um we started this a year ago in
the first month we donated
$150 this uh month we're donating 44,000
so that's a pretty Healthy Growth uh in
a year after this talk I hope you help
us capture 1% of the stable coin market
after which we would be able to donate
six million uh uh to projects within the
ecosystem every month um how can you do
this you can start by diversifying your
usdt and usdc holdings start with 10%
today ramp it up to 100% % by the end of
the year you can ask your employer to be
paid in a different uh stable or you
could integrate glow Dollar in your depb
directly um I hope uh you are as excited
as I am about reclaiming our 8 billion
and that you'll start funding public
goods within uh the crypto ecosystem
with me thank
you thank you gar
um it's a very cool project I need to
say anyone with in audience with okay uh
the gentlem in the red
shirt catch it catch
it uh could you talk a little bit more
about how holders choose which public
goods the funds go to and how might that
change at scale um sure yeah so it's
very easy you go to app. Glow dollar.org
there you connect your wallets based on
how many glow dollars you have you will
see an amount of funds that that will
generate on a yearly basis then you can
choose recipients uh we currently have
eight in a list these can be either
causes so for instance uh web free
public goods or individual recipients
like uh giveth um and then uh if you add
them to your bucket of recipients you
want to have you can choose which
percentage each is going to get let's
say you want to do 50/50 then uh you
sign a message we uh store it and then
at the end of the month we tally
everything up and donate it to the uh
relevant organizations
cool do we have other questions in the
audience one in the back
yes hi there great presentation I just
wondered if there if you could outline
if there's any uh differences of a
negative variety between the main stable
coins and what you're doing I mean is
there any would there be any
disadvantage in using glow dollar what's
the biggest challenge for that well um
of course there are some disadvantages
but at its core it's just a similar um
stable coin as usdc we are us issued
100% Fiat backed by cash and us
treasuries we follow the same license
model so it's the same sort of risk
framework um that said we are not as
ubiquitous as usdc so you might not be
able to use it at all exchanges or in
your favorite dii platforms uh but you
can hold it in exactly the same way in
your wallet as you do use DC great thank
you very
much we have time for one more more
question anyone okay over there hey what
type of organization is glow dollar is a
nonprofit glow dollar is currently
structured as a nonprofit that means
that we do not have the exact uh 501c3
status in the US yet but we are what's
called a non-stock corporation uh that
means that there is no equity there's no
token there's just directors and then
within our um um statutes of the
organization It also says that we cannot
distribute dividends um or anything of
that kind we can only distribute
salaries and we are working on becoming
an actual nonprofit in the near
future cool actually still a little bit
of time left any more questions from the
audience anyone if not thank you gar
thank you so much for the sharing today
now we are taking another mini break for
one minute and then I'll come back to
welcome our last speaker of the day
[Music]
t
o
[Music]
yay this is our last session of the
day uh we have Chris as our speaker and
he's GNA talk about cult truth values
and a bubble let's welcome
[Music]
Chris hello hello can you hear me well
all right that's not the actual title
but that is the actual ual title so yeah
originally this presentation was
intended as something more technical but
now I found it actually more interesting
to bring something more humanistic here
to this stage and this title might sound
confusing and I'll try to cover a lot of
ground here and I'm very excited to do
that with you together today so a bit of
a prease so yeah my background here is
quite diverse um so I used to be a
software engineer for a while um I used
to work in research and a bit more in a
coordinative perspective but I'll
actually get right into it to give you a
bit more of that so values I'll start
with talking about values of individuals
in the ecosystem and how I perceive
different people here and how where I
allocate myself as well and then give
you a bit more of a landscape of yeah
different companies different parts of
the ecosystem in this value um framework
then I'll talk a bit about economical
and political games truth Cults the
bubble and I'll try to tie it all
together at the end even though it might
sound confusing now it will like make a
lot more sense when I go into
it so I like to ask myself the question
a lot is why what's actually my
motivation why I'm here and what is the
motivation why other people are here and
so to put it in a very simple framework
I realized most people can be described
in this kind of triangle so either
people care a lot about decentralization
in the space people enjoy fun in the
community or people care a lot about
monetary gain and often that gets a bit
dis disguised or it's not very clear and
so it's really nice to have very direct
conversations with people about that and
for me personally has been a bit like
that so I started with a a lot of
idealism I realized at some point
there's also a lot of money to be made
here which is often not directly talking
about that much but in the end I stayed
because of the people and the community
and I'm slowly going back towards more
idealism and impact but if we look at
the space overall actually it makes
sense to extend this framework a bit and
add one more the intellectual challenge
which is very interesting for a lot of
us here and so if we do that and we try
to map the space a bit so then we get to
a landscape which looks a bit like this
and for me that was pretty interesting
to just allocate different parts of the
ecosystem and also see like where does
it fit where could I personally fit with
my values and this is not the full truth
but I found it really interesting to to
map the landscape a bit like that and
maybe that's helpful or interesting to
one of
you yeah continuing here towards the the
games we're playing the economic games
in the ecosystem so there was a really
good talk recently this week by kristofh
schel from flash Bots where actually in
a market structure where there's a lot
of private value for example private
order flow the stable equilibrium is
actually a full Monopoly which is the
opposite of decentralization do we want
that let's look at what the market
actually looks like for example here the
Builder Market some of you might know
it's a duopoly basically at the moment
but in a equilibrium actually it would
be a full-on monopoly and why is that
like that or for example looking at how
order flow works also here it would be
basically equilibrium of like one party
controlling all of order flow but
actually it looks more like this like a
very complex structure so that means in
the background there's a lot more
political games happening than we are
aware of it's very interesting to
observe those once you're like a bit
deeper into the space and the question
is how do we not devour ourselves in
this like internal political Warfare but
actually focus on the issues we care
about open question for now might get
back to that so another angle to look at
this is like what do we trust in in the
space so here we can put it under
another framework so I feel like the
space emerged a lot from losing trust in
government institutions then trusting
more in protocol and code
or do we actually just trust ourselves
because often we have this overemphasis
on just wanting to trust the protocol
the code something predictable but maybe
there's something else and so I yeah
kind of ended up with this nice midwit
diagram I really like those so some of
us really work hard I used to really
work hard and want to save the world but
in the end Also let's have some fun
let's not be too serious in this space
but also really just enjoy ourselves
once in a while and so one question that
arose in my Reflections there is if you
just have fun sometimes crypto feels
like a big big playground of technology
and do we then still actually care about
issues or do we just become chill and
have yeah just have fun do nothing to
change the world for me actually it's
more the way if we can relax a bit if we
don't have to have these like political
warfar for example stuff
like like this then we can actually be
more united and aligned in the ecosystem
over
all and so to continue from
here what are actually if we look at
ourselves really reflect deeply on
emotional space our needs as humans here
like what do we actually care about why
are we here and what makes us happy for
me actually it's really mostly about the
people and to be more seen as like a
whole human being to be sometimes
confidently insecure and not know things
that's something which really fulfills
me and that's also a reason why things
like this place here as a conference but
for me it more of a than a conference
with the Cozy spaces the smaller groups
or popup cities have been th thriving
where you actually get a feeling of
community but then also there's other
dangers there if we become such a closed
ecosystem of like Community really close
to each other but then they can also be
you see myself there at subin for
example it can sometimes become almost
cult-like we have we're like a bubble in
ourselves so what about this vibe that
the whole ecosystem feels a bit like a
bubble with its own language and we
don't actually know how to talk anymore
with the outside world is that a danger
as well and so I realized in a very
interesting conversation with Phil Dian
that the world is actually watching us a
lot more closely than we think um for
example the New York fed recently
published a paper in August where they
were looking at tornado cach sanctions
and I was astonished by the amount of
detail how they actually understand the
Builder landscape and the graphs I
showed you before so I think it's also
time to start talking to this world and
not only see them as the enemy but maybe
find a more collaborative approach there
so to conclude based on all of this
we're in a complex space here
but sometimes you're a bit too too much
stuck in your head because we try to
build protocols which predict every
single edge case but by evaluating
things we can also trust more our
intuition be humans be vulnerable be
stupid like I often also have this
imposter syndrome even though we work
really close with ethereum researchers
and we like very deep in the ecosystem
that like I know nothing but all of us
sometimes feel like that and even though
we can still create things we can dare
to also be on stage once in a while like
myself here and sometimes peek outside
of the bubble talk to people outside of
the space try to speak their language
and put things in like simple words and
simple Frameworks like I Tred to do it
here today thank you thank
you hi
good to have you here any questions um I
do have one like what do you think is
the way for us to break out of the
bubble because it's the language is so
different you know how do we start like
understand where other people come from
like start from the other person's
starting point bring bring bring things
in into really simple words simple
language find analogies from other
people's world and to describe it from
there and then bring them closer in is
that how un your
mom yeah I'm still struggling with that
but I'm making some progress slowly my
dad is easier cool uh do we have any uh
question from the
audience any
question I guess we can have discussion
privately after this cool happy to talk
later thank you so much thank you
[Applause]
amazing we're finally coming to an end
of our session today congrats everyone
this is the third day of Decon tomorrow
will be the last day wo or not uh we'll
be back here tomorrow and I'll see you
here bye guys
[Music]
you m
oh
[Music]
oo
o oh
[Music]
sh
bu bu bu bu oh
[Music]
o
oh
[Music]
he